Thank you.
Oh shit.
Oh, I forgot.
Okay, sorry.
I might be on loading screen.
All right, there you go.
Hey, hello, everyone.
Hello.
Merry Christmas, everyone.
Merry Christmas.
Welcome to my Christmas party, guys.
I was like, I got everything set up.
Oh my, I'm so prepared.
And I looked, I was like, oh, I'm not moving.
As you guys see, I have custody of both the Twitch goons and
the YouTube goons right here.
custody of both of you guys at the same time.
It's very rare right here.
And I have to sit in the middle to make sure you guys do not
touch.
I have to make sure that you too do not touch or I will get
bad.
So I shall sit here in the middle in between you two.
Yeah, hello.
Merry Christmas, everyone.
Yes, we're doing multistream.
Uh, for the first time, well, I mean, I did do it for, um, I
think it was for Bandai, uh, but that was not on my channel.
This is the first time I had to do it on my channel, so it's
like, I, I, I've been, like, working on the stream stuff
since, for like, five to six hours.
Making sure everything is okay.
I don't want to get bad or anything.
Um, hands up, Twitch goods.
Fight, fight, fight, fight.
You're sipping on my, sipping.
on my eggnog watching my children fight each other during
Christmas.
What a wonderful holiday.
Like five feet apart because we're not allowed.
Because we're not gay.
Who's your favorite chat?
I love both children equally, guys.
I love you both equally.
Here.
I love both my children equally, guys.
Anyway, so for those who don't know, this is my first time
doing a multi-stream on both channels.
This is going to be a very rare occasion.
I will not be doing this very frequently or very often.
Maybe, like, for special events such as this.
Because I figured, you know, it's Christmas.
stream uh for today uh for those who are maybe spending the
holidays alone or you know they want end their christmas or
they want to start their christmas holiday with me uh you
drop in and out i'll be streaming i think at most i'll be
aiming for 11 hours so i'll be throughout the day you can
drop in or drop out whenever you want uh we do have a
schedule a christmas schedule also for some reason okay i
i've been trying to figure out like um what what plugin to
use for multi-chats that I can read, but it looks like the
YouTube one is overpowering the Twitch chatters.
Because I, so, because it's like all red, and I'm like,
where are the purple chat?
But then I swapped it, like, my dashboard on the Twitch
side, but I can see you guys chatting, but, like, the
YouTuber, the YouTube chat is, like, overtaking the entire
plugin.
As it's we need enforcement quick dragons um uh dial thank
you for the super chat thank you thank you it's not gay the
orbs don't touch um but yeah unless someone has oh i see it
i see someone i see someone i see um oh it was a re it was a
resub okay i still resub pushed through the barriers of you
too okay this is what i see okay i'll show you guys what i
see on my side it's so weird It's so weird doing multi.
I'm sure I've been like Googling everything to find out
figure out like What is the best like plug-in for
multi-chat, but like everybody gave like different answers
So I don't know.
I don't know which plug-in is the best for For like to read
both channels.
All right, here you go.
I'll show you guys what I see This poor guy Okay, here it
is.
Oh, yeah what I see on my side because I'm like where the
fuck are the twitch shatters and I turn her and I look over
to like the actual twitch dashboard and you guys are here
you guys are typing like it's just like he broke the barrier
oh shit here you go here I need to make sure you're not
covered too I need to make sure I forgot I can't cover up
twitch that
yeah oh wait oh twitch came oh my god it's overpowering now
oh you guys broke through for like one second no he guys
broke through for one second it got all purple for one
second uh no uh you can have both chats um on the same they
it's it's very okay i'll let you guys know this it's like
weird twitch has like these vague rules on purpose so that
they can like like pick and choose stuff like what they want
to like enforce and everything so basically um the rules are
very hard to understand because they're so vague so and they
didn't update it i think but basically you can have both
chats on the screen but they just can't touch each other so
they can be like or like it's very distinguishable that, um,
it's very distinguishable that they're, they're like
different chats.
So you can see that the YouTube chat looks different from
the Twitch chat, uh, because if, if it wasn't allowed, then
all live YouTubers would have been banned off of Twitch
because they have both chats showing on their streams.
Um, and, and also like I've noticed like, that's why they're
like super, uh, super vague on purpose.
So they can like basically pick and choose what they want to
do.
um yeah so that's why like that's why like we can do this a
lot of vtubers would have been banned a lot of the
multi-stream vtubers would have been banned if um um if like
you know if i it wasn't allowed to have both chats
multi-streamed YouTubers also do both chats on the same on
the same screen.
They just have to it just has to be distinguishable.
Yeah.
It has to be like fucking distinguishable in between like
what is Twitch chat which is what is YouTube chat.
And look it is.
So if any staff is watching YouTube chat has a Santa hat.
Twitch chat has a I guess a Christmas hat with a little
Christmas tree.
switch and also twitch chat is sitting to my right and
youtube chat is sitting to my left and also they're also
different css codes so you cannot confuse them with each
other i've seen streamers who combine both yeah some of them
got banned you're not allowed to combine both i was watching
a video of a semi big streamer and like not it wasn't like
super big he was like you know like streaming and he was
like oh yeah i thought i was allowed to have both chats
combined um but then i got i got a suspension so he's like
yeah don't do that guys i thought they wouldn't catch me but
they did like he's like i thought i wasn't big enough to get
caught but i did get caught so um so don't do it guys i was
like okay i need to make sure we don't combine them where
they don't touch each other uh w thank you for the akasupa
thank you thank you merry christmas toky and dragons thank
Thank you to the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Luffy, thank you for tier one.
So thank you.
This is like so confusing for me.
Kind of like thinking.
It's so weird.
I think like my multi-chat is like having trouble handling,
grabbing from both sides.
I'm just getting fucked.
Like, oh my gosh.
There has to be a better plug in for this.
No, it's okay.
It's okay.
It was like five seconds where I showed them combined, guys.
Look, see?
They're both sitting on opposite sides of each other.
But yeah, like I said, I want it to do, um, I want it, don't
worry, left side, now my Twitch chat is on my left monitor,
my YouTube chat is on my right monitor, so this is how I'm
going to distinguish.
I, I, it sucks that I can't have you all together for me to
look at, but, um, that you two are fighting each other, and,
uh, it depends on who is typing the most to break through
the barriers.
To thank you for the Twitch Prime, thank you, thank you.
Yeah, the multi-chats having a...
It's literally a fight right now.
It's like red versus blue right now on my multi-chat screen.
Let's see.
Bite size.
Thank you for the magenta soup, but thank you.
Merry Christmas, dokey.
My parents surprised me with retro dokey.
Christmas ornaments.
So now you have a permanent place on the Christmas tree.
Thank you for the magenta soup, but thank you.
Oh my god, that's so cute.
it's really thoughtful your parents i hope yeah thank you
again for the magenta soup but thank you thank you i hope
you guys all have been having a wonderful christmas
especially if you're on the other side of the world because
you guys already celebrated christmas um time zones are
weird like that you guys are in the fucking future right now
um but um but yeah i hope you guys are having a great
christmas right now or had a great christmas if not i hope
you guys have one time with me today on christmas um but yes
i will be drinking later on in the middle of the stream um
you know for the holiday cheer uh so we will have like a
little intermission where i grab food and also a drink as
well um and uh but you bet we have a long day plan today
like i said i'm gonna aim for 11 hours so here is the
today's schedule um i hope the multi-stream thing is not too
scuffed because like i said it is my first time doing
multi-stream and um i've been working on stream stuff for
like six plus hours setting everything up and making sure
you do not you two do not touch each other
i do not want you two to fight uh frail thank you for the
akasupa thank you thank you hey merry christmas or whatever
where's my christmas raccoon frail She has been sending me
raccoons for, it's crazy.
I can go to the DMs and I will just keep scrolling and
scroll.
It's just never ending.
It really, it's never ending of raccoons on my fucking DMs.
But yet, but yet you didn't send me a Christmas raccoon,
bro.
Yeah, where's the Christmas raccoon?
That's what this side is, the sexier side.
Don't Fight, fight, fight, fight
Oh yeah, but I remember I was going to show you guys the
skin Oh god, I need to make sure I don't Okay, I got to put
it in the middle I got to make sure You both are shown There
we go Here you go, I got to make sure none of you guys are
covered So I'll cover myself Oh my god, okay YouTube doesn't
ban me if I don't show you I'm sorry YouTube look i'm not
playing favorites it's that it's just that one child will
kick your mom out of the house okay and it's not you youtube
okay so i got it look i'm not playing favorites i'm just
following the rules i'm so anyway um like we're start we
start we do a little intro and then and then later oh my god
i want to play the spelling bee roblox you guys have to
suggest me some games because i forgot i i'm not showing the
browser of us browsing games because i'm scared
so so you guys are gonna suggest me some stuff to do um and
um i spent way too much time doing stupid bits for this
stream i just need you guys to know that it doesn't even
last that long to the bits they just last like it's like i
swear to god i think i spent like four hours doing stupid
fucking bits for like like a five minute segment
so oh my god you guys better laugh sweet and god anyway
anyway then after roblox after roblox we're gonna either
play what do whatever you guys want or we do the climbing
game because i promise you guys i would fucking beat that i
don't think we're gonna beat in an hour but an hour 30
minutes know we could make progress we can make progress on
it um and then we're gonna go karaoke christmas karaoke i
need to figure out i i realized oh i know one song i'm gonna
sing i'll give you guys i'll give you guys a little spoiler
bum bitty bitty bitty bum bum i don't even know if you have
the instrumental bum bitty bitty bitty bum Bum bitty bitty
bitty bum bum And then Fortnite and Minecraft server So
we're going to browse random free SMP servers So like I said
I picked games where I know that Also I'm going to, sorry,
look little Timmy Sorry little Yimmy You're Timmy and you're
Yimmy
That's how I named my twins guys timmy t for twitch yimmy y
for youtube anyway um i try to pick games that were either
free to play or um or um a lot of people own acts have
access to it so what kind of name is yimmy look i'm sorry
yimmy but timmy was born first okay timmy is five seconds
older than you so when he was saw Timmy and was like, you're
Timmy.
And then the doctor was like, oh, it's twins.
And then so, so I was like, God, I don't know.
Yimmy.
So Timmy, Yimmy.
Master Chief, thank you for the five gifted selves.
Thank you.
Timmy was abandoned for three years.
He doesn't count.
He's the first, Yemi.
He was still first.
But wait.
Yeah, respect your elders, Yemi.
Anyway, anyway, so we're going to go by honor system.
But I don't play favorites, guys.
I did abandon Timmy for three years, Yemi.
Okay?
Look, look at how, how, how starved.
Like, look, he's starving.
Timmy's starving, Yimmy.
Where did Timmy go?
Wait, wait, oh, there.
That's like, Timmy, are you alive?
Where, that's gonna say, what is Timmy not working?
Okay, Timmy's alive.
Timmy is breathing right now.
Um, but look, look, Yimmy.
when was the last time we fed timmy yimmy it was like i
don't even remember when was the last time we fed timmy uh
so um like i said uh we're gonna do honor systems for the
game so if you're able to get into one of the games please
let other dragoons have a chance to join in on the games and
you guard timmy and yimmy you two are allowed to snitch on
each other so timmy if you see Yumi, uh, Yumi being in
another game, and you're like, wait, you were in the last
game, feel free to snitch on Yumi.
Timmy, you too, if you see, sorry, wait, Yumi, you too,
Yumi, if you see Timmy, um, in a game before, and you're
like, you're, you already played one game, feel free to
snitch on Timmy.
So, uh, just let me know, and then we'll kick them out.
We don't even look the same.
That's why I gave you, of course not.
That's why I gave you two different hats.
Guys, it's so I can distinguish between you two.
So I know which is which.
I swear to God, parents who give their twins, like give
their twins slash triplets the same clothes.
Like, what the fuck is wrong with you?
like I don't know maybe they can tell who's who but still
like bro just give them different clothes like why do you
want them to match like it's already hard enough anyway uh
we're gonna go crash on some random free you know how
there's like Minecraft SMP servers that are free to join
we're gonna crash some of them well I'll try to look up some
Minecraft servers and then we'll um we'll like we'll raid it
I don't know we'll play like we'll grab a Bedwars server or
something I want to play it.
Oh my I wish I could play like the Minecraft hunger game
servers, but But I know you guys are all just gonna fucking
stream snipe me on I on both streams You guys pull up both
streams to see which one is like has the lowest latency and
then stream snipe me I so most likely we will not do my
Minecraft hunger games, but I do want to do the oh my god I
want I want to go to the parkour civilization server.
I want to try that up we're gonna go with Marvel Rivals
we're gonna play a couple of Marvel Rivals I don't know
maybe it'll just be like game or two and then we'll do
something else but like um I do want to play just a little
bit uh because like um because I haven't played in a while
and also good night we ended off on good night dragoons chat
so we're gonna end it off with that like I said we're gonna
try to do 11 hours uh today which is very long for me um so
i should have taken a nap before this stream just so i can
build up my energy uh but i really wanted to like do some
funny shit on my stream like customize some make some funny
assets and stuff like that uh for today's stream because
today's a special stream it is a christmas stream so i i end
up just working on stream stuff for the last six hours i
mean i should have done it Yesterday, but I literally went
straight to bed yesterday because I was so fucking tired Um,
so, uh, so I woke up early.
I literally woke up early and just went straight into like
working on stream stuff Um, but yeah, it's gonna be a fun a
fun, uh, Christmas for everyone.
Uh, I hope so Uh, yeah, so, uh, yeah, the karaoke will be
archived.
Um, I will try to sing the royalty free song I'm going to
sing the songs that are maybe royalty-free because we're
Christmas caroling today.
You two will be helping me, too, for the Christmas carols,
Timmy and Yumi.
We gotta go earn some extra money, you know, because you
guys want Christmas presents, right, Timmy and Yumi?
So y'all go Christmas caroling with Mama to earn your
Christmas presents.
thank you gotta go to oh thank you for the akasupa thank you
thank you gotta go to family christmas but just want to wish
you all and all the dragons a merry christmas can't think of
a community rather be part of and the best ocean dragon
could ask for thank you thank you thank you for the akasupa
thank you thank you also man thank you for the 110 biddies
thank you thank you merry christmas toky thank you merry
christmas to you i want some ram sticks what tooth okay who
said bad, Yimmy.
Santa's been busy using AI.
You think Rab grows on trees?
Yeah, Yimmy.
Even Santa?
Oh my god, did you guys see them?
Okay, I know like, you know, okay, like we all have our
opinions about AI, but I missed when AI was first being
introduced and people were just using that to like create
dumb fucking dumb shit like you know Like just dumb memes
and shitposts and stuff now.
It's like a little bit problematic But back then when AI was
starting, you know, like the fucking ash baby is actually AI
I loved how when people found out the ash baby meme was AI
and some like I remember I saw a tweet and people were like
Would you do you really think they fucking burned a child
and Like, they buried, they buried a child, a real child is
ash.
A fucking course is AI.
Yes, it's AI.
It's, it's like AI.
They generate a bunch of babies, like, screaming in ash.
So, um, my world is a lot.
So, um, it could be, that is true.
It could be Photoshop, too.
Um, uh, but it what it is AI generated for those who don't
know um um but anyway so I thought it was really funny but
uh it is it is pretty problematic but I thought it was
really funny for Christmas time that parents are using AI to
like to like generate Santa into their photos to fuck with
the children like some parent was like can't wait to tell
the children that they missed Santa and then they fucking
knew the AI generated Santa putting presents under the tree
yeah so they're like what it makes them believe in Santa
they're like oh my god Santa is fucking real Santa came and
freak brought presents down like I'd be so hurt yeah but the
child wouldn't know it's AI children don't know what AI is
and just stop all right i think it's better than what the i
don't know you guys remember this but i think okay i think
tricking children into believing in santa with ai is more
more is more morally okay than when parents were telling
children that they didn't get them any christmas presents
and also when they ate all their candy and then have it all
filmed on camera and then sent over to Jimmy Fallon.
Or was it?
I think that is a lot worse.
Because that was a thing a couple of years ago where Jimmy
Fallon was like, parents, record yourself telling your kids
that they're not getting any Christmas presents this year.
And also that time when he was like, Parents record your
children record telling your children that you ate all their
Halloween candy And then it was broadcasted on national TV
everywhere and also YouTube groups too Yeah, yeah, and also
it has like millions of views on YouTube as well Like you
can literally look it up on YouTube right now.
It's like it's like Jimmy Fallon Halloween candy or some
shit And people were like, oh my god, it's so, I think, I
think tricking children and thinking Santa is real is a bit
better than the thing they did with Jimmy Fallon.
Like, it was, it was a lot, yeah, it's like the therapy is
going to be so expensive in the future for them.
It's what a Jimmy Someone was like maybe isn't it the other
Jimmy I got confused It really is really hard when like
Celebrities share the The same fucking name It's like the
Chris's It's like which Chris are you talking about Chris
Pat, Chris Evans Um Um The third Chris And the fourth Chris
I'm sorry I can't remember the third and fourth Chris On the
top of my head right now
I just remembered Pratt, Hemsworth, sorry, Chris Hemsworth,
to be fair, I feel like, no, he did do the, he did do the,
what movie was it, Furiosa movie, Mad Max movie recently, oh
yeah, Chris Tucker, Chris Brown, Chris Farley, Chris Evans,
I don't know why I said Evans like five times,
Did you know like Chris Rock isn't a, everybody hates Chris,
isn't a documentary about Chris Rock's life?
I, it blew my mind.
I was like, what do you mean Chris doesn't have a little,
like Chris doesn't have like, like Chris Rock's life isn't
like Chris, Chris Rock and everybody hates Chris.
I was like, what the fuck?
I felt like I had trust issues.
No, he made up family members, too, in the show.
I know.
We've all been lied, too.
Oh,
yeah.
And also, like, for the AI stuff.
Oh, wait.
I'll show you guys the photo.
Let me see if I, like, saved it.
It's actually pretty fucking funny.
Oh, here we go.
I was like I was like Oh my god That's so fucked up It's
like telling my children They just missed Santa And then
fucking AI generated And fucking Santa That's like crazy
New ways to lie I'm sorry Yumi New ways to lie to your kids
Like Like
It looks so short.
There's another one.
Let's see.
I went with the ring doorbell.
Oh my god.
That's like crazy.
Look at this one.
Jeez, the eye is so fucking scary.
They fucking got a photo of their ring.
Ring camera and fucking AI generated Santa into the ring
camera shit.
That's fucking insane.
Santa in the home.
Yeah, I know.
AI is so scary now.
Because it's always growing.
Yeah, I would fall.
Bro, if I was a child, I would fall for it too.
Like, that shit is so real.
Not not surreal.
Yeah, why would he go through the front door.
Is he stupid or something?
This is why we can't have Ram Bros.
Santa stole all the Ram.
stole all the Ram.
But this isn't worth the Ram's shortness.
Guys, I'm pretty sure it's not the parents AI generating
Santa.
That's fucking why.
the ram shortage
oh duck thank you for the twitch prime thank you thank you
chris thank you for the 10 gift of ships thank you thank you
yeah no i think so i think like like in a year or two um i
progressed so much i remember when people were like oh oh my
god did you see the crate okay did you see okay some of you
guys might not have seen this like uh drama um but i was so
curious about it because popped up on my for you page and
there was like this drama about like art tracing and like
apparently you can like you can like trace over like artwork
with green lines or something so when you record it uh the
green lines do not like trace over like ai art and then like
you can green screen um the line art if it's green and so it
won't show up in the recording and i was like what the
no it was showing up in my four you everyone was looking
talking about this shit and i was like what the fuck is
going on and then like and they were like here's how you do
it and literally this this guy was like all right so just so
just like overlay the thing you want to trace with So when
you're recording it, when you're recording the video, you're
drawing this thing, you can, like, it will not show, it will
not show up because it's green, because the camera will
delete the green from your footage.
And I'm like, what the fuck?
Fucking my day.
You just hide the, you just hide the layer.
But now, now there's fucking, now you can like just record,
like, delete the green.
off of your footage?
Like, that's so fucking complicated.
That's crazy.
That's so much effort just to, like, not get, trying to not
get caught.
Yeah, they just chroma keyed it out.
No, it's basically like they, okay, so like, you know how
regular tracing you just like you just like get a file you
want to you get like an artwork you want to trace and then
turn the opacity down and then just like draw on top of it
so what people do now which is incredible like which is like
it's like apparently a super common thing too uh because
usually when they're like oh show proof that you drew this
thing they'll like record themselves drawing it so um so
what people do to like not get caught is that i guess like
through uh is that like overlay the artwork that they want
to trace with green so you can chroma key it out from the
fucking video so i was like i'm like geez that's so much
effort i know i was like what you can chrome you chroma key
out the green artwork that you overlaid so that it only
shows the liner
It is.
It's so much work.
I can't think of the tier one.
Get the tier one sub.
Thank you.
That's crazy.
That's why AI is fucking crazy now.
I cannot keep up.
I literally can't.
Oh my god.
Also recently, I've been, um, oh, oh, sorry, uh, I, like,
stopped a little bit, uh, recently, I've been, uh, looking
through that, you know, there's, like, a Twitter trend right
now where people look through, like, IMDb's season ratings
for each episode, and then people were, like, posting, like,
summaries of, like, children's shows, like, Dora the
Explorer, and...
Thomas the tank engine and stuff like that and then I love
there's like this guy who was like super obsessed with
Thomas the tank engine like that's like his like hyper
fixation
it's like and then he was like then someone asked him um
here I was I'll post it here so someone asked him like oh i
wonder why like season 12 and 16 was so bad and he was
literally like every episode is is bad it's slop and like he
has like all the knowledge of thomas to take engine the
fucking show like it has by the way it has like what is how
many seasons oh my god a lot of seasons like 20 plus seasons
yeah of all like i mean he likes trains i would to be fair i
think i think it's because like i think it's because he just
has a very hyper fixation on trains in general um but yeah
no it's been going on for fucking decades and i like how
someone was like and then someone posted the game of thrones
uh this is why i would never watch game of thrones like
someone posted a Game of Thrones summary thing where they're
like um where it was really sad because it was like 8 to 9 9
basically for their reviews slash ratings for Game of
Thrones and the very last episode was like 4.4 if you were
like it was literally like 8 8.5 8.7 9 9.9 9.3 of the season
of the series 4.4 and like so I'm like thinking like people
I'm like bro like why fuck would I commit to Game of Thrones
where where it where apparently the last episode is so
fucking bad that like it literally killed the franchise like
oh I didn't kill the franchise because we still have the
dragon show or whatever but like like the hype literally
died because It's like, it's so, apparently it's so bad That
like, that like, it just felt like you committed all that
time to watching the show Just to have, like, just to have
it like fall apart And like, apparently the reason why it
was so bad Was because the creators, the showrunners No, the
showrunners went to Star Wars right after showrunners like
Star Wars and yeah they wanted to write yeah they wanted to
write the fucking Star Wars sequel so they like fucked over
Game of Thrones they like rushed Game of Thrones to like go
to Star Wars and then their show got wait their show got
cancelled oh my bro and then their fucking show got
cancelled holy shit that's so sad dude bro they so they at
least they did to be fair they don't need to ruin Star Wars
because they're already they're already doing it um jade
thank you for the hundred biddies thank you thank you sam
welcome to tomato farm welcome
i will i to be fair like they don't need to do much to ruin
star wars they already oh my god it was like i never watched
the last was it the last star wars movie all right here my
when i read this i only watched the first one the first star
the first uh sequel it was reboot for the Star Wars films
was it reboot okay what is it called like the the what is it
called the sequel sequel like is it the um the one with Kylo
Ren yeah so um I know like the first part of the film like
the first movie because it's a trilogy yeah the array
trilogy and then there's like a there's like a clip of of
like a movie theater trying to like watching the last movie
and then everyone was like no i hate star wars and then the
credit rules because apparently my life spoiler but it's a
good that i'm spoiling you guys by the way because it's
apparently a really bad film um um ray the main character
was like everyone was thinking she'll be like was it
palpatine's daughter or some or like great granddaughter or
something and people were super disappointed that she ended
up being a fucking Skywalker like another Skywalker and um
and like I think it's really weird that Finn the
stormtrooper wasn't a fucking Jedi like I thought
oh wait she's like oh like she's yeah but she's pal wait
she's palpatine's clone
Why the fuck is she like, I'm a Skywalker?
Why the fuck did she say that?
Like, I guess she's ashamed of her fucking name, I guess.
That's so weird.
I think it would have been better if she, like, kept
Palpatine's name and, like, try and, like, yeah, she just
called herself.
Yeah, okay, that's just weird that she fucking called
herself Skywalker, that she just renamed herself like that.
like i said i didn't watch it but i was just like reading
the summary and people were like mad that she called herself
a skywalker so i was really confused i was like she's a
skywalker but i felt like ben should have been ben should
have been like uh had like force powers like actual force
power it was just weird like like in the first movie he's
like i have the i'm holding the lightsaber um Like, you
know, and I'm like, oh, he's force sensitive.
And then they just, apparently they just didn't do anything
with that.
And I was like, and then people were like, yeah, he's not a
Jedi.
I'm like, how is he not a Jedi?
In the first movie, he literally held the fucking, the
fucking lightsaber.
Oh, he had low sensitivity to the force.
He literally teleported the fucking lightsaber.
How the fuck is he have low sensitivity?
It's not a key.
Like, so key.
Was it not?
No, he doesn't have to ask Kyle.
Did he, like, fucking him?
Anyway.
Anyway, I only watched the first film because, like, I heard
the second and third one didn't go so well.
Oh, yeah.
And I'm sad that, like, in the Mandalorian, like, they're
making...
They're making Pedro Pascal show his face more, but I'm
like, that's not...
That's not it.
Wait, was the trilogy made by three different directors?
That's stupid.
That's actually stupid.
Why the fuck has it been made by three separate directors?
Wait, two?
It's like, it's like Guardians of the, I like how I'm just
spreading misinformation about Star Wars.
People were like, that didn't happen with Finn.
I'm like, really?
Oh, whoops.
Just casually spreading misinformation.
It happened in my head, okay?
It's not misinformation if I believe it in my heart.
believe it in my heart it's not misinformation in my head
it's canon exactly possible thank you for the five gift and
ships they can thank you jay thank you for the hundred
bitties thank you thank you okay i feel like it's just like
um i don't know yet anyone that follows like okay this is
what pissed me off about guardians of the galaxy because
guardians of the galaxy i love james gun when it comes to
his movies i think james gunn is a very good director and
really good at writing this before but he was the one that
he he was the one that wrote and direct i don't know if
direct as direct as well but he wrote the script for uh the
live action scooby-doo movies so i've always loved a lot of
the stuff he's done um and um i know like some people don't
like james gunn's stuff because like we were like snyder i'm
not snyder versus james gunn my personally like james gunn's
dc more than snyder's dc and i don't know if people are
gonna fucking try to execute me over that but i've i've been
more interested in james gunn's vision for dc than hit than
snyder's vision uh for dc um and um and basically um i what
i really didn't like about guardians of the galaxy is that
james gunn had like a thought out plan for the trilogy for
Guardians of the Galaxy and and then like you know they had
to do the Avengers stuff you know so you know they they
basically like messed up James Gunn's plan so that so like
he had to like fix it like they had to build off of the
Avengers movie um to like figure out what to do
All, like, messed up from that.
And I felt like that's why, like, three didn't feel as
strong as, like, the other movies.
Yeah, it had to align with the continuity.
Yeah, because all the Marvel movies are directed by
different directors.
Oh, look, there's Santa coming back.
Jake, thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you.
Tokyo Dragons just got back from making homemade cinnamon
rolls with fab just in time for a comfy stream with you guys
hope you all have a wonderful Christmas too thank you thank
you for the magenta soup thank you thank you uh Marshall
they give us a super chat thank you thank you release the
Snyder cut oh wait they did I didn't say that guys Snyder
fans don't come at me guys I want to say I think I've only
watched I think I've watched like one Snyder film and I was
like that ain't that ain't it.
Oh, yeah, it was super.
I did not let I know that I know like the Snyder fans are
super passionate about like the Snyder The Snyder Superman
movie, but I didn't fuck with the Snyder.
Oh my god, his name is so fucking hard to say The Snyder um
Superman movie.
I didn't I didn't like that one, but and then but I haven't
watched the James Gunn Superman movie, but James Gunn
Superman movie gave us the rage-baiting chimpanzees.
So I think I know who won.
I think I know which movie is better.
But when I first saw that scene, I thought it was fucking
AI.
I was like, there's no, what the fuck is this?
Superman.
Superman is a bitch.
Movie ratings based on memes.
It's like Timothy Chalamey in his movie.
Okay, I don't know, you guys, yo, Timothy Chalamey is, but
he's the guy that played the, Wanka movie and he's also the
one that's dating Kim Kardashian's sister.
That was crazy.
The fact that like he's literally dating, like he's in the
Kardashian family right now.
Like, yeah, and he's the one in Dune.
I didn't watch Dune, by the way.
So he's also the guy in Dune.
So for those who actually know what Dune is, um, and he's
like been like going around doing like a marketing thing for
his newest movie.
Uh, yeah, they're still dating.
Uh, but yeah, he's like doing the this marketing thing for
his newest movie and he's like doing a lot of crazy shit so
he's like doing collabs with like big streamers um like i
don't remember what who that streamer is because like i
don't watch him but it's like basically like uh doing like
giant collabs with huge streamers to advertise his movie he
clearly climbed up the fucking uh the orb in las vegas you
know the giant orb in las vegas he climbed up on top of it
to advertise this movie and he also fucking released a rap
collab he released the fucking uh rap song and did a collab
with someone that people thought was him just to be just to
advertise this new movie and like okay what the fuck is this
new movie like because like you know it's working the
marketing is working because he's doing all these freaking
crazy shit where you're like what the fuck is this movie
like what the fuck is going on why is he doing all of this
um and then i looked at the movie and it's about ping pong
like it has nothing to do with whatever the fuck he's like
but whatever his marketing campaign is working it's about
like some documentary about this guy playing ping pong like
it's some like drama documentary shit I was like, what the
fuck?
The movie is called Mighty Mike.
Yeah, it makes it look like it's like, I don't know.
I don't fucking know.
I don't even know what I expected.
I just didn't expect it to be about ping pong.
Like,
yeah.
Yeah, it worked.
It worked because I thought it was like, I don't know.
I just thought it was, it was just not ping pong.
That's all I thought about.
What's the rap song for?
Unrelated to the movie, apparently.
But he gave it a shout out.
The ultimate sport.
It worked though.
The marketing worked on me.
I was so fucking confused.
Dixie, welcome to Tomato Farm.
Welcome, welcome.
oh yeah and I read an interview from him and he was like oh
the reason why I'm doing all of this is that apparently he's
like a very forgettable like I guess so because like he's
like in a lot of movies but I can only remember him in two
movies and it's the and it's oh wait I can only remember him
in one movie and it's the Willy Wonka one and also the fact
that he's dating Kim Kardashian's sister um and that's like
literally the only thing I can like remember about Timothy
Shalemey.
But apparently, he does a lot of movies.
He wins like, oh, he wins like a lot.
He gets nominated for a bunch of stuff.
But he just has such a forgettable.
Like he's just like pretty forgettable in general, even
though he's really good at acting.
And so he's like, so that's why he's going like super hard
right now in marketing himself.
Because like people don't remember that he's on
Interstellar.
Interstellar?
I was like, he's an interseller?
Yeah, like, I was like, wait, he is?
Yeah, he's apparently, yeah, he's in that movie.
Yeah, wait, he was?
Yeah, people were like, he was like in the interview.
He's like, it pisses me off that people don't remember me
that.
Remember that I was in that movie.
And so that's why he's fucking going crazy right now in
marketing.
Because we're a fucking ping pong movie.
Like, yeah,
he can, he's so, he just has a sort of forgettable face.
No, he was like, the guy, the main character's son.
Don't insult.
Ping pong is intense to watch, though, I will say.
I don't remember.
Ping pong is very intense to watch.
I could never forget that face.
He's like a, he's like, just like, I guess like he's really
good at what he does.
It's just like he just doesn't, he's just not memorable for
me to remember him.
Yeah, he's a gamer, isn't he?
Doesn't he like, oh, doesn't he like game?
Oh yeah, speaking of, oh, and he, I know he loves basketball
and shit.
You see the NBA?
There's a thing where like, uh, we're like, um, They did
like a basketball simulation Where like It was like Disney
characters playing basketball Like I don't know Where it's
coming from Like what is this NBA's dunk the halls Like what
the fuck is this Yeah they did a space jam Yeah Disney
characters It's like crazy I was like what the fuck Am I
looking at Yeah Okay, let's see.
N-N-B-A.
Oh, here.
No, it's not IRL.
They did a simulation.
Let's see.
Let me make sure.
Yeah, my Chrome's not.
Oh, my God.
They got Stitch.
I was clubhouse.
Come inside.
Smoking side.
Mickey Mouse.
Clubhouse.
What the fuck is this?
Wait, why the fuck is Stitch here?
They couldn't get like...
Wait, who did they not get?
Okay, they got Mickey, Goofy, Donald, Minnie...
What about Daisy?
They replaced Daisy with Stitch?
Poor Daisy.
Stitch is...
Bro, Stitch doesn't even go.
go to the school.
He doesn't go to the clubhouse.
Where the fuck is Daisy?
Daisy actually has a role in the clubhouse.
She's a girl.
Minnie's in the team.
I bet Daisy is taller than Minnie.
He does now.
She got traded.
Yeah, they traded her last minute.
Yeah, Merry Christmas, everyone.
Oh, it's almost time.
All right, it's almost time for Rope.
Our first gaming stream with the dragoons.
All right, let me pull up.
Guys, what is the spelling, what is the spelling bee game,
guys?
This is very important.
Let's co-play the spelling bee game together.
I've been wanting to play that game for a long time.
does anyone know what it's called all right let's swap
screens real quick oh let's do
all right here we go so you guys are still not touching each
other this is fine what i did here no no there's a there's a
roblox game where is it just called spelling bee all right
we're gaming i have like a million tabs open right now
please don't judge me all right roblox tab don't worry guys
i'll buy a server so we don't have to crash some kid server
we don't have to crash this wait it's always spelling me
there you go wait there's only eight people right now is
this the right one there's no okay 87 all right wait this
hat this can't be the right one is that actually the right
okay spelling spelling b roblox game oh my god oh it oh it
has a present on there okay there you go what the fuck oh
wait what okay i figured it out all right create private
server It's just going to be called dokey bird now.
Yeah, it's just going to be called dokey bird.
I can't be bothered to oh It's free Oh my god guys.
It's free guys.
All right I'm generating a link right now I'm gonna go to my
I'm gonna join the server first Let me join the server first
guys so I don't get like I don't get locked out of the
server I gotta make sure I don't get locked out.
All right.
I don't know if my sound guide team.
Okay.
Sound guide might not be here because it is Christmas.
All right, let's claim this.
All right, I'm in.
All right, here you go.
All right.
All right, spell eat.
What?
Oh, my God.
That scared me.
Scared me.
I was like, who said that?
Wait, I was trying to spell with the YouTube chat, Dad.
YouTube.
Jimmy, speak to me.
Don't worry, Jimmy.
I got you.
All right.
Jimmy, live.
Okay.
All right.
Cat.
Yeah.
All right.
Try spelling.
Size.
All right.
Wait, we should do it extra hard.
How do I make the server extra hard?
What the fuck?
Spell mix.
Guys, there's no way you can fuck this up, guys.
It's literally the easiest name.
Oh, wait, it's seven.
Your word is rain.
It's not me yet.
I want to make, I want to do hard, extra hard.
Oh, wait, you guys can't see it.
All right, try spelling mom.
one all right now you just know how to spell at least okay
next word is soda it's not me yet all right please spell son
there's no way okay yeah i was gonna say there's no way you
guys can mess it up can you spell hand how do i change the
difficulty of this game please spell milk i level.
I won't play the second hardest.
Not the hardest.
I realize.
I want to cook up what the hard... Milk, bro!
The next word is bird.
Alright, spell best.
Please spell.
Alright, there you go.
Your word is pink.
We got this, guys.
We can pass spelling bee.
First grade spelling bee.
It was rigged for me.
Please spell Uh, she, they give the 10 gift, uh, they give a
10 dollar donation.
Thank you.
Spell noob.
Spell noob, bro.
Noob.
All right.
Spell cake.
Oh, I can spell cake.
Your next word is bar.
Spell snow.
All right.
Spell ball.
Can you spell moon?
We got this.
Your next word is gold.
Your next word is car.
I don't think there's no way we could lose this.
There's no...
How's anyone gonna lose?
Like, it's all three letter words.
Next up, kiss.
What?
All right, can you spell run?
I can spell run.
Your next word is baby.
All right, spell that.
It's never gonna end.
We're gonna be here forever.
All right, can you spell rally?
Your next word is angel.
Oh, my God.
Echo.
Oh, my God, it is getting harder.
Guys, it's getting harder.
The words aren't three letters anymore.
Oh, my God, it progressively gets harder.
Next up, state.
Okay.
Wait, I should have to lock in.
That was five letters.
The next word is bingo.
Oh, my God, they increased it by one.
All right, try spelling excerpt.
All right, can you spell row?
It's okay.
Next up, update.
I'm coming back.
All right, spell still.
It's not fair.
The next word is click.
I pressed enter.
I...
Spell clever.
I'm just gonna... I'm panicking.
The next word is...
Exert?
Like...
Spell...
Exerting?
They set me up.
This guy gets braided.
I get exited.
What the fuck is that?
The next word is hello.
No, it's just this.
Please spell pasta.
I have to like, okay, that's not fair.
They get me.
He got pasta.
I got exited.
I had to look up for the definition.
All right.
all right try spelling convey i even spelled it right but
then they didn't process it i got pinged it was ping guys it
was ping next up reply got pinged spell forbid it's not fair
the next word is foggy foggy your next word is burial
difficulty of this server i want to go right into like the
heart oh all right spell monk he spelled uh-oh all right can
you spell human it was the ping guys oh yeah spell do you
have any mods on in my chat right now can you guys change
the game can you spell twist yeah i don't know do i have
okay well i mean i got eliminated so i guess i can change it
myself i i guess i could change it myself please spell quack
your next word is burger row playing roblox with dragons all
right spell filter oh all right got it next time it's up to
you all right try spelling next time it's your job to change
the king category and i let you i'll give you the free will
to like also adjust the Next one.
Ah, yes.
All right.
Spell bugger.
Spell cabin.
Please spell cabin.
Please spell white.
This is not fair.
I swear.
I swear it was the hardest one out of everybody.
All right.
Can you spell sock?
Like he gets sock.
Your next word is.
Get sock!
Do a lobby with 40 people more than...
I'll do.
I really want to play the spelling bee, though.
I want to try the spelling bee.
Your word is ink.
Spell melt.
I think the copium.
All right, can you spell giant?
All right, guys, how do you change the difficulty in the
server?
Spell gender.
Oh, God.
Jeb?
Spell stumbled.
I was like, yeah, I wasn't like, Jeb?
Spell orange.
It's a...
All right, can you spell green?
Nice.
Your word is...
At least I didn't spell Jeb instead of gender.
Your word is intent.
Oh, extreme servers?
I made my own server.
How do I create an extreme server?
Yeah.
All right, can you spell land?
I created a server, but it didn't let me like...
The next word is dairy.
Spell shake.
Press the portal on the left.
Oh, this one?
Spell.
Oh, my God.
I'm...
Please spell film.
How do we do this?
Oh, server is now on expert mode.
Please spell exile.
Guys, guys, lose.
Oh, my God.
Alright, here we go.
Here we go.
We're on expert mode now.
Alright, if you already... Guys, if you already played with
me, uh, go... Go leave so that other dragos can join as
well.
You guys have the freebie of beginner mode.
But it's time.
It's time for...
Alright, can you spell apocryphal?
Let's do advanced.
Spell Quixotary.
Let's do it, guys.
Please spell neuroplasticity.
What the fuck?
Apocrine.
Okay, apocrine.
I got, like, the first four digits correct.
Guys, apocrine.
All right, can you spell Purile?
All right, we changed the difficulty.
Maybe, yeah, yeah, X-ray was a little bit too hard, guys.
I mean, there's genius.
Oh, my God.
He won by just being the last person.
Here's this.
All right.
It's fine.
I changed the difficulty, guys.
This should be okay now.
I got the first word.
Why is my first word?
your word is oh my god i forgot the tea i forgot the tea all
right try spelling myopic okay we gotta change the
difficulty again we'll do moderate we're gonna do moderate
spell metabolism okay wait i can spell metabolism spell
beneficiary beneficiary There we go.
Oh, he got it.
He got it.
He made it through.
Next up, caustic.
That's not caustic.
I got pestilence and he gets caustic.
What the fuck was that?
Proclamation.
All right.
Spell hourglass.
You get hourglass?
Your next word is...
Pestilence is harder than Cossack!
Can you spell systematic?
Alright, we tone down the difficulty.
Can you spell neighboring?
Okay.
Oh, I was gonna say it.
Alright, can you spell...
This is a European dictionary.
I was like, that's a U.
There's no U.
Your next word is...
steadfast also it's a volume okay guys your word is
exponential okay guys i didn't realize propaganda i didn't
realize like i relied so much on spell check can you spell
expenditure spell check is my hero oh he said turn it down
okay turn it down is bronchitis bronchitis oh he knows i'm
to spell bronchitis the next word is calibration okay i know
i know cal calibration i can do that all right can you spell
favorable favorable f-a-v-o-r yeah can you spell ravenous
rab she spelled rab surrogate surrogate easy next up
solidarity solidarity can you spell supposedly supposedly
s-u-p-o-s-e-d oh there you got it the next word is asthma
wait asthma as in oh yeah asthma yeah your word is
microorganism okay i failed my first one because um your
next word it was rigged it was rigged I didn't hear him say
pestilence.
I heard pestilence.
And I was like, oh, pestilence?
I don't know why there's no T there, but okay.
He said pestilence.
It's a TTS.
A TTS fucked me over.
Spell Zephyr.
I was like, oh, I don't know what pestilence is, but maybe
it's a word that I wasn't aware of.
Pecuniary.
It was ping diff too.
the ping diff got me the next word is uncharacteristic it's
spelling beat it literally exposes you if you rely on spell
check bro these guys are so smart you must be smart in fifth
grade what bro micro miniature
why is that word so long that was such a long ass word there
is no time to type that don't worry this time i got it guys
if you guys play it already make sure to land on the dragon
have a chance uncomfortable uncomfortable yeah okay this is
the difficulty for me congratulate this is the difficult for
me we got it we figured it out is telepathy we got it your
word is frolic okay all right can you spell finally this
okay maybe i the difficulty is too easy the next word is
slay oh slay as in oh not the not the other slay i thought
like slay girl spell flavor yeah your word is chronic oh my
god this guy has custom walnut all right spell syntax please
spell offender all right try spelling pursuit
i doubted myself i was like maybe it's the one with the why
the next word is agnostic it's not fair i was like oh wait
it's the why it was too late for me I think it's spelled
with an A.
Okay.
You know what?
Let's do a master.
Let's see how that goes.
Wait, I'll be the first one.
I believe in us.
All right.
Spell tonsillofarangitis.
Tonsillofarangitis.
Tonsolofarangitis.
Oh.
My god.
Can you spell pseudo-rombicubakta Hebrew?
What?
All right, spell lymphangioleomyomatosis.
Your next word is psychoneuroendocrinological.
Psycho.
say he don't he's not even always got he got it neurological
please spell okay let's go back to the hillapilification
try it try it you got this i can leave it you they're not
even words okay which one did we want moderate or advanced
in advance you got this you got please spell canaliculo
dachryocyst or hynostomy okay because these rounds are so
fast if you get on to these rounds and then you want to join
the next we do another when we do another game of this you
guys can join another game so don't worry if you're Like,
oh, I was only in the game for like 10 seconds because I
chose my kickmaster.
You're allowed to join another game.
Yeah.
Because I did.
I did fuck with you guys there.
I did fuck with you guys.
All right.
Okay.
This time it's moderate.
Yes.
It's moderate this time.
So we got this.
We.
Oh my God.
That's a cool ass.
I like that.
Look at guys like my skin.
I'm Thomas the Tank Engine.
All right.
Can you spell Frostbite?
I can.
Your word is heritage.
Okay.
Wait, was I on?
What was I on?
Hexagonal.
I'm dyslexic.
The next word is ricochet.
Oh.
R-I-C-O-H-O Oh, it doesn't even show me the word anymore.
Can you spell gibberish?
Please spell detrimental.
D-E-T-R.
Alright, can you spell commodity?
I feel like I'm in a real spelling bee.
spell aerodynamic
okay your next word I'm almost up next I'm almost up next
here I go okay spell unprecedented
what oh see can you spell negotiation look it's the pressure
it's the 90 I got unprecedented.
The next word is symmetrical.
Unprecedented?
Did he got unprecedented?
Like, you know, I was thinking about...
I was thinking about someone getting unprecedented.
I was like, is that...
Oh, that's like my initial thought.
Look, I was thinking under pressure.
Can you spell...
It was under pressure.
He just unprecedented him, you know?
Pomegranate.
That's...
Yeah, when they decide to leave, they get unprecedented.
All right, can you spell syllable?
When the presidency gets taken away.
The next word is skeleton.
Oh my god, this guy is too good at spelling.
This guy is so good at spelling.
Please spell independence.
because you're getting unprecedented it's unprecedented
look guys i'm learning a lot of new words today guys i'm
learning everyone i'm i'm learning reliability also so is
the sound a lot better now or should i turn it down more all
right spell
imprisonment spell charisma we're learning a lot about each
other guys we're learning a lot can you spell kangaroo no i
can read i just oh kangaroo it's the pressure okay it's the
it's the pressure of this okay guys i i i i feel so much
pressure try to type out the words and it's freaking me out
it's okay all right can you spell blizzard I could spell
blizzard.
The next word is non-plussed.
Can you spell wholeheartedly?
Oh, um.
Oh, he just leaves.
He just, he, I can't just leave.
Your next word is technological.
He fucking do.
He was like, oh.
Don't look at me.
He's like, he tipped.
He's like, don't look at me.
Your next word is venerate.
Venerate?
What?
Bruce, the same.
He's also like, venerate?
Can you spell nebulous?
Yeah.
I'm sorry.
scared nebulous please spell doctrine oh god i think i'm
next
spell extravagant am i it up no all right can you spell
portfolio oh i think that got glitched out oh wait what
Oh god, okay.
Alright, spell participation.
Who the fuck is?
Biggie cheese.
Okay.
The next word is resilience.
What?
Oh my god, it's with an E!
It's with an E!
I will...
No!
I could have lived!
of an e okay one one more, one more, one more I gotta live
past two rounds guys I gotta I have to live past two rounds
this is my mission alright try spelling enchantment there
you go two rounds can you spell abditive I have to survive
two rounds oh can you spell endeavor i have not lived past
the second round once except for the except for the
kindergarten level okay that's good if everyone fucks up
here spell mathematician mathematician mathematician ma
Try spelling recession.
Oh, yeah.
Press enter.
Oh, what?
It's spelled with one C?
Your next word is pronunciation.
Okay, God didn't get that.
I would have added two Cs.
Guys, I'm way too into this game.
Featherweight.
I'm sorry.
This game is actually pretty good.
This game is...
It reveals a lot about each other, guys.
It reveals a lot about both of us.
Both you, Timmy, and Yimmy.
Derogatory.
Spell aspiration.
Okay.
Exper.
All right, spell humanitarian.
Humanitarian.
Yay!
Second round, love!
Thank you so much for the rain!
Merry Christmas, Y'all.
Thank you.
We guys had a great stream.
I'm, I'm, I'm like fighting for my life right now.
I survived the second round.
Guys, I'm so good at the spelling game.
I think I won, like, look at that.
Look at that.
All right, spell Hornswaggle.
Oh, my God.
Yes.
I don't want to die.
Oh, my God.
One more.
All right.
Try spelling scholarship.
No!
Why does he get such an easy word?
Your word is.
Understand.
Ha ha ha.
Never mind.
I take this.
Worthwhile.
All right.
Can you spell passionate?
Yeah, I can.
All right.
Try spelling.
Exaggerate.
Yes.
I did it.
I am the best spelling.
You know what?
I'm so confident.
Confident we're gonna go expert mode.
That's how confident I am now Look at that.
I won.
I'm so good at this.
Look at that guys.
Your word is acculturate
What the fuck oh my god Homogeneous I forgot a C.
I fucking forgot a C.
I fucking there was a C
Sanguine.
Sanguine?
What the fuck is that?
All right, spell thermionic.
Thermionic.
Oh my god, at least a Doki would.
All right, let's do genius.
Genius, Tav.
I feel confident.
Those words weren't even that hard.
I just forgot one letter.
They weren't even that hard, guys.
Oh my god, people are leaving.
People don't want to try this one.
Please spell portmanteau.
Port what?
Oh, dog.
Can you spell institutionalization?
Okay, that one is so easy.
It's like institution and analyzation.
I got portmanteau.
Declare Sisman.
Declare.
All right, can you spell photo reconnaissance?
Okay, you do photo.
And then Reconnaissance.
Next scene.
Thank you for 10 gifted subs.
Thank you.
Reconnaissance.
Alright, guys.
Okay, okay.
I think I can get addicted to this.
But we gotta stop.
We gotta find a new Roblox game.
This game.
This game is dangerous.
It really is.
We got...
We gotta find another server.
We can't get...
We can't reveal more of ourselves today.
Alright, let's see it.
What is it good?
Oh my god, we have to play this.
I know I always play this, but it's so fucking fun.
I love...
I love shrimp game.
It's such a fun fucking...
Oh wait, where's my server?
Oh, there's my server.
Oh, my server's still alive!
I forgot it's forever!
all right my server is still alive let me go grab the link
all right guys i'm in this is one of my favorite roblox
games i'm like always i'm so obsessed with this one all
right go in guys it's time my thomas the tank engine doesn't
come with me
over here guys it's time to play shrimp game i always play a
shrimp game it is a classic get over here guys we can all
join shrimp game but how many people are in here oh we have
five more four more guys come four more three more oh these
guys They're still loading in.
The suckers.
Oh, never mind.
He disappeared.
My 26 seconds to get in here.
I can't believe I made a Roblox account for this.
Oh my god, wait.
I forgot you can be a guard.
I forgot in this game you can actually be a guard.
I should have picked a guard.
All right.
Also, I lowered the sound a little bit.
Yeah, you can be a guard in this game.
All right.
Wait, I think it can be a guard right now.
Wait, let me...
Uh, wait, it's sand.
Wait, I gotta buy this.
Wait, how many time do I have?
No, wait, wait, wait.
And
I was about to die.
The timer fucked me over.
Bum, bum, bum.
Oh, we all skipped it.
Okay, vote for next game.
We'll do season two.
Vote for season two!
Season two!
Come on, guys!
I don't know what's different, but I want season two!
I'm stuck here.
Wait, season one better?
Yeah, but I don't know what season two does.
Dad's for me.
Wait, we have someone that's actually a guard.
Yeah.
There we go.
Wait, can I still be a guard?
Okay, it's fine.
I don't need to be a guard.
Oh, shit.
How come I can't run?
I can't run!
Okay, okay, okay, I figured it
out.
I'm gonna get you.
I'm still alive.
This line!
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, wait, wait.
Oh, shit.
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait, watch this.
Oh, shit.
Oh, I don't have my push anymore.
I wanted him to push them.
No!
Because everyone made it.
That took you so helpful.
I'm such a helpful person, guys.
I pushed everyone to the finish line.
I saved everyone.
I'm a hero.
I'm a hero, guys.
I did it.
I saved everyone.
I'm such a good person.
Okay, what's this?
Oh, do we get...
Oh, this is apparently a classic.
Wait, is this not the...
Oh, wait.
This one is the...
Wait, no.
We should do the...
The...
the classic classic isn't that the oh wait no that's the the
gona is the fucking other thing the classic classic we bring
the sound up a bit okay
yeah the cookie cut i gotta say isn't the gona the cookies
okay it's okay it's not the umbrella it's It's not the
umbrella.
We got this.
It's not the umbrella, guys.
Okay.
I'm just gonna do this.
Got it.
I'm so nervous.
Oh!
Oh my god, someone got shot.
I baited!
I can't!
I got a star!
Because I'm a star, baby!
I'm a star!
Oh, look at this guy.
He's still doing his key.
Oh, you got the umbrella.
Look at him.
You got the freaking umbrella.
You picked the wrong door.
Wait, did he survive?
Did you survive?
Umbrella, umbrella done.
He actually survived.
Oh, look at us!
We lived!
Yay!
Job done.
Yay, job done.
We're live!
There's still... Oh my god!
Only...
Only six people died?
How are we all still here?
Only fucking six of us are dead.
oh my god we're gaming too hard we're just not spellers when
it comes to battle royale oh this one this one mingle one of
my favorites
yeah twitch chat is on it's on the left the left is twitch
chat the right is youtube chat that's timmy and yimmy okay
okay At least we can choose our fate.
This is where people die.
This right here.
This right here is where we die.
Yeah, we can live, but we can't spell.
This is one of my favorite game modes.
Where am I?
Where's me?
No!
They removed the song!
There's no song now!
Did they actually removed it because of copyright?
Okay.
That's crazy.
That's actually crazy.
They removed the song.
It's one of my favorites.
No, I think it got muted.
It got muted because of...
Two.
You and me.
You and me, buddy.
We did it.
We live.
We live, Evan.
You and me.
Evan, you and me.
That's a key right.
We got this, Evan.
You and me.
Let's go.
We fucking live.
Not us.
Not us, Evan.
Let them go.
All right.
We live another day.
You and me.
Pop, pop, pop.
I can't believe it.
Wait, you guys not hearing the song either, right?
It's not just me, right?
Oh my god.
No, don't do this.
One.
This is my.
Get out.
One!
It said one!
Get out!
Oh my god, it's 10 seconds.
It's 10 seconds.
Get the fuck out.
Get out of my
room!
oh my god oh my god oh my god no
that's not my fate that is not my fate that is not my fate
that is not my fate that is that my story will be rewritten
my story will be rewritten as foretold
I shall be born again.
It took 11 players to set up.
Toki.
The power of having adult spending money.
Oh, you cheater?
You also bought it!
You're online because you also paid to revive!
This is the revive room!
You can't say shit!
You are part of the problem, didn't you?
You all bought revives to be in this room.
That's okay.
It means we don't have to go through that area.
You're so cool.
It's all right.
We don't have to do the mingle.
Look at that.
Guys, look at that.
We all lived.
everyone we're so good we're so good at squid game we all
live oh look at all that money we're gonna get look at all
that money guys oh my god that's gonna be my money that
money is gonna be mine oh all right do we do the classic or
jump rope i see more people voting for classic I mean, this
one's easy.
We have enough people to test it out.
We have enough people to...
To go through all the glass.
I believe.
At least that...
At least Mingle just, like, kicked half the players.
Thank God for that.
I think we can all vote to skip.
Guys, come on, guys.
We can all...
Guys, who is the one dragon?
did it but we have enough sacrifices
oh shit oh i'm scared
oh my god oh my god i almost messed up the jump there there
were so many people in front of me look at that look at all
the sacrifices okay it's fine I just gotta figure out who's
me and who's you and who me is all right four minutes we
have so much time this is easy
okay up up up up there's so many people and so many of them
are also impatient
Is the guard okay?
Oh, the guard can't.
He's like, oh, the guard lives.
That has to be the right one, right?
It's the one to the right.
It's that one.
It's the right one.
Come on.
It's the right.
Oh.
Wait, I have an idea.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, wait.
Right.
Next.
Oh, I got
it!
Left now.
We made it!
We did it!
It's left.
We're all saying it's left.
He didn't believe in us.
No trust.
No fucking.
Trust the left one for real.
It's obviously the left one, guys.
It's obviously...
I trust that you and Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Sleepy, thank you for the 100 biddies.
Yeah, guys.
I was watching your backs, guys.
I was there for all of you.
I watched all your backs to make sure that there was no one
coming from behind.
Got your backs, guys.
i was covering yeah but everyone said left we all said left
surely that's the right way oh no not this i i don't know
how to play this mode this mode is so stupid
whoa stop get out here this is my oh Whoa, no!
Oh god, oh no.
Oh no!
My, I'm...
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa!
It's not fair!
Everyone just wants to punch me!
I have a plan.
Okay.
Guys, I did it.
My plan.
Oh my god.
No Pakistan.
Not the Pakistan.
It's okay.
They don't know this is me.
They don't know.
Oh god.
don't no no no
backshot yeah backshot backshot oh no
please calm down backshot no wait wait wait no is that fair
everyone just keeps punching me what
okay i got i have a plan i can see the timer i have a plan
chat i see the timer watch this
this is the pain no no no this plan this plan is solid it's
solid right now we wait we wait
right here till the time is right the time just increased
another 30 seconds we wait until the time is right and then
we come in this is it this is it this is it right here it
keeps increasing when does the time okay i'm gonna take a
bathroom break at this point
oh my god the timer actually went down i'm coming in
what i paid 99 they took my money they they took my money
wait where am i i was not
surprised my 99
They robbed me on Christmas Day.
Oh my god.
I don't even get to see the winner.
I don't even.
I don't even get to see who won.
Not only did they rob me.
But I can't even see who won the game.
I got robbed on Christmas Day.
Merry Christmas everyone.
Not on Christmas Day.
i can't believe it it can just expire all right let's find
another game oh my god okay you guys see that meme about
where you can be a silly seal and did you guys know about
the silly seal roleplay server doki doki a bird but seal a
doki seal i'm buying a doki I'm dying at a seal.
Let's see.
Yes.
A seal server.
We're going to be seals, guys.
The silly seal RPAY.
There's a really funny clip revolving this Roblox server.
I can't show it on stream because it's very bad.
It's a very bad clip.
But it's very funny.
Yeah, we're Sears!
Look at us, go!
Oh my god, my multi-chat died.
My- My fault, where did my multi-chat go?
Wait!
Yes!
Oh, I'm being carried!
Guys, give me a sec.
The multi-chat disappeared.
Where did my multi-chat go?
Oh, there it is.
There you go.
How do I slap my belly?
Yay!
Let's go!
My name is Eggbird!
I'm Eggbird!
Wait, can I transform?
I'm a choppy seal.
That's me.
Oh my god, wait!
Let's see.
Give me a a sec.
I gotta put on a hat.
Give me a sec.
Let me put on my hat.
I need a bigger hat.
I have a mustache.
Ooh.
Guys, look at me.
Look at me.
How to clash.
Shut up.
In the evil time.
Yay!
Whoa, that's crap!
All right, get out.
Squish.
Oh my god.
Squish, squish, squish, squish.
Squish, squish, squish.
What?
I don't think...
I don't think seals make that sound.
I can scratch.
The lead down.
Wait, no!
Oh, I can dance!
Woo!
Let's go!
I'm so happy!
Wait, wait, let's see.
I'm gonna be...
Yeah!
Whoa!
No, no, no, I can't...
Yay!
There's seals, guys.
We're just...
Oh my god, wait, I can fish?
Wait.
How do I fish?
How...
I want to fish.
Let me fish.
Oh, wait.
Here we go.
And then...
How do I...
I guess I'm trying to fish, guys.
Stop.
I try...
I'm trying to figure out how to fish, guys.
Stop.
Oh, my God.
Now I'm swimming.
I can't.
Let me sit back.
No.
Let's.
I can do it.
I can do it fish.
It's fishing time.
Okay.
I got my fishing ride.
And then, how do I...
Oh, fish.
Alright, I'm fishing.
Oh, shit!
What do I get?
Oh.
Let's go!
We can create more
time for me!
Let's do it.
Let's fish again.
again.
As I did.
I got a fish, guys.
Yes, please.
Please let me fish,
guys.
Get me out of here.
I got a sardine.
Hello.
I want to take you.
I want to Click the shake.
Whoa.
Oh, my God.
Wait, I got fish.
I got fish.
Okay.
We got fish.
Let's go.
Yay.
Wait, how big is the trout?
Look at that, guys.
Guys, look at my fish, guys.
Show me.
Holy shit.
Look at the fucking everybody's just in the hole.
Just hit the fucking door.
Let's show our fishes, guys.
What fish did you guys get?
Look!
This is my fish.
Please clap.
I got this is my fish.
Please clap for my fish, guys.
Please clap.
Yeah.
Yeah, everyone.
Please clap.
Yeah!
The princess carried me.
Please clap for my fish, guys.
Please.
Yay!
Okay, let's...
I...
Yay!
Oh my god.
Wee!
I love this game!
Oh my god!
Wee!
Oh, I can clap on this
game!
Woohoo!
It was so fun, guys.
Oh my god, oh, okay, it's fine.
I'm okay.
Wait, I can swim away.
Oh my god, there's a fucking crab!
Can't do anything to the crab, though.
Oh, I'm still clapping.
Give me, I need to, I need to stop clapping.
Okay, there we go.
I need to stop clapping.
Oh my god, I can hear, I can hear, I can hear the seals
clapping behind me.
Merry Christmas, everyone.
You're right behind me.
Oh, wait, how did you jump?
Wait, how did you do that?
Whoa!
Wait, I'm getting...
Oh, my God.
I'm getting some air right now.
Oh, wait.
There's an...
There's an abandoned building here.
Oh, my God.
The human race is...
dead it's just all seals now it's like splatoon literally a
seal utopia
fucking like an actual seal utopia guys wow
well everyone is dead start clapping Yay!
Wait, there's minigames?
Wait, where's the minigame?
Oh my god, there's a minigame!
Wait, there's other minigames around here!
There's radiation?
Wait, pranks are on?
What the fuck are the minigames?
Where's the radiation?
That's what I'm worried about.
Oh my god, look.
Look, they're just chilling.
My chair.
This is my chair.
Okay, I want to know where the radiation is.
Let's see.
Lying down.
That's a cat.
Guys, I am worried.
I got scared.
That might be a bit too long.
Too much yelping.
Where is the...
Wait, is this the radiation?
Guys!
Guys, I think I found it.
Wait, how do we get in?
How do we get in here?
A nocturnal fish...
I'm in the lab.
Wait, I'm in.
Wait, how do we...
We go up?
Oh, where am I?
How do I?
Oh, my God.
I'm trying to.
Guys, I'm trying to get on it.
Oh, my God.
One at a time, Seals.
One at a time.
I'm very bad at surfacing.
Okay, I made it.
I made it.
Yay, please clap.
I made it, guys.
All right, where are I?
we now?
What?
What the fuck is that?
Oh my god, that's an orc.
That's a giant orca.
The killer of seals.
Run!
Oh my god, he got radiated.
Where do we go?
Guys, I don't know where to go.
know where to go
oh oh oh oh he's got him
oh oh no i'm stuck i'm okay i live
you're saying it's okay oh no no oh no he's
coming i don't think he made it i don't think he made it oh
no oh no oh oh my god you live
No, we'll be fine.
We'll be fine.
Where do we go, guys?
Where do we go?
Where the guys?
Where the fuck do we go?
We were clapping so happily.
What happened to us?
We're so happy with our claps.
I don't...
We should fish.
You're in this is a perfect fishing place, too, guys.
So true.
In the middle of all of this, let's fish.
Look at that.
Oh, I got sea bass.
Sea bass.
More like a bea bass.
Oh, hey, guys.
Another fishing zone.
Maybe I'll have good fishes.
oh my god you got an angler fish what the he's just like
that's me that's me oh
okay what did i get what did i get i got sardine oh zero
point nine pounds though All right, let's see what our
places there are here.
Imagine there's a jump scare, bro.
That would be fucking...
That would be fucked up.
I wonder if there's actually anything here, though.
Do you guys see anything?
Oh, shit!
Oh, my God!
The Orca's here!
He's...
I was like, why are you guys all running away?
Oh, my God.
He's trying to crash the pie.
And he's like, you did it and fight me.
Okay.
Oh, hey.
This is the bathroom.
Hey, guys.
Where the fuck do we go, yes?
There must be something here.
Oh.
Wait.
Who has the green card?
Did anyone found the green card?
Guys!
We need a green card stat!
Quick, dragos!
Marry each other!
Guys!
Okay, guys.
There are a lot of us here.
Wait.
Pixel has it.
Where's Pixel?
Wait, where is he?
Where the fuck is Pixel?
He has the green card.
Where is he?
Oh, God.
Run!
Where the fuck is Pixel?
Oh, oh, he opened it.
He opened it.
Go, go, go, go.
Oh my god Drop the card Drop the card right now Where did
you get the card Where did you get the card, Pixel?
The card!
Where is it?
Where is he?
He said follow Which one's him?
We're all white seeing it I see him, I see him Follow this
white seal.
Where is it?
Where did you get?
Oh, oh under in the Okay Where Card where Wait, where is he
where I lost him?
We're all white seals.
I lost him I don't know where he is.
Where did he go?
We're all white seals.
I can't tell us apart I'm here okay okay okay here he is
where where did you find it where did you find a pixel buy
it where did you find it oh my I'm stuck I got I got I got
get air okay there you where did he go where the pixel go I
lost him again
where's the green card
wait oh it spawns oh my god drop the card right now drop
drop oh oh it spawns random oh my god each player gets
different spawns oh fuck okay alright each player gets
different spawns I will figure this out okay I'll go fine
guys bait the orca Gotta know what's over on the other side.
Guys, bait the orca.
He's blocking.
He's spawn camping, guys.
He's not moving.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
I will find the green card.
Maybe it's in here.
No.
Is there any green cards here?
Oh, my God.
Each player gets random spawns.
That's so fucked up.
Okay, now I'm stuck in the hole.
Guys.
Guys, help.
How did you...
Guys.
Guys, help me.
Someone carry me out.
Guys!
Someone carry me out of the hole!
Please!
I'm stuck.
I can't get out!
Okay, wait.
Guys, please.
Please.
I can't get out of the hole.
Oh, wait.
Oh, there's a hole in the hole.
Here.
Never mind.
I figured it out.
I figured it out, guys.
I did it.
Oh my god.
Where the fuck is there?
Maybe it's an immense bathroom.
Mommy.
Okay.
There has to be a green card somewhere.
Where the fuck is the green guy?
Oh my gosh, she's just camping.
Oh, she's stuck.
She's stuck, guys.
Wait, that's a mushroom.
Oh, I can't grab it.
Oh my gosh, she got unstuck.
She got unstuck.
Is that a bone?
What the fuck?
What the?
Oh, a brand new dad.
I was just like, what the fuck?
What is that sound?
Where the fuck is the green card?
I just want a green card.
Oh, oh.
Oh, wait.
That's just a reflection.
Never mind.
I got baited by shiny.
It was shiny and I got baited.
Any green cards?
Green card.
Where is the clap for the green card?
We'll never find the green card, guys.
We'll never be able to uncover the secret.
The secret of the secret of the seals.
We'll never be able to figure it out.
We'll never know what was going on here.
Wait, I got cheese.
Wait, I've got cheese, guys!
Their fate is truly sealed.
That's a good one.
Is there...
Card?
Any green card?
We'll never know the lore.
We'll never figure out the lore.
That's so sad.
the lore will be forever locked to us we'll never know the
lore of the seals
it's so sad it really is I'm gonna eat my mushroom yam yam
yam yam what the fuck bro she found a skull
we'll never know the lore of this game will forever be
trapped in the labs i'm never gonna get out oh my god it's
isenberg it's so sad it's so sad i am now a sad seal
i am now a sad seal i'm so sad guys I'll never know the
Lord.
I'll never know the Lord.
We'll never know.
The clap of sadness.
Curing me.
I'll never want to move again.
Oh my god.
Please Put me out of my misery
Me with no lore We'll never We'll never figure out the lore
It truly is a sad day Take me to the orca Take me To the
orca Let me Oh shit Oh
accept our fate feed me feed me to him feed me to the orca
it's over feed me to the orca I I want to be oh wait is that
where we go when we're eaten we just respawn there
he just fucking takes us to the red room It truly is
terrible.
I'm so sad.
Goodbye.
It was a sad day.
I will never figure out the seal lore.
I will never figure out the real lore behind the seals.
i love that game that game is so silly it's called what is
it called it's called be a silly seal and i truly was a very
silly seal i haven't i've been sealed i've been sealed out
of the seal experience blood they give us 300 biddies thank
you thank you not only did they stole my money i couldn't
get lore They took away my lore Wait, what is this?
Wait, wait a minute.
Wait, what is this?
Wait, wait, wait, wait, I'm creating a...
Wait, how many people in the server?
Guys, I'm creating...
Wait, don't get it.
It's a good use of my...
bucks guys okay i know i did say we were supposed to play a
difficult game about climbing but like i don't know if you
guys are having fun i hope you guys are having fun but i'm
having a lot of fun just playing random roblox games with
you guys
guys we can role play we were a silly seal and now we can
role play as a lion
all right here's the server guys i'm claiming my coins
we're in the savannah now
all right i want to be i can't be a lion wait wait wait but
i can
yeah i am the king of the savannah i was gonna say king of
jungle but oh wait
never mind that is a lot i'm not paying guys i'm i'm not
paying 70 to be a lion i'm bro what the fuck bro what okay
okay i can't like i'm not paying 70 dollars to be a lion
guys i don't have the robux for it all right we'll be Okay,
maybe I'll, okay, I will, I'll, how about this?
I'll pay, wait, okay.
Okay, that is still $70.
How about this?
I'll be a zebra.
I'll be Marty.
I will pay $70.
I will pay $7 to be a zebra, though.
I, I'll pay $7 to be a zebra.
Wait, I could be a bird.
What the fuck am I doing?
Oh my god.
Okay, there we go.
I could be a bird.
Oh my god, a crocket.
Okay, let's be a bird.
Jokey a bird.
Wait, can I not?
All right, here we go.
A male yellow hornbill.
Starter character.
Wait, let's just...
do a doki actual doki bird wait i can red bill why can't be
a tool can well i can be a tool can bird
all right i will pay i'll pay seven dollars to be a toucan i
will pay seven dollars to be a toucan guys they don't have a
crow unfortunately wait yeah they don't have a crow all
right let me put my paypal information real quick i forgot
my okay never mind guys i can't be bothered to find the
password of my paypal i guess we're just default
no we're default andy wait i do have wait i can't wait
there's a crow wait i have just enough wait i can be a crow
i'm croaky wait croaky i can be croaky
here we go i do have passkey but like it doesn't work on
roblox i have to like pull it up on my on my different
browser but i can't be bothered all right
it's me croaky i got it how do i fly wait i can only hop
wait how oh my god that's it why is there a dead dog here
what why is there a dead dog i don't want to eat this stop
i'm trying to eat it wait the dog's eating it okay i have
groups and then oh attack e for e okay oh my god guys no
croaky oh my god he's eating me he just ate rules of nature
it's okay i just gotta learn how to fly i'm doing it i'm
flying
Don't worry!
They can't harm us when we're in the sky!
Copy, croaky, tax, pop us for it.
Thank you in the super chat.
They can't hurt us!
Quick!
Take the skies, my brethren!
Alright, grab, carry, X for toggle, rest.
A custom movement is C?
How do you guys...
Oh, there you go.
Wee!
That's right.
Cat hunt us now.
We're in the sky now.
Cat hurt us now, guys.
That's fucking right.
Don't press B.
What's B?
It's sent.
What the fuck is sent?
Oh my god, that's a dog.
Okay, we're gonna go on the other side.
There's a there's a dog waiting for us to go down He's
waiting for he's waiting for me to touch the ground.
I see the dog Oh my god.
Oh my god.
They're fucking surrounding me Shit
Sky.
Oh, no.
I'm okay.
I'm okay, guys.
Oh, my God.
Wait, who's hitting me?
The other bridge are fucking trying to kill me.
That's okay.
I'm never being
burned up.
That's it.
Oh, hey.
That's food.
Yum, yum, yum.
I'm hungry.
A dog's gotta eat.
You know?
Okay, C, B is sent.
All right.
Oh, my God.
Oh, my.
Okay, that's the scent of everything.
Oh, I'm so fast.
What other controls do I have?
Let's see, I can grab, carry, custom movement.
A dog's got to eat.
I'm yum, yum, yum.
Guys, being a crow, everyone started.
She was trying to beat me up, guys.
It wasn't worth it.
That's a hippo.
I'm yum, yum, yum.
My hippo now.
I'm so hungry.
What are you trying to do, huh?
Oh, what the fuck?
He's trying.
It's okay.
I'm faster than a bird.
Guys, I don't think the wild dogs are going to stick
together.
Okay, we're going to go grab some water.
Everything will be fine.
We will live.
We will head to Pride Rock.
To settle our claim.
Attack it.
Hey.
Hello, sir.
Let me smell your ass.
Whoa, where did he go?
Oh, hey!
Wait, there's a baby!
Oh, shit!
Wait, can I grab this baby?
I want to grab...
Oh, my God.
He's coming over.
Guys, baby attack him!
Oh, fuck.
Oh my god, he's just die bombing Attack him attack the bird
We hunt we hunt now we must now we eat family we now eat
Yes, family eat the bird Eat my family familia Kill him war
on birds Is that the baby?
Oh, hey.
That's right.
This is a war!
They can't beat us.
We're more tanky.
Dogs strong together.
Are we eating another bird?
Wait, oh my god, we killed another one.
Oh my god, there he is.
There's another bird.
Oh my god, it's a fucking war.
Burn him on versus dogs.
Get him!
We are faster and we are bigger.
Ground versus air.
That's right.
You gotta drop down soon, birds.
You have to drop down soon.
Oh, shit.
Our own cotton tool.
Oh, wait.
You were just...
try to get him.
What the?
Oh my god.
It's okay.
I'm okay.
I'm okay, guys.
We got him.
We got another one.
Oh my god.
The fucking die bomb.
Fucks with me so much.
They like die bomb.
I'm one of the good ones.
This is artillery guys quick fire the artillery oh wait
there's a fucking gazelle hey is he is he and then a fucking
random gazelle joins it which side are you on oh shit
goodbye i don't think i'll ever be i don't think that's it
i'm leaving the survey i'm joining Texas oh shit that's it
I'm joining oh wait that's a strip I'm good where the fuck
is that I'm going to California we're the appreciate my role
play that's taking it I'm good role play they'll appreciate
the role play Oh my god, the sky is an elephant.
Where are all the people?
I'm gonna go role-play in peace.
I am tired of war.
I just wanna be a bird.
I shall role-play in peace.
When I find people.
Alright, here we go.
Wait, I found some gazelles!
Oh my god, they're hunting!
They're hunting!
Holy shit!
Return to nature.
Return to peace.
I can finally be a real bird.
What the fuck is that over there?
What the fuck is that?
Oh my god, look at there's an elephant.
I'm at Pride Rock!
Oh my
god, that's a lion!
Wait, I'm gonna talk to this lion.
Oh my god, he's just dragging it away.
lions
oh my god these guys these guys pick yo yo
who's who's the king of the savannah
the buffalo there yeah
oh my god it's the
The buffaloes are...
Wait, wait, wait.
He knows the way.
I want to know.
We are bird.
Oh, that's us.
Oh, he's still typing.
He's still typing.
I want to know who's the king of the savannah.
Who is it?
Okay, I know.
Okay.
Are you the king?
Are you the leader?
What if I say, can you be my dad?
Who the fuck is the thing?
No.
I'm role-playing, guys.
Am I doing it correct?
Oh my god, they're all hunting.
Oh, thank you guys.
Oh my god, these guys are...
Oh my god, they're killing the birds.
Oh my god!
Get him!
It does!
Oh!
Kill him!
Yeah!
Oh my god, wait, he killed him!
Wait, he killed him!
He killed him!
Well, we're hungry, so...
I mean...
Who's food, guys?
Wait, wait, that's the...
That's the bad one!
That's the bad cheetah!
Look at that red!
He killed our friend!
Guys, we all surround him and then we kill him.
Oh my god!
Wait, actually that's like, wait, wait.
Hello.
Wait, he's the good one.
He's the good one.
No, he's the good one.
He's the one that saved us.
He's part of the Mule crew.
Oh, never mind.
He's not good.
He's a bad, never mind.
He started killing again.
No, that's...
Yeah, no, you started killing.
Okay, I leave.
I leave.
Nobody is kind here.
No, no one.
The Savannah is a cruel place, guys.
Wait, is that a black lion?
His name is Simbob McGee.
Oh, he's gone.
Simbob McGee is gone now.
Simbob McGee.
Hello.
Oh my god, there's a lot Hello Fuck, okay.
Hello, Mr. Elephants Hello Guys guys, I'm trying to bond
with the elephant guys I'm trying to bond Hello
Fucking dream Tri-Fi.
The fucking crocodile got me.
Alright, we leave.
We leave.
We can't roll flip.
It's so dangerous in the wild.
Who would have thought the Savannah is a very dangerous
place.
It's like they're animals out there.
They're looking wild rat.
They're wild animals.
It's not role play safe, chat.
is it guys i know that we do the dinosaur one i could tell
where it's gonna head we're just gonna fucking start eating
each other again i don't trust us i don't trust us anymore
we're just gonna start eating each other i was just trying
to talk to the elephant bro he sat down and everything i
wanted to talk to him one wait what is this let's see try to
see like what other ones i want to try out what is this wait
how many people can be in the server oh wait wait this must
be might be fun okay oh
it's free yeah it's free it's a free server i love it
all right for this server no one can eat each other good
news everyone you can't eat each other this time there's
there's good news here we can survive
what do you mean no fun i was trying to roleplay
all right we're going to end arnica
We're going to Antarctica, everyone.
Norma.
We're gonna be...
Canada.
Hello, everyone.
We're in Antarctica.
All right, let's grab some uniforms so we're fully prepared
for Antarctica.
I'll be fully kidding guys.
We all get flares.
We can't get flashlights.
We can't...
Is this fun?
I don't know.
I think we can do this guys.
I think we can survive Antarctica.
Guys, I think we can make it.
Alright.
Alright everyone.
Alright guys.
We can do this.
We can conquer Antarctica.
And we shall... What the fuck?
How do I do one expedition?
How do I start the expedition?
Guys, how do I start the expedition?
Guys, I don't think that cat is gonna make it.
How do we start it?
I'm ready!
Oh, there you go.
Search and rescue!
Wait, no, that's not it.
No, that's not it.
I have to pay for that.
I...
Where the fuck is this?
expedition here oh that's to get a guide oh there you go
expedition teams come
wait i don't what the fuck whose teams are these i want to
be on my own team wait who's the winning team oh this is the
winning team guys oh wait what oh this is like a community
Oh, when you join their team, the expeditions you win goes
towards the points there.
How the fuck do I start this?
You gotta head over to the water?
The water.
And not grab...
Oh, hey, gingerbread.
I grabbed gingerbread, though.
Oh, no, we don't need to call emergency.
Complete...
To unlock the entrance to the mission base.
The parkour.
Oh.
To guide.
Wait.
Find the parkour.
There's a trail.
Oh here.
Oh I found it.
I found it.
I did it guys.
We did it everyone.
Quick.
Plant the flag.
I'm gonna buy a flag.
I bought a flag guys.
I'm here to plant it for Canada.
for Canada we shall claim Antarctica for Canada
all right nice no I gotta beat Australia wait is that
Australia or New Zealand's flag I'm so sorry I can't your
flags are actually very similar to me
Okay.
Okay, here you go.
We're gonna make it.
We gotta be faster than the llama guy.
He's quick.
He's gonna claim it for his country.
It's one of them.
I mean, you guys don't even know.
Yeah.
Oh God.
There's so many of us.
I quit.
I can't see.
Alright.
Don't let him plant the flag.
It has to be for Canada.
Canadian is quick.
We gotta work together.
Clean Antarctica is our own.
We gotta do it for the queen.
May she rest in peace.
She's still our queen.
She's still on her fucking loonies and tunies and all of the
above.
Alright, here we go.
Oh, Canada.
Uh, ho, ho, ho.
What the fuck, Santa?
Oh, shit.
Santa, what the fuck?
Oh, my God, I got distracted by Santa.
Wait, what's up with the...
Okay.
Oh my god.
Oh Canada, our home and native land, true patriot love.
And I forgot the lyrics.
Burn on.
Oh my god, someone quick.
Push him.
Someone push him.
Don't let him get up there.
When do we start eating each other?
The moment he dies, we eat him.
So no one can find his body.
Oh my god, wait, someone.
Oh, I thought that was like the RCMP just now.
How is she always ahead of me?
How?
Oh my god.
Wait, what?
Oh, I don't like that.
Oh my god, it's like it's almost gonna fucking drop or some
shit.
How is it still going?
It's okay.
We can still make it to the top.
Oh my god, how fucking long is this?
Oh, oh.
Whoa.
Oh, I do not like that ladder.
That ladder was a freaky ladder.
That was a freaky-ass ladder.
Wait, there's a present down there, guys.
There's a present down there.
You guys should jump down and get it.
That present looks so good.
Think about the things you can collect.
Oh, my God.
I like this.
Oh.
Guys you're covering up the screen right now There's more Oh
wait that's the end That's the end I see that's light Guys
don't let it Fall, fall, fall
Wait Is that Is that him?
Oh my god we did it
Oh my god we did it I made it it.
We did it, guys.
We're Canada.
Major mountain range of the...
What?
What's this?
What's over here?
Oh my god.
Okay.
I got this.
I'm a profession.
Oh, oh, oh, guys, I don't, oh my god, guys, I don't, guys,
guys, I don't think I'm making it.
Wait, what do you mean that's only part one?
Oh my god, oh my god, I don't think, it's okay, we claimed
this for Canada, though.
It's okay, we claimed this for Canada.
we're getting okay let's get some more gingerbread and i
grab a lantern too wait that's love this is level two you
mean there's
oh my god i just realized i just realized this is level two
oh my god
we made it let's
get okay i thought we'd be like climbing mount everest type
deal i didn't realize it's just parkour we're just
parkouring parkour they all waited for me how nice it's
literally getting it's literally what's it called the the
game where you were climbing the climbing thingy that got
delisted on steam because they had too much copyright shit
getting is it getting no not getting over it no no the only
up this is only up but we're in that nartica are you fucking
kidding oh my god do we get up oh it's here it's only up
guys because we're only going up what
Okay, we did it.
Wait, what is this?
Oh, okay.
Walkie-talkie.
Oh, so it would rescue me.
I don't need rescuing.
I'm a professional.
Wait, where did my flag go?
Canada.
God, I can't see.
Got this.
Canada will be the first country to climb.
Mount Everest.
Come on.
Go to the abandoned one.
Don't be pussies, guys.
Let's all go to the abandoned one.
Come on.
Go, go, go.
Right, right side.
No.
Pixel, go right.
Right.
Guys, right.
Everyone, right.
Everyone, go right.
Everyone, don't be pussies.
I got the safe one.
It's just you and I.
It's you.
It got him.
We did it, guys.
We fucking...
We did it, everyone.
We did it.
Fuck out of the climate.
this okay is this press eat yeah oh my god follow the people
they know which way is the right way
hey i didn't i said everyone but i didn't say also me i
didn't say i should go that way oh my god i can't see but
like i have these guys to see for me What the fuck?
Wait, does he have a snowmobile?
Wait, what?
How do we get a snowmobile?
What the fuck?
Oh, wait, spawn.
Okay, um, I didn't realize there were holes there.
I didn't realize there was a hole.
Guys, wait up, guys!
There was a hole!
Guys, wait up!
For Canada!
Everyone!
Oh my god, everyone's gone!
Guys, for Canada, guys!
Oh.
Oh, oh, there we go.
We gotta drive slowly here, boys.
Ew!
Search!
No!
That's okay.
All right.
We can do this.
Meow.
Forgot it all!
All right, just gotta make sure we don't go too fast here I
gotta slow it down No Wait, I'm still alive, everyone I'm
still here Guys Wait, move me if I can Wait, no Wait Wait
Wait Wait Wait Guys, I don't understand.
I don't understand.
Okay, I still have 880 help HP.
There you go.
wait up, guys.
Guys, you can't leave me.
I'm the honorary Canadian in our expedition group, You can't
leave the honorary Canadian.
Wait, I mean, I'm actually Canadian.
You can't leave the real Canadian.
Guys, I'm not I'm real Canadian.
I'm real I'm Then I bet the the official Canadian Official
oh shit.
Okay, okay Here we go.
I made it guys Here we go.
Oh No, now it's night time Well
What the fuck?
Oh, we just go through.
Oh my god, there's penguins!
They were in the hat!
Oh, whoops.
Sorry there, buddy.
Alright, here we go.
We're okay.
We still have full HP.
Oh, shit.
water, though.
I gotta drink water.
Why don't I get off this car?
Wait, guys.
How did you guys get off?
Oh, you jump.
Okay.
Alright, what next?
Oh, my God.
It's seal time.
Okay, it's time to go.
I still have my flag.
Okay.
Oh, where are the seals?
Where are the fucking seals?
They told me I would meet some silly seals.
Where are they?
Where are my silly seals?
Oh my god, I can't see anything.
I'm a little scared, guys.
I have a lantern, though.
Oh, there's a seal!
There he is!
Oh, I see him.
Oh, the music is quite nice, too.
It's very relaxing.
It's like we're going to cave dive and then get stuck in the
hole.
It's like those scary cave diving stories.
Alright.
We're doing it, everyone.
We're making it.
Oh, we made it to a second cast.
Hey guys!
I am official 124 and I have reached the highest point of
mountain in Antarctica.
Avalanche has it.
Oh, it's low, guys.
Don't worry.
The avalanche is low today.
It's okay.
We'll be fine.
There's no avalanche here.
Amen
We'll be fine guys It says low avalanche Which means we'll
be okay As long as nobody makes any loud noises We'll be
fine How the fuck did this guy reach the highest peak
already We just started We're on mountain number three How
does this guy How are you almost dead too Wait what the fuck
this guy almost dead.
He has zero HP.
Nearly someone can sneeze on him.
And then, like, he'd be dead.
Wait, is that the strat?
Is jumping the strat?
Oh.
A small and dangerous ice fall.
Oh, no.
It's getting a little scary now.
As long as none of us fall, we should be okay.
Guys, we should all be safe.
I think I just saw someone die.
I think I actually just saw someone jump the wrong way.
Okay.
Making it.
Guys, we go to the hard one, guys.
Guys, come on.
To the right.
See, I'll lead the charge.
I'm gonna lead the way.
Guys, come on.
Come on, you guys, pussies.
Guys, don't be pussies now.
Don't do this again.
How come no one believes in me anymore?
Um, oh, shit.
Okay.
See, we're okay.
Um, all I'm saying is, because, like, you guys didn't want
to do advanced with me.
Um, so I had to...
to suck it up and do the baby one.
Like, no one else wanted to do advance.
I was gonna do it.
I'm like, fine.
I guess I'll do the baby route if you guys are all babies.
So what's the point?
What's the point in doing advance route?
If, like, no one can watch me do advance route in game.
Oh my god, here it is.
Wait, is that Zoro?
Wait, how guys using that oh my god i've just been oh this
okay we're climbing
oh i guess we don't touch the ice we don't touch the ice
will be fine
see we're making it there you go
Okay, we're fine, we're fine.
It, like, pulled me back.
Oh, shit, the guy!
The guy is here!
Oh, oh.
Okay.
No.
Alright.
Okay, I think the guy blew the whistle, and then an
avalanche came.
The guy literally fucking blew whistle and then Oh no, I
gotta hydrate Guys, remember to hydrate, guys Wait What can
I hydrate?
Remember to hydrate, everyone Stay hydrated Oh Oh, 7 Oh, 7
Oh, 7 Oh
Oh my god, am I okay?
Oh my god, where am I?
guys don't play the trumpet during an avalanche guys don't
oh my god how do we get back up
there oh mama oh my god oh my god it's another avalanche oh
no we can make it just gotta go parkour okay where are we
where the fuck oh wait we're here
yeah it's not too far from where we ended up okay we made it
we made it we made it we made it we made it guys we gotta
follow the god follow the god he knows what he's doing he's
gonna take us to the promised land
Sherpa.
They'll lead us to the top.
Bum bum.
Bum.
The province land is near.
We made it.
We made it to Mount Vincent.
We're gonna follow the guide.
Follow him.
Where's my flag?
Oh.
We're Canada!
Oh, the music stopped.
Okay.
Which way do we go?
We go down?
Oh, wait.
We don't have that yet.
I was like, down is up?
Oh, my God.
He's dead.
Guys, somebody rescue him.
Oh, my God.
We're just gonna leave him?
Oh, seven.
it's like the it's like mount you remember like the the
landmarks at mount everest
it's like the mount everest landmarks that's the one with
the boots yeah the fucking that's like where we know when we
know we're like there You see the guy...
Wait, is that so...
Why is he going backwards?
They're now a landmark.
Mr. Green Boots.
Sir, I think you're going the wrong way, sir.
Yeah.
Yeah, he's in character.
I gotta make sure there's no gaps in the hole because of you
guys.
all right here we go
this is basically a difficult game about climbing if you
think about it chat we are climbing technically also weeper
thank you for the five gifted souls thank you thank you this
is technically the same game we were both we're also
climbing here we're climbing as a team chat doing expedition
together
Oh my god.
How far have we gone?
We climbed so far.
Is that our Sherpa?
Yeah, that is.
That is our Sherpa.
Sir, how much do we have left, sir?
Are we close to the top?
Oh my god, this is just as hard as a real expedition.
Oh, seven.
Hey, this is your fault!
This is your fault.
I-07, your body.
Oh my god, wait, rescue me!
Wait, search and rescue E!
E!
Take me back!
Take me back to the place!
Take me over!
How do we get searched and rescued?
I demand to be searched and rescued.
I Don't understand you were not helpful How
Okay Lost I'm lost I'm lost.
I'm lost right now.
I demand help.
No, no, no, no, no.
We do not.
No, no, no, we do not.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no.
I'm lost.
I am lost.
I am rescued.
No!
Please!
Rescue me!
I don't understand!
That's it.
Wait, how do I...
Where's my plane?
That's looking it.
That's it.
We go.
Fly!
Let's go.
We shall...
I still have the flag.
Let's fly to the top.
Let's go.
We got this.
We're searching rescue and I'm being rescued.
Oh my god, look at all these people that are dying.
Oh my god, look at all these landmarks.
Holy fuck, they're actual landmarks over there.
Oh my god, why is there so...
many dead people there but these real people they'll fly
over them no get down get down we don't need to rescue them
wait wait wait wait wait come back wait come back wait wait
come fucked up wait come back come back wait wait wait wait
wait oh there you go yes right loses wait what hey what how
do you guys go up how you make plane go up
wait how did you guys make plane go up Wait, how do you guys
drive?
How to drive?
I'm trying to figure out how to drive!
Wait, how the fuck did she do it?
How come I can't drive the helicopter?
How are you?
Well, I don't get it.
drive the helicopter how are we supposed to pick people up
if we can't get the helicopter you are not helpful you are
not helpful all they can do is sit in the passenger seat no
wait go up go go go go go wait is that the furthest we can
go ain't got no gas there's no way she fucking oh wait he
fucking flew the plane there's no way I can't believe it I'm
not I don't I'm not fucking oh my god that's a top what the
hell
I can die this guy's not making it look at him look at him
die no no
yeah fucking what do you mean ain't got no gas
this is not fair this is not fair bro come on bro come on
i'm gonna jump oh my god oh my god it's okay it's okay i
have i have i'm back to 100 health that's okay there you go
we're fine i use the help for myself all right we keep going
we keep going
Wait, you have a helicopter, too?
We're not safe.
Why are we saving him?
Oh, he's fine.
It's fine.
Oh my god, there's another landmark right there.
Yeah, I see that.
Wait, is that the next checkpoint?
Wait, that's the next one.
Wait, no, that's not it.
That's not the next one.
We go back up.
Wait, is that actually the next checkpoint?
Oh my god, it is.
It's over there.
Yeah.
I think that's the next checkpoint We made it That's okay We
made it We did it We did
it Oh my god we're so good at this game guys Wait search in
red rescue we're so good at this I want my own helicopter
there you go that's fucking right I've got my own helicopter
now don't worry I'll go rescue them guys here take the route
don't worry I'll rescue you
where's the next mountain
here wait there's someone over there hey guys yeah I wish
you were in my helicopter don't you huh that's a king right
oh my god so we're Borealis who's over there what the fuck
wait I can't take the helicopter in there that's a natural
volcano we can't save this man wait no how do I descend
imagine having having to do this by foot I imagine that wait
how Why don't I fucking descend?
Don't worry.
I still don't know.
It's okay.
I can grab another helicopter.
With our taxpayers' money, we can grab another helicopter.
Oh, I got the helmet, too.
I'm perfectly safe.
Oh What cap is this?
Oh What cap are we in right now?
Oh
No, I don't have insurance for this cap.
Oh Oh no.
Oh no.
What do you mean, Cap 2?
Hey guys.
Guys.
Guys, I need help.
Someone, please.
I need help.
I'm lost.
I need help to get back to my cab.
I can't.
I left my helicopter.
Wait, where do we go?
Wait, where's the next area anyway?
Guys, I can't.
I left my helicopter.
I think.
I think we're stuck here.
I think we might be stuck here.
I don't think we're ever completing area.
I don't remember where the water parkour is.
Guys, is it around here?
Guys, where's the water parkour?
Where is it?
My poor plate.
I left my plate.
It might be over, chat.
Oh
Take me to my helicopter.
I got searched and rescued.
Let's go
We got searched and rescued guys.
We did it guys
Wait fuck is this?
Where are we going?
What is this place?
What?
What do you see over here?
Oh, it's a journal.
It's a dot.
It's lore.
It's okay.
We will beat the mountain.
Don't worry.
I'll go on this one.
This guy knows where he's going.
Don't worry.
We will conquer the mountain.
We are search and rescue Oh my god, don't worry.
I got the flag too for Canada
There oh we're stuck we're stuck here.
We're stuck it's fine It's fine we're still stuck here.
Okay, we might be blocked a little bit, but that's okay
away all right here we go he has cancelled the help that's
look at us go
look at that imagine we actually searched and helped oh no
no no no no no no no No, no, no, no, no.
Oh, there's my helicopter.
Guys, guys.
Drop me off at my helicopter, guys.
There it is.
Take me to my helicopter.
We're almost there.
Oh, my God.
Okay, okay.
I got, okay.
You gotta make sure.
Okay.
All right.
We can do this.
We gotta make sure I don't die here.
Okay.
All right.
I'm gonna get off.
in oh you're getting higher you're getting higher bro okay
okay okay oh whoa whoa whoa guys guys guys i'm having doubts
now okay all right ready in three oh i don't think i can
make that guys i'm a little worried How did you?
Okay.
Okay, this is...
Okay, I don't know.
I feel like if I drop out, I will... I will die.
I will die.
Sir, you have to park the plane.
Okay.
Alright, it's fine.
You there.
You.
Okay, okay.
My plan.
The other helicopter.
Pick me up.
All right, all right, I'm ready.
Okay, right here.
All right.
All right, we go, we park.
We park down there.
And then we park down.
Okay, okay, wait, wait, wait.
There we go.
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I got this.
Here we go.
I don't think we're making it.
I don't think we're gonna make it.
It's okay, it's okay.
It's time for, it's time to giggle caroling.
Anyway, guys, I'm gonna...
Alright.
Okay, I'm gonna grab water, guys.
Kids, kids.
Timmy and Yimmy.
You too.
Play nice, Timmy and Yimmy.
Okay?
I'm gonna go grab water.
Mama's gonna get some water for the Christmas before we go
Christmas Kierling.
So you two play nice.
Okay, guys.
I'll be right back.
My food's here, too.
And buy my foods, y'all.
I want to grab my food, too.
All right.
Did you guys get along?
Did Timmy and Yimmy?
Did you both got along, guys?
Okay, let me eat my food first before we go Carolyn, guys.
Mama got to eat.
Hungy.
So I shall never believe you, Timmy.
What did you guys do?
What, Toki, Yimmy is being, what did you do?
Yimmy is being.
mean as yemi what did you okay sorry yemi what did you do to
timmy
i hate you yemi what did you two do no timmy is the bully
they're gaslighting
timmy is just overreacting Timmy kicked us.
Timmy, is that true?
Did you kick Yimmy?
Oh, sorry.
Yeah, Timmy, sorry.
Timmy, is that true?
Did you kick Yimmy?
Surely no money will look over.
Thank you, Mr. Chat.
Leon.
Thank you.
I'm truly thinking of a five-gifted toast.
Yimmy did it first.
Is that true?
Yimmy, did you kick Timmy first?
Next day, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's a Jewish tradition to get Chan his food on Christmas.
Is there a dish you particularly recommend?
Which is like mouth-watering chicken.
It's so good.
It's like cold chicken drenched in chili oil.
And it's so fucking good.
And total C, which is shredded potatoes.
It's like sour vinegar shredded to potatoes.
And it's so fucking good too.
favorites.
I'm treating Timmy and Yemi both equally.
I don't have favorites.
You're both equal in my eyes.
I'm just slightly better.
You guys gotta fight for mommy's affections, guys.
Then maybe I'll have a favorite.
Bird, thank you Super chat, thank you, thank you.
Remember, we're your favorite.
Mehdi, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Now how come Timmy got a PS5 for Christmas?
You got...
You got an Xbox.
Is that not good enough?
It's the console wars.
Mr. Broken Bond, thank you for the super chat, thank you,
thank you.
Timmy is using his status as the oldest of Boilies.
Please punish Timmy to the timeout chair.
Look, one got an Xbox, the other got a PlayStation, and then
mom, mommy, got a PC with a 50-90.
Mama got the PC.
That's too damn bad if you guys wanted the PC.
I worked very hard for this PC.
over here right template thank you for the thousand videos
thank you thank you yeah of course i'm my number one fan i'm
my own i'm if you want me to if you really want to know who
the favorite is i am the favorite here
you guys will never work together you have to barely touch
each other you're not you're not even allowed to be like
close to each other why do you think have to sit in the
middle you
guys are legally not allowed to work together or or or timmy
gets deleted timmy gets taken away for custody or does it
come when they take away your children the service where you
have to call someone and take away the kids
cps yeah cp if you two get close to each other cps will come
over and take timmy away
i know you guys can't even work together
yeah they give us 100 pennies thank you thank you timmy
stole our playstation why can't you two share you have both
consoles yes they do Yes, they do.
CPS will only take Timmy away.
Yimmy is fine.
Timmy's the one with more regulations.
Timmy, your father?
Your father is very strict.
I break one rule in the custody.
And that's custody agreement.
And it's over, Timmy.
Why do you think, like, I only get you on on the weekends
every other week to me but this is a i made a special deal
with your dad that i can i can bring both of you along for
christmas who's the father amazon
yeah when your dad when your dad finds out that you got
close to yimmy he's gonna call the cps on me And we can't
have that.
I gotta get my child's...
I gotta get my child's support.
Whenever I get paid.
You know, Timmy?
Whenever mommy gets a paycheck from your daddy, that's the
child's support for taking care of you.
My paycheck from Amazon.
And Yimmy, we don't know who your real father is.
I'm sorry.
That's why you get to stay with me longer.
All right.
I am done now.
I'm done eating.
I do have more food that I ordered, but I don't want to get
too bloated for caroling.
All right.
We're gonna do Christmas caroling now, Timmy and Yimmy.
So, um, ladies, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hi, Joki.
Here, it's already the 26th.
Can I get a happy birthday, please?
Also, the other day, while catching VODs.
I heard about you wanting new videos, and I appreciate that.
It's hard to catch streams.
Yeah, we're at 2026.
I'm gonna be doing, I'm gonna be posting videos.
I'm still trying, in the process of trying to find the
perfect editor for us.
because I do want, like, you know, very, I'm very stickler
when it comes to, like, videos and stuff, because videos
have to be, like, in a way where the people who, to make
sure that people don't click away.
So I have to figure out, like, what kind, I have to figure,
like, you know, gotta look through a bunch of editors and
stuff to find the perfect one for us, the perfect match.
But yeah, anyway, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Happy birthday to you.
All right, guys.
So, Timmy, Yimmy, we're going to go grab the others, all
right?
So, we're going to go out and grab the other.
I'm going to go out and grab the others.
So, I'll be right back to me and Yimmy.
I've realized, if it feels confusing, I realized I sort of
made a mistake in this and the way I set this up.
So, I don't know how to segue to this bit that I have.
So to all the Timmy's and Yimmy's that aren't here with me
today, we're gonna go grab them real quick.
Okay, guys?
All right, give me a sec.
Give me a sec.
I'll be back very soon, Timmy and Yimmy's.
We're just gonna grab the other Timmy's and Yimmy's to make
sure we have enough backup seniors for the Christmas
caroling, guys.
Like I said, I realize I forgot how to, I don't know how, I
realize I have like an oversight in terms of how to set this
up, but like this is a good bit, I swear to God.
Hi.
Hey.
Open up.
Gibby.
Sorry to go Christmas caroling.
Hey.
I clicked the wrong thing.
What are you doing?
It's Christmas caroling time.
It's 6.30.
Well, it's 6.48.
What are you doing, huh?
Get over here.
Hey.
Hello?
Open up.
Come on.
Don't you want to go Christmas caroling?
Hello?
I posted the schedule.
Why aren't you here?
I know you're in there I saw the lights were on The lights
were on I saw it
Man Open up
Don't you want to go Christmas caroling With the other
Timmy's and Yimmys You didn't show up to the Roblox party I
sent you a couple of letters did you not get my evite hello
did you get my evite I sent an evite did you get it don't
worry don't worry okay look get your ring cam on your ring
cam on come on get it on hello
Timmy, Timmy's, Yimmy's, it's time.
Is it Thursday?
Is Thursday?
Yeah.
Thursday is my day.
I got you guys on Thursday.
Our agreement was that I get you guys on Thursday.
Hello?
Sorry, I could only fit like a couple of the Timmy's and
Yimmy's in my van like the more timmies and yimmies i have
for christmas caroling the more the more tips we're gonna
get so i need to bring you a lot man in the agreement in the
agreement we agreed that every thursday i get the holidays
and i also get thursdays so you both have to come out
Mama's getting angry now
Mama's angry Don't worry I'll give you guys a Guys alright
how about this How about I'll give you guys A little Also
I'm wearing a t-shirt too Mama's cold too I forgot to put on
a jacket A little bit messed up there Don't worry don't
worry It's okay I'll sing my way I'll sing my way to your
hearts.
Mama shouldn't have left their keys.
I forgot to get my jacket.
Alright.
Don't worry.
We'll start caroling.
I'll give you a sneak peek on what you're missing out.
I'm just finding the song right now.
I know it's like quiet.
It's a little awkward that it is quiet.
But don't worry.
I'm just I'm just grabbing the song right now.
Okay, I brought my I brought my boom box Okay, I'm just
trying to find this I'm trying to find the cassette tape for
my boom box to play the right song for us Let's see wait is
this the right song
You want me to freeze to death to me and you be is this the
right one
god no this is not the right song sorry sorry mama is like
messing up guys don't worry don't worry we're gonna go
caroling very soon i just i messed up a little bit
wait they don't have bum diddy diddy diddy bum bum
bum bum bitty bitty bitty bum bum i'll call the bum bitty
bitty bitty bong you guys want to come out now do you guys
do you guys want to do you guys want to come out and go
christmas caroling with me now oh hey oh there you go there
you go don't worry guys here we go bum bitty bitty bitty
bitty bum bum don't worry guys Here we go.
I'm
so like crazy for not realizing that.
Why would we give way to water packs?
So we could use it as a blanket?
Here we go.
That's the reaction I thought I'd get.
I don't know what the instrument is.
This room has been associated with ideated with basketball
at the mall of various old jobs.
He runs around town for free or at most odd dollar.
Fire up!
So rudely it's made fun of his feet Or boys, a sister, a
shortness When he wasn't looking But the next time you see
him He'd still go out of his way to smile And where about
you when I ask you About your mother's separation Or
something like that Because he unlike us Actually cares
about someone other than himself The reason I bring this up
to you Is because I was the worst offender
Going nowhere, then the tiny little man rushed to my side.
He should have gotten a big thank you.
Instead he got poured a potty ride.
I'm here for the chorus, guys.
Why am I seeing this part?
This part's not important.
Whoa, freaky?
Never watch some football.
A fuzzy screen was all that we could see.
Whitey came over with a hanger.
Spent the game atop a TV.
Wow!
Oh my god, please, hurry.
I'm here for the chorus.
Come on.
Get to the good part.
Sorry.
Sorry, don't worry, Christmas Carol will go a lot better
when we're outside.
Whoa, I don't remember this line.
Whoa.
Where is the part?
I gotta get some wine.
Who said starting with the worst?
This is a classic.
I just, I don't care about this part of the song.
I just need the chorus.
Oh, and the last night of heart goes just not fair.
Bum bitty bitty bitty bum bum.
Bum bitty bitty bitty bum.
Wonder if that guy ever wiped his ass with the wrong hand.
Bum bitty bitty bitty bitty bum bum.
Bum bitty bitty bitty bum.
Bum bitty bitty bitty bum bum.
Bum bitty bitty bitty bum Bum bitty bitty bitty bum bum Bum
bitty bitty bitty bum
All right, Timmy, Yimmy Do you guys want to go out now to
Kierling?
We got a lot more of these too
I put that as the first song on my list But then I'd never
listen to the first part of the song.
I've always just listened to like, um, to the ending part.
And I was like, oh, I do not remember this part.
Bum bitty bitty bitty bum bum.
All right, we'll do a real song now.
Okay, we'll give you a look, look, Timmy, Yimmy.
I'll give you a real song now.
So you know what it's like to go Christmas caroling with
your mom.
All right, all right, here you go.
or do a real one
all right yeah jingle bells jingle bells jingle all the way
oh what fun it is to ride in a one horse open sleigh yeah
jingle bells jingle bells jingle all the way oh what fun it
is to ride in a one horse open sleigh dashing through the
snow In a one horse open sleigh Over the fields we go
Laughing all the way Ha ha!
Bells on bobtails ring Making spirits bright What fun it is
to laugh and sing A slaying song tonight Oh jingle bells
Batman smells Robin laid an egg Oh what fun is to ride In a
one horse open sleigh Hey!
Jingle bells Jingle bells Jingle all the way What fun it is
to ride in a one horse open sleigh Day or two ago, I thought
I'd take a ride And soon Miss Fanny Bright was seated at my
sign The horse was lean and length, misfortune seemed his
lot We got into a drifted bank and then we got upset Oh,
jingle bells, jingle bells, jingle all the way Oh, what fun
it is to ride in a one horse open sleigh Oh, jingle bells,
Batman smells, Robins laid an egg Oh, what fun it is to ride
a one-horse open sleigh Dashing through the snow, and a
one-horse open sleigh Over the fields we go, laughing all
the way, ha ha, wails on bobtails ring, making spirits
bright What fun it is to laugh and sing a slaying song
tonight Oh, jingle bells, jingle bells, jingle bells all the
way.
Oh, what fun it is to ride in a one-horse open sleigh.
Hey!
Jingle bells, jingle bells, jingle all the way.
Oh, what fun it is to ride in a one-horse open sleigh.
There we go.
I sang a real song, guys.
Instead of bum-bitty-bitty-bitty-bitty-bitty.
All right, now would you guys come outside with me to go
Christmas caroling, guys?
Will you guys now come outside?
Too cold.
I'm literally wearing a t-shirt right now.
It's my day.
It is my day.
And I'm going Christmas caroling.
All right, how about this?
What the fuck is this, son?
Santa, oh, like, run Rudolph, run.
I've never heard of this song before.
Let's see.
Santa Claus is coming to town.
Yeah, if I can go out while it's snowing in just my t-shirt,
you guys can come.
Okay, I'll do one more song, and you guys are also coming
out to Christmas caroling.
I know where the keys are.
I wanted to let you guys open the door for me, because I
assume you guys...
you know i assume that you guys would you know you know
would open it up yourself but because you did not i shall
now grab my key after this song i'm gonna go grab the key
and unlock the door myself i'm gonna drag you out with me i
just wanted to like test you guys to see if you'll open the
door and clearly you failed the test you failed the test so
now i'm angry i'm angry now I'll give you one more song.
I'm going to give you one more sound song and then count the
three for you to open the door.
Let it snow, let it snow, let it snow.
Wait, what song is that?
What song am I humming right now?
What do you mean weird person?
What do you mean?
I have custody of you!
What song is that?
Oh,
is that?
Is it this one?
I don't even know the audio.
I sang this a lot when I was in private school.
King, the sisters walked the crowd on the feast of semen.
When the snow lay round about deep and crisp and even.
Brightly shone the moon that night through the frost was
cruel.
came in sight gathering winter fuel oh my gosh thither page
and stand by me if thou knows it's telling yonder pleasant
who is he where in what his dwelling saw he lives a good
leak hence underneath the mountain right against the forest
fence by st agnes fountain.
Oh, I fucked that up.
It's been a while since I was in a church.
Time walks hither through thou and shall see him.
It's not because, like, you know, I'm not allowed in a
church.
I just haven't been in a church in a while.
And by a while, I meant, like, decades.
Through the rude winds, wild lemon, and the bitter weather.
I remember there was a song that's not it's like the same
tune and but it's not this lyrics so stronger files my heart
i know not how i can go no longer mark my footsteps my good
page dread thou in them boldly thou shalt find the winter's
rage freeze thy blood less coldly
the peatrod where the snow lay dinted he was in the very sod
which the saint had printed therefore christian men be sure
wealth or rank possessing me who shall but what was the poor
shall yourself find blessing i don't remember these lyrics i
remember the two oh my god i can't believe it like like as a
kid i sang that song because it's like the lyrics are like
like i definitely did not understand this song when i tried
to sing this as a kid i still don't i i still don't really
understand all right that's it you're coming outside i don't
care put our clothes coming in like we're going outside all
right and then montage of me breaking into the house and
dragging you outside whoa sorry let me put the color back
inside me
give me a sec there we go sorry i had to put color back to
my soul i breached the defenses all right so we have yimmy
here yimmy here and being one of my backup singers and then
Timmy here is going to be selling matches for us so we can
you know double the profits and everything and also for
anyone that loves you know a family look we're the family
and I we're having Christmas caroling with the family
together and if anyone walking by you know we're out in the
cold look at poor Timmy over there he has to sell matches to
afford the on his back guys and look at yimmy look at him he
has to carol out here on christmas day we're here busking
our asses off right now so that we can afford um oh my god
oh my god it's so cold look look guys it's so cold outside
that timmy is yimmy is practically frozen right now don't
worry don't worry timmy get the match closer bring it to
yimmy real quick Help, help, yimmy out.
Don't worry, we fixed you.
Don't worry, so, um,
no worries.
See, you're okay now.
You're okay, Betty.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Joshua, thank you for the super chat.
Someone broke into my, uh, rude.
Thank you with 10 gifted subs.
Thank you.
You're right.
Let me, oh man, I definitely need, let me put on a shirt on
real quick.
There we go.
There you are, I should be fine.
I'm fine now.
I don't know about, uh, Tray, we'll put it on, wait for the
Christmas spirit.
All right, there you go.
I have, I have a Tray, uh, you two will be fine.
You guys have hats.
You, you, you, you give me the gift, 10 gifted socks.
Thank you, thank you.
But yes, we're here busking right now.
Um, these poor kids, these poor Timmy and Yimmy, they're so,
they have to work on christmas day so they can be able to
afford dinner later on guys so if you guys want to help out
poor timmy and yimmy over here oh you know that that's yimmy
and that's timmy feel free to you know he's selling matches
he's singing carols with me um feel free to support your
local small businesses i am the business right here
Trish, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Mr. Thank you for the 500 bitties, thank you, thank you.
Do bitties count.
Yeah, yeah, don't worry, don't worry.
Bitties are your 100% count as well, guys.
Don't worry.
All right, we'll do a little classic here.
All right, here we go.
Yeah, it's the perfect song for me and the kids.
You know, Dasher and Dancer and Prancer and Vixen, Common
and Cupid and Donner and Blitzen.
But do you recall the most famous reindeer of all?
Rudolph the Red-Nosed Reindeer and a very shiny nose.
And if you ever saw it, you would even say it closed.
All of the other reindeers Used to laugh and call him names
They never let poor Rudolph Join in any reindeer games Then
one foggy Christmas Eve Santa came to say Yimmy, why aren't
you singing?
Rudolph with your nose so bright Won't you guide my sleigh
tonight?
Then how the reindeers love Tim as they shout it out with
glee Rudolph the red nose reindeer You'll go down in history
Yay Tim you're doing great doing great with those matches
Yumi you're supposed to be a back-up dancer Look Timmy's
singing along and he doesn't have to sing along
That's right, good job, Yumi.
Good job.
Our schedule said Christmas caroling.
Where is my Christmas caroling?
Yumi having...
Yay!
Bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada-bada.
Rudolph the Red-Nosed Reindeer had a very shiny nose.
And if you ever saw it, you would even say it glows.
All of the other reindeers used to laugh and call him names.
They never let poor Rudolph join in any rude air games.
Then one foggy Christmas Eve, Santa came to say, Rudolph
with your nose so bright.
Yimmy, you're flat.
You got my sleigh tonight.
Then how the reindeer loved him as they shouted out with
glee.
Rudolph the red nose drained.
You'll go down in hysteria Alright, Yumi, look, I know this
is your first time going out caroling But come on, buddy You
have the lyrics right in front of you Timmy, you know what?
You know what?
Okay, that's, you know what?
We swap, we swap jobs I think Timmy might be a better singer
than Yumi We're gonna have to swap roles here Let me see,
alright, let's see you.
This is, I assume, okay, that's where, where are your, where
is your, okay, that's the hat?
What the fuck?
Okay, there it is.
I found it.
I think this is it?
Yeah, all right.
All right.
Jimmy, you're going to give your brother here.
The thing and then, and then Timmy, you're going to give the
matches to Jimmy.
So that's his job now.
All right.
This is, is now your turn to sing timmy i believe in you you
were singing along with me even though you it wasn't your
job so so timmy you get to sit do be backup singers now and
then but if you if you if you mess up timmy i'm gonna be
angry but and yimmy now you just just sell your matches
yimmy just
you got you got this it's not that difficult Let's see,
Timmy could do it.
And like, you know, if he was able to do it, you should be
able to do it too.
You know me.
Don't give Jimmy fire.
What do you mean?
What's wrong with his?
What's wrong with him and fire?
Let's see.
What do you?
Where's some fun Christmas songs?
I would love to do Felice Navidad, but like, I literally
only know, like, one part of the song.
And it's...
Also, I know I asked you guys if the instrumental is too
loud or okay, but I didn't really look at chat when I asked
that.
I didn't look at either of my chats.
So is the instrumental okay, guys?
I hope I'm not hurting your ears to me and Yumi.
is it okay it's fine okay i can do it loud if it needs to be
yeah
all right get ready for my espanol i'm sorry i'm sorry to
all spanish people oh wait wait i already missed my cue
there was only one cue and i already missed it i apologize
in advance to all my Spanish speaking dragons out there that
will be listening to this right now.
It's like when I say, it's like when I say tortilla.
Tortilla.
Tortillas.
Yeah.
Feliz Navidad.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Prosperano y Felizidad.
I want to wish you a Merry Christmas Whoa!
I want to wish you Merry Christmas I want to wish you a
Merry Christmas From the bottom of my heart I want to wish
you a Merry Christmas I want to wish you a Merry Christmas I
want to wish you a Merry Christmas on the bottom of my
heart.
Felix Navida yeah!
Feliz Navida Feliz Navida Prosperano y Felicida Feliz Navida
Feliz Navida Feliz Navida Prosperano y Felicida I want to I
wanna wish you a Merry Christmas.
I wanna wish you a Merry Christmas.
I wanna wish you a Merry Christmas from the bottom of my
heart.
I wanna wish you a Merry Christmas.
I wanna wish you a Merry Christmas from the bottom of my
heart.
Oh my God, go Timmy, go, your turn.
Come on, Timmy.
yeah yeah to me all right give me some give me go come on
give me you know your cue yeah give me everyone wish you a
merry Christmas I want to wish you a Merry Christmas I want
to wish you a Merry Christmas from the bottom of my heart.
I wanna wish you a Merry Christmas.
I wanna wish you a Merry Christmas from the bottom of my
heart.
Feliz Navidad.
Prosperano y Felizidad.
Yay!
We did it, guys!
We sang as a family!
We did it!
Good job, you, Yumi.
You redeemed yourself today.
You were in tune and everything.
I'm proud of you, Yumi.
You did it.
And you sold matches, too.
Hello, everyone.
If you guys like our performances, we do take tips.
but you know these kids they're so cool and they've been
wearing they've been wearing the same hat for like 10 plus
years now and like but i just can't afford to buy the new
hats so they're seeing their hearts out so they could get
new hats guys
We're bonding.
You, Timmy, and Yimmy.
Guys, when was the last time you get to bond with each
other?
Huh?
When was the last time Timmy and Yimmy, both of you, have
ever get to be together, especially on Christmas?
Okay, thank you for the biddies.
Thank you, thank you.
Um, Congo, thank you for the super chat.
I think Doki would be the type to pronounce for Frihole's.
Isn't it Frijoles?
Frijoles?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright, next song.
Hope you all enjoyed Felice Navida.
All the people walking by us right now.
I hope everyone walking by us enjoyed.
Felice Navida.
Yeah.
I wanna wish you a Merry Christmas Whoa, I wanna wish you a
Merry Christmas Hey, let's see you Oh my god, I accidentally
made Christmas caroling like two and a half hours I think I
missed, I count the time wrong It was not supposed to be two
and a half hours long But I guess we're gonna be out in the
streets for two and a half hours hours, kids.
Wait, Santa tell me.
Wait, is that the... Wait, no, that's different.
That's Ariana Grande.
Wait, we shouldn't play Ariana Grande on Twitch.
We shouldn't do a karaoke of Ariana Grande.
I don't trust... I don't know.
I don't have the music VOD track thingy, so I don't know.
I don't trust it.
Let's say, here comes Santa Claus, here comes Santa Claus.
Is
that the right here comes Santa Claus?
Why is it fucking sung by Elvis Presley?
Is it this?
Is this sung by originally Elvis Presley?
Here comes Santa Claus, here comes Santa Claus, right down
Santa Claus lane.
Vixen and Blitzen and all his reindeer pulling on the reins.
children singing all is merry and bright hang your stockings
and say a prayer because Santa Claus comes tonight here
comes Santa Claus here comes Santa Claus right down Santa
Claus lane he's got a bag that's filled with toys for boys
and girls again hearing those sleigh bells jingle jangle
what a beautiful And cover up your head, because Santa Claus
coming tonight.
Here comes Santa Claus, here comes Santa Claus, right down
Santa Claus lane.
He doesn't care if you're rich or poor, he loves you just
the same.
Santa knows that we're God's children and makes everything
right.
Fill your hearts with Christmas cheer, because Santa Claus
comes tonight.
Santa Claus, here comes Santa Claus Right down Santa Claus
lane He'll come around When the chimes ring out It's
Christmas morning again Peace on earth We'll come to awe If
we just follow the light Let's give thanks To the Lord above
Cause Santa Claus comes tonight Santa Claus Cause comes
Tonight
Uh Uh Santa Claus won't save you.
I mean, Merry Christmas, everyone!
Yay!
We're having a great time.
Right, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Merry Christmas!
Yay!
Aren't you guys having fun?
guys all right you're all having a wonderful time spending
Christmas with me there's a song I'm trying to remember that
you still love seeing I am see first-time chatter he's
having a great time look at that let it snow let it snow let
it snow wait what is this oh yeah how does this song goes I
I saw mom kissing Santa Claus.
I'll never actually remember how this one goes, but I'm
curious what the instrument of this night.
The Jackson 5.
Let's do it.
From the Jackson 5.
Paid actor.
Oh my god.
From the Jackson 5.
It's not too loud, right?
The instrumental.
Yeah, so I showed up to the door.
I'm doing bum bitty bitty bitty bum bum
Oh my god, that's high.
Yeah, you know which one was Michael Jackson's part That is
so high.
Yeah.
Yeah, I can't do that I do it unfortunately I do not have
Michael Jackson's range which is I know it's it really sucks
guys Joy to the world.
Let's do that.
I, unfortunately, I know.
Unfortunately, I can't even do that.
Seriously, I'm sorry.
Wait, why is this so slow?
Oh, this is Mariah Carey's version of Joy to the World.
I was like, what the fuck?
This is a slow-ass Joy to the World.
All right, here we go.
Christmas caroling.
We gotta get the Christmas spirit.
Joy to the world.
The Lord is come.
Let Earth receive her King.
Oh, my God, it's high.
Let every heart prepare our prayer room And heaven nature
sing And heaven and nature sing And heaven and nature sing
Oh my god, I forgot how high this is I will say, I sang this
as a kid So like, clearly I Puberty happened for me Joy to
the world, the Savior rings.
I'm like, oh my God, last time I sang this was when I was a
child during Mass.
The Savior rings.
Let man their songs implode.
Well fields and floods, rocks, hills, and plains.
Repeat the surrounding joy.
Repeat, repeat the sounding joy Oh, joy to the world, the
Savior rings Let men, their songs implode While fields and
floods, rock hills and plains Repeat the sounding joy,
repeat the sounding joy The sound and joy Holy fuck Sorry
God I like The song is joy to the world But like I swear to
God We sing joy to the world Probably like barely Oh there's
a children chorus of this Would this be easier for me
Is this easier because kids are seeing this Joy to the world
The Lord is Oh my god no the children are higher the
children kids why didn't you sing join the world with me i
didn't bro the guy who would have thought the kids are even
higher that's crazy my ava maria that shit that shit is
beautiful but i don't i have a feeling that i will not be
able to sing that
Do I remember like some of my favorite Christmas songs?
The cheetah girls have yourself a merry little Christmas.
What the fuck did they sing?
Alright, Timmy, Yimmy.
Do you have any song suggestions?
Timmy and Yimmy.
Great song?
I don't think I've heard of it.
I don't think I can fucking just do it off the bat.
here this song i can do it's not really christmas but it has
it's in fall snow but i know i can do this song it we're
gonna do something that's not choir related yeah that's a
classic from my end oh yeah i keep asking the instrumentals
okay and i keep looking away i'm sorry i should listen more
to my kids
Snowmiser It is fine Okay I just worried that it's too low
Instrumental I mean I could get it higher Look it is
unfortunate The sound team Is not It's not around right now
Fly me to the moon It is a low not know that i'm sorry i'm
sorry the instrumental is low and you gotta hear my voice
there you go elsa do you want to build a snowman come on
let's go and play we never see you anymore come out the door
it's like you've gone away we used to be best buddies and
now we're not i wish you would tell me why you want to build
a snowman it doesn't have to be a snowman okay bye okay and
then i age up a little bit here 10 years past he really
starts hitting
You want to build a snowman?
We're riding bikes around the homes.
I think some company is overdue.
I've started talking to the pictures on the walls.
Hang in there, Joan.
It gets a little lonely.
All these empty rooms.
Just watching the hours take by.
And then her parents die.
Rest in peace.
Goodbye.
Like every Disney movie, the parents never live.
I built a character.
But this isn't a Disney movie to me and Jimmy.
I'll be alive forever.
You got to get rid of me.
07 to Anna and Elsa's parents.
That's right.
Elsa, please.
I know you're in there.
People are asking where you've been.
They say have courage, and I'm trying to.
I'm right out here for you.
Just let me in.
We only have each other.
Just you and me.
What are we gonna do?
You
want to build a snowman?
Whoa!
Yeah!
Frosty, the snowman, was a jolly happy soul With a corn cob
pipe and a button nose And his eyes ring out of coal Frosty,
the snowman, made the children And were they surprised when
before their eyes he came to life that day?
There must have been some magic in that old silk hat they
found.
For when they placed it on his head, he began to dance
around.
Whoa, Frosty, the snowman was alive as he could be.
And the children say he could laugh and play just the same
as you and me.
Frosty the snowman knew the sun was hot that day.
So he said let's run in we'll have some fun before I melt
away.
Down to the village with a broomstick in his hand, running
here and there all around the square saying catch me if you
can.
He led them down the streets of town right to the traffic
cop.
And only pause a moment when they heard him holler, stop.
Frosty, the snowman, had to hurry on his way.
But he waited by saying, don't you cry, I'll be back again
someday.
Thumpity, thump, thump, thumpity, thump, thump, look at
Frosty, go.
Thumpity, thump, thump,
Look at that, guys.
Look, Elsa built the snowman with Anna.
That was not flat at all.
It worked out perfectly.
I don't know how the fuck Frosty instacute after.
Look at that, guys.
Stop, stop resisting.
Frosty, get the snowman.
It worked out perfectly.
it's a happy ending everyone they built the snowman together
look at that look at that guys they did it
of all the things they could play i know i was like oh
that's good timing all right let's see there's another song
i want to sing wait actually maybe i wrote it down Sometimes
I write down fun songs to sing, but sometimes I don't.
Did I, it's like, did I do it or no?
Well, okay, I really want to sing this song, but I'm so bad
at this song.
Also, I don't know if I get away with it.
As in like, I don't know if like Twitch would let me.
That's the hardest part with multi-streaming, with karaoke.
Because like, I don't know.
how how safe i am
all right uh let's see let's uh i mean life is like a banana
here in duck break fuck it let's go at least we still have
youtube proud of their be cautious i'm like okay let's go
like a hurricane.
Here in Duckburg, race cars, lasers, aeroplanes, it's a duck
blur.
Might solve a mystery or rewrite history.
Duck tales, ooh.
Every day they're out there making duck tales, ooh.
Tales of D-ring, do bad and good luck tales, ooh.
Whoa!
Yeah!
When it seems they're heading for Final Curtain Call
deductions never fails That's for certain The worst of
messes Meek-on-sasses Dock-tails, ooh Every day they're out
there making dock-tails Ooh!
Odeering, do bad, and good luck tails.
The danger, watch behind you.
There's a stranger out to find you.
What to do, just grab on to some duck tails.
Oh, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow, meow.
Meow, meow, meow.
I will have to say, I did grow up with the newest for the
DuckTales reboot, not the old one.
Ooh.
DuckTales, ooh.
They're out there making dovetails, ooh.
Tales of Deering, do bad and good luck tales.
There's a little danger, watch behind you.
There's a stranger out to find you.
What to do?
Just grab onto some dovetails.
Every day they're out there making dovetails.
Tales of Deering, do bad, and good luck tales.
Every day they're out there making duck tails Tails, oh
dear, and do that and good luck tails Not ponytails or
cotton tails, no ducktails Yeah!
I wish they made more ducktails.
It was so good, the reboot.
Ooh, fucking fish, he cancelled it.
It was so, I love the reboot so much.
And like, what's his name?
Like, the Dr. Who guy?
He was so good at Scrooge McDuck.
I swear.
Like, I feel like he was like the perfect voice for him.
For Mr. Mc, like, yeah, David, yeah, David Tennant.
David Tennant was so good in it, too.
I'm so sad that they canceled it.
It was such a good show.
They were going to make dark, they were going to have
Darkwing Duck and then Disney canceled it.
Because they were supposed to be, they were going to make a
spin-off.
off of the DuckTales reboot or Darkwing Duck, but they were
like, nah in the end.
I thought it did really well.
Yeah, Darkwing Duck was in DuckTales.
They added a lot of the old classic characters into the
reboot, too.
It's really good.
I feel like every season just got better.
Yeah, David Tennant voices Scrooge McDuck.
It's Disney tradition.
I don't believe in that.
I think they just didn't merchandise it enough.
I think like companies usually always cancel shows when they
can't merchandise it enough.
I heard they're bringing, oh, I heard they're like rebooting
My Little Pony again.
And like, because they keep like, because they made it, for
those who didn't know, like, they've been trying to chase
the original My Little Pony high with the main six, but they
new generation and apparently it failed really badly so
they're rebooting the main six they're literally remaking
like like twilight sparkle and all all of them again i think
it's on the concept art phase they're like okay we're gonna
bring back the original six characters but what if twilight
was an earth pony instead of a unicorn and what if uh uh
pinky pie is a pegasus instead because pegasus um instead of
a uh uh earth pony oh no it's apparently it's gonna be
different animation style yeah they're remaking friendship
is magic but they're because they're like oh why is there
why is the the new generation not making as much money as
the main six
i can't believe weird out banged a pony and had kids For
those who don't know, Weird Al is an actual, like, like,
pony, so has his own pony sona in My Little Pony, and then
he marries Pinkie Pie, and then they had kids.
My Little Pony appears to just mad because of Uma Musume.
My Little Pony walked so Uma Musume could run.
Also, My Little Pony is incredibly popular right now in
Asia, especially in China.
So, like, I won't be surprised that they want to bring back.
friendship is magic just to capitalize on that because it's
insanely popular right now in China I'm too tired for this
lore It's the most wonderful time of the year I know a lot
of the Christmas songs from Glee too
It's the most wonderful time of the year With the kids
jingle belling And everyone telling you'd be of good cheer
It's the most wonderful time of the year It's the happiest
season season of all.
Ding, dong, with those holiday greetings and gay happy
meanings when friends come to call.
It's the happiest season of all.
Yay!
There'll be parties for hosting, marshmallows for toasting,
and caroling out in the snow.
Like right now!
There'll be scary ghost stories and tales of the glories of
Christmas.
Wait, we'll How did this go?
It's the most wonderful time of the year.
I actually did not know that part.
Be much mistletoeing and hearts will be glowing when loved
ones are near.
It's the most wonderful time of the year.
All right, gotta get a drink now.
Mama's gotta drink now in the middle of this song.
There be parties for hosting Marshmallows for toasting
Gareling out soul Gumbay Zero clock In the middle of karaoke
I'm like alright this is drinking time now Most Wonderful
time Of the year There be much Mr. Tome And hearts will be
glowing Who love ones are near It's the most wonderful time
It's the most wonderful time It's the most wonderful time Of
the year Oh wait, sorry I took a sip and I was off key now
It's off tempo I sound a lot happier
let me grab my drink real quick guys let me here we go gompe
yeah you know what wait i should just attach the let me hold
it real quick i think make more sense if i hold it all right
give me a sec i gotta disappear i gotta go grab more drinks
real quick get children stand out here and sell more matches
for me all right give me a sec
yeah all right i'll put this in here all right oh wait all
right
There you go.
Got it.
Kids, I'm back.
Let me...
There you go.
It's the most wonderful time.
Yeah.
No touchy, kids.
No touchy.
This is...
is adult this is a drink for adults only big boys can drink
this this is adult juice kids no touchy oh my favorite all
right i need backup this dance backup singers for this guys
are you guys ready okay wait am i pitch tight enough guys am
i tight enough I like it, Chipmunks.
Ready to sing your song?
Yeah, yeah, I'll see you now.
Okay, Simon.
Okay?
Okay, Theodore.
Okay, Alvin.
Alvin!
Okay!
Christmas, Christmas, time are toys and time for cheer.
We've been good, but we can't last.
Christmas Harry fast Like a prank that moves the loop Me I
think they're adult juice
I do This one That
moves the loop I'm
sick Please Christmas don't be late We can hide And the way,
please Christmas, don't be late.
Let's sing it again.
No, that's enough.
Let's not overdo it.
Let me overdo it.
We wanna sing it again.
Wait a minute, boys.
Wait a minute.
Why can't we sing it again?
You know, Miss Miss, I sing this like, oh my god, I pushed
myself lower.
I've seen this like, not even during Christmas.
I sing it whenever.
I, like, like, everyone knows that it doesn't even matter if
it's Christmas or not.
I always bring it up in karaoke.
But now I actually do, I actually do have an excuse to sing
it now.
I actually do have an excuse to sing it.
Zipper, thank you for the super chat, thank you.
Thank you.
Christmas, Christmas time is near.
It's tradition.
Every karaoke.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Next, thank you, the super chat.
I know it's a bit early, but speaking of My Little Pony, can
we get winter wrap-up?
I don't even think we have a care of fun of it.
Yeah, the only My Little Pony song that's in care of fun is
literally this day under our spell.
Friendship is Magic.
Open up your eyes.
Rainbow from Sia, and I'm the friend you need.
That's all the songs in here.
I'm surprised under a spell, like they have under a spell in
here.
I have all the Equestria Girls songs there are.
Like that was the one that's in the fucking Kira fun.
Bum bitty bitty bitty bum bum.
Santa.
Oh, you guys know whenever we do Santa baby, I'm not the one
singing it.
I mean, you guys really want Santa baby?
You know who's singing Santa Baby.
It's not me who's singing it.
Alright, I gotta go bring him over.
Guys, we're singing Santa Baby.
I gotta bring him over.
Okay, give me a sec.
Alright, kids.
Give me a sec.
I gotta get someone over.
He's gonna be joining us, too.
Let's see.
whoops
all right you guys must be like what the fuck is she do
don't worry you'll understand if you watch the last
christmas carols you'll understand
all right there you go all right
all right all right here you go
the shot.
Don't worry.
The dog is here to babysit you guys now.
The dog is here.
Your babysitter is a dog.
Here we go.
It sounds like you.
You say, woof.
Hoof.
Santa baby, just slip a sable under the tree for me.
I've been an awful good boy, Santa baby.
So hurry down the chimney tonight.
Woof, woof, woof.
Santa baby, a 54 convertible too.
I'll wait up for you, dear, Santa baby.
So hurry down the chimney tonight.
Think of all the fun I missed.
Think of all the girls that I have kissed my mom next year.
just as good if you check off my christmas list home santa
baby i want a yacht and really that's not a lot been an
angel all year santa baby so hurry down the chimney tonight
Santa, honey.
One little thing I really need.
The deed.
To a planet of mine, Santa baby.
So hurry down the chimney tonight.
Santa, cutie.
Fill my stocking with the duplex and checks.
Sign your X on the line Santa cutie and hurry down the
chimney tonight.
Come and trim my Christmas tree with some decorations bought
at Pet Smart.
Really do believe.
Let's see if you believe in me.
Santa baby, forget to mention one little thing.
A caller.
I don't mean on the phone, Santa baby.
So hurry down the chimney tonight.
Hurry down the chimney tonight.
Hurry.
So yeah, I told you, in one Santa baby, you know who's going
to sing it.
And it's our resident playboy right here.
It's...
Grr.
Handsome.
There's a little playboy that sings it.
Wow.
That's what you ask and you shall receive.
All right.
All right, dad.
You gotta go now.
I gotta take you back inside.
You're only wearing a t-shirt.
Timmy, you stay here.
I'll let you in a super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
Goodbye, dad.
Oh my god, his thing fell over.
Oh my god.
He like disappeared and it fell over.
I gotta get that.
I gotta get the antler off of me.
Give me a sec, guys.
Yeah, I get it off of me.
I'm not expected to just fall over like that.
Whoa, what the heck happened there?
Just fell over just like that.
Alright.
Let me just say, I gotta fix this real quick.
quick all right don't worry i'm back all right what's next
whoa we still have an hour left all right guys hmm what do i
want to sing next
Yeah, say goodbye to dad.
He went back home now.
I'm already drunk because I'm fucking Asian.
That's why.
I didn't even drink that much yet.
I'm thinking what song I want to sing next.
What do I want to sing next, actually?
Oh, I have an idea.
no i'm not drunk yet don't worry kids i should actually
hydrate water
every day i imagine a future where i can be with you
Now write a poem of me and you
The ink flows down into a dark puddle Just move your hand
right the way into his heart But in this world of infinite
choices What will it take just to find that special day?
What will it take just to find that special day?
Yeah, dokey dokey.
Yeah, some people sometimes post like dokey dokey leisure
club fan art in our tag.
I guess I think it's the have I found everybody a fun
assignment to do the day.
When you're here, everything that we do is fun for them
anyway.
When I can't even read my own feelings.
What good are words when a smile says it all?
And if this world won't write me an ending, What will it
take just for me to have it all?
I swear, I saw that so many people, like not a lot, but it
would happen occasionally when I get like random dokey dokey
literature club stuff on my like fan tag or like merch tag
Or even like, oh, I think my favorite is when I get bird
watching and bird seeders.
That's my pen.
I'm going to write better words for those who are dear to
me.
Is it love?
If I take your, is it love?
If I set you free.
The ink flows down into a dark puddle.
How can I write love into reality?
the sound of your heartbeat what do you call loving your
reality your reality though I don't know how to love you
I'll leave you me yeah yeah actually we got like bird like
actual bird watchers in our bird cedar tags it's actually
pretty funny also I heard Doki Doki literature club recently
came out on the phone so you play on the phone now
it's absolutely wild that caller I don't mean on the phone
still works out a joke good job thank you I am the improv
queen no thank you to dad he is so good at improv sorry I
didn't mean me sorry guys I meant dad I know he's a lyrical
genius.
He's the next Lin-Manuel.
Yeah, oh my god.
We have the next Lin-Manuel right now.
Take the halls with bells of Bali.
Okay.
Rocking around the Christmas tree.
Oh, I have something perfect for this.
Watch this.
Guys, I gotta get an outfit real quick, kids.
I'll be right back.
I know I keep coming back in and out, but this is very
important, okay?
Like, this outfit is very important for this.
Wait, let me say I didn't put it correctly.
There you go.
All right, here you go.
Don't worry, I'm back.
Watch this.
Yo, the alcohol is hitting hard today.
I got it out of my trunk, guys.
Kids, I got it out of my trunk.
I packed my special, my special head gear for this very
special sound.
Wait, let me, I think I'm gonna get better, but I'm like,
it's like here, right?
Wait, no, it should be like big as, no, it should be like
here, okay?
Right here.
There you go.
We're here all night, everyone.
All night.
Tips.
Anyone want to give you some, give us some tips?
Here we go.
I think it's the same one.
Oh, yes, Michael Bubl and Carly Ray.
Oh, wait.
Is this the right one?
Oh, shit.
Sorry, I found it wrong.
Okay, I found the wrong one.
Rocking around the Christmas tree and the na-na-na.
Gomp, bump, bump.
Whoa!
Yeah!
Rocking around the Christmas tree at the Christmas party
hop.
Gumbay!
Miss a tongue where you can see every couple tries to stop.
the Christmas tree let the Christmas spirit ring later we'll
have some pumpkin pie and we'll do some caroling that's what
we're doing now you will get a Santa wait how does it sound
really when you hear voices singing let's be jolly deck the
halls with bows of holly rocking around the Christmas tree
have a happy holiday.
Everyone dancing merrily in the new old-fashioned way.
.
What a sentimental feeling when you hear Voices singing,
let's be jolly Down the halls with balls of holly Rocking
around the Christmas tree Of a happy holiday Everyone
dancing merrily In the new old fashion way
Bro, I already forgot like I just knew I just knew the main
verse rocking around and I don't I didn't realize there were
more than that There's a while I kept like what the fuck is
because like I didn't realize there was more to just Rocking
around the Christmas tree.
I was like there's more to this song than rocking around the
fucking Christmas tree Oh my god Not ready for that I I I
just wanted to rock around the Christmas tree.
Jingle bell, jingle bell, jingle bell, jingle bell, jingle
bell, jingle bell ring.
Oh, we should do that, we're doing rock.
All right.
All right, Bobby Holmes.
Jingle bell, jingle bell, jingle bell, rock.
Jingle bell swing and jingle bell ring Snowing and blowing
up bushes of fun Now the jingle hop has begun Jingle bell,
jingle bell, jingle bell rock Jingle bells chime in jingle
bell time Dancing and prancing in jingle bell square In the
frosty air What a bright time it's the Right time to rock
the night away Jingle bell time is a swell time To go
gliding in the one horse sleigh And giddy up a jingle horse,
pick up your feet Jingle around the clock Mix and mingle in
the jingling feet That's a jingle bell rock Jingle Bell,
jingle bell, jingle bell rock, Jingle Bell chime in the
jingle bell time Dancing and prancing in the jingle bell
square In the frosty air What a bright time, it's the right
time To rock the night away Jingle Bell time is the swell
time It's a good lighting and a one-horse sleigh.
Giddy up, jingle horse, pick up your feet.
Jingle around the clock.
Mix and mingle in the tingling feet.
That's the jingle bell.
That's the jingle bell ride.
Woo!
Yeah!
Another sip for me.
Let me hear it.
Thank you, the 100 biddies.
Thank you.
Thank you for the Twitch Prime.
Sarah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That's a classic song that was always playing during those
Christmas reruns on public TV television.
All right.
Let's see.
There's one song I really want.
Wait.
Did I have it?
You know what song I was hoping they have?
Britters or B?
Because I've been re-watching community.
I've been re-watching community in the office lately.
Getting rid of bigot up.
Da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da-da.
That sucks.
They don't have...
Getting rid of britta.
That's a good song.
What's this song that has a similar to?
What's the there's a song that's that's similar to that
tune.
That's actually really popular song
Oh, and then well no no no we can't sing that one.
There's too much history in there We didn't start the fire
We can't sing that
Too much history like too much history in there Let's see.
Sissies, mom.
Let's see.
Oh, wait.
Do they have this one?
Ah.
Wait.
Why do they have the German Digimon opening?
They have the German Digimon opening, but none of the
English ones?
Come on.
Come on, come on!
It is a classic.
I can't believe it.
They don't have like the...
Okay, do they have...
I wonder.
Nah, they don't.
What?
The English one was is peak too, guys.
The English one is also peak.
Why don't they have the Naruto German opening, huh?
If it's so peak.
It's perfect for me.
Alright, let's see.
I'm gonna see what other stuff I can sing.
They have this.
Oh my god, if they have this, I would be so excited.
Oh, they don't.
You know what I want?
I went and checked it.
They have Dora the Explorer.
Dora, Dora, Dora, Dora, Dora, Dora, Dora, Dora, Dora, the
explorer.
Oh my god, wait.
This is close enough.
Okay, I should get the drink is hitting.
Okay, I'm getting drunk.
I'm actually, um, do you understand why?
Wait, is this actually?
Take your places.
Like.
Can we fix it?
Yes, we can!
Bob the Builder, can we fix it?
Bob the Builder, yes, we can!
Scoot, muck, and dizzy, and rolly, too.
Lopty and Wendy joined a crew.
Bob and the gang have so much fun.
Working together, they get the job done.
Bob the Builder, can we fix it?
Bob the Builder, yes we can!
They have this one not Thor of the Explorer?
I don't know.
Time to get busy, such a lot to do.
Building and fixing, so it's good as new.
again we can really get sound working all day till the sun
goes down above the builder can we fix it above the builder
yes we can above the builder can we fix it above the
building yes we can
let's go
There's like this whole new song about it.
Okay, straight down.
I don't know this part.
There's no lead for this.
No, any situation.
Look out.
Here we come.
Can we...
Can we build it?
Yes!
Can we fix it?
Bob the Builder.
Yes, we can!
Can we fix it?
Bob the Builder, yes we can!
King and mixing, having so much fun.
Working together, they get the job done.
Can we dig it, yes.
Can we build it, yes.
Can we fix it, yes.
Bob the Builder, yeah!
Bob the Builder, all together now.
Bob the Builder, can we fix it?
Can we fix it from the building?
Yes!
We can!
Can we fix it from the building?
All of the building.
Yes, we can!
Yay!
I was not expecting...
I legitimately was not...
expecting this sign to be in here.
I was just like fucking around.
Oh, wait.
Wait.
Here we go.
Merry Christmas, everyone.
Merry Christmas.
Oh, here I am in my tubby again.
My tubby's all filled with water and nice fluffy stuff.
And I got my soap and washcloth to wash myself.
And I got my nifty scrub brush to help me scrub my back.
And I got big fluffy towel to dry.
Drive myself when I'm done.
But there's no other thing that makes tubby time.
The very best time of the whole day.
And you know what that is?
It's a very special friend of mine.
My very favorite little pal.
Oh, rubber duckie, you're the one.
You make that time lots of fun.
Rubber duckie, I'm awfully fond of you.
Oh, rubber duckie, joy of joys.
When I squeeze you, you make some noise.
Rubber duckie, you're my very best friend.
It's true.
Oh, every day when I make my way to the tubby.
Yellow and chubby, rubber dada bitty.
Rubber duckie, you're so fun.
And I'm lucky that you're mine.
Rubber Ducky, I'm awfully fond of you.
Whoa!
Hey, rubber ducky, would you like me to scrub your back with
my nifty little scrub brush?
You would?
Okay, how's this?
Hey, you want me to scrub out your ears?
Oh, I see.
You don't even have any ears.
Oh, do you?
I'm like the drunk ad right now.
Bird, Fatoma, and Doki Ernie.
I'm, no, I think she's Ernie and I'm Bert.
Every day when I make my way to the tubby.
I buy a fella who's cute and yellow and chubby.
Rubber duck dub dubby.
Rubber ducky, you're so fun.
And I'm lucky that you're mine.
Rubber ducky, I like a whole pond of.
Rubber ducky, I'm awfully fun.
of you.
I can't believe they have that sock.
I was not expecting that.
I was like, what the fuck?
Rubber ducky.
.
I don't know the other wait what about okay yeah no they
don't they don't have any every song guys but let's see what
else do I want to sing you're an easy being green I can't
sing that song though because like I don't remember how it
goes.
It ain't easy being green.
Fuck that.
I'm like, I'm sorry for the stream.
I'm like, oh, I don't have this song that I wanted.
Oh, wait, do they have this?
Wait, do they have...
Wait, I want to sing this song, though.
It has nothing to do with... Oh, I just realized I've been
singing songs that have nothing to do with Christmas.
I'll go back to Christmas, I swear to God.
I swear to God, I go back to Christmas, see.
I had too much silly juice.
I did.
I like this song.
I love this song.
I'm just grooving now.
It has a very long intro, but don't worry.
The payout is so worth it.
Come on, kids.
Come on, Timmy Yumi.
Jam along with me.
It has a long-ass intro, but it'll be worth it, guys.
It's mostly instrumental.
It's not tequila.
lyrics yeah we're almost there I don't know what about I'm
gonna miss my cue at this point I never miss it me yeah
everybody wants to be a cat because the cat's the only cat
but nowhere is that tell me everybody's picking up on that
Beeline beat, because everything else is obsolete.
Square with a horn makes you wish you weren't born.
Every time he plays, but with a square in the act, he can
set music back into the caveman days.
What's this about Bazaar?
Heard some corny birds who try to sing.
Still a cat's the only cat who knows how to swing.
He wants to dig a horn, a gig or something like that.
When everybody wants to be a cat, a square with a horn makes
you wish you weren't born.
Every time he plays, oh, a rinky dinky dinky with a square
in the act.
You can set music back to the caveman days.
Oh, rinky dinky dinky everybody wants to be a cat because a
cat's the only cat who knows where it's at when playing jazz
you always has a welcome mat because everybody digs a
swinging cat
oh no the drunk aunt got the cat ears now but i don't gotta
pay now
You got the cat ears!
What do we do?
Yeah, cat ears works for everyone.
Oh
We're yeah, we're getting there we're getting to the we're
getting to a drop soon.
Oh, we just got the drop Wait, no, this is we're almost
there at the drop Wait, what the fuck?
Oh, it's it's her
I don't remember her part.
I always remember the guy part All right, don't worry.
I got the guy part Don't worry No kitty Take it to another
key Modulate and wait for me I'll take a few bad lips Pretty
soon The other cats will all commence Congregating on the
fence Beneath the alley's only light What?
Oh, here, that's your part.
You got that, girl.
I'm just grooving.
Everybody, everybody, everybody wants to be a cat.
Everybody, everybody wants to be a cat.
Woo!
Everybody wants to be a cat.
Everybody, everybody, everybody wants to be a cat.
Woo!
Meow.
Let's go.
went back to rubber duckie for some reason they really want
me to sing rubber duckie but it's not that time but the
power of the moon i challenge you
but oh
finding evil by moonlight winning love by daylight from a
real fight.
She is the one named Seller Moon.
She will never turn her back on a friend.
She is always there to defend.
She is the one on whom we can depend.
She is the one named Seller.
Seller Venus, Seller Mercury, Seller Mars, Seller Jupiter.
Secret powers are so new to her.
She is the one One-name seller, Moon.
Can you feel your fingers, children?
Been out for a long time, but the adult use is warming up
Fighting evil by moonlight, Winning love by daylight, With
her seller scouts to help fight.
She is the one-name seller, Moon.
She is the one named Seller Moon.
She is the one Seller Moon.
But too damn bad.
We have another 30 minutes outside.
Don't worry, kids.
You're going to have a good time.
Because it's time.
I know we haven't sang a Christmas song in a while.
But don't worry, we'll get there.
Brum.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
your basic average girl and I'm here to save the world you
can't stop me cuz I'm Kim possible there is nothing I can't
do and what danger calls just know that I am on my way it
doesn't matter where or when there's trouble if you just
call my name Kim possible call me beat me anyone reach me
when you want to page me it's okay I just can't wait until I
hear my cell phone ring, doesn't matter if it's day or
night, everything's gonna be all right.
Whatever you mean me, baby, call me, beat me.
Anyone reach me?
Get him here.
Switch the stitch, message clear.
Me here, let me reassure you.
Never gonna leave you alone.
I'm on my way, you know, always count on me.
When it gets dark, it'll help you see.
I don't remember this part.
The TV intro is soon started.
Remember when there's trouble.
If you just call my name Kim Possible.
Call me, beat me.
If you want to reach me, when you want to page me, it's
okay.
Just can't wait until I hear my cell phone ring.
Doesn't matter if it's day or night, everything is gonna be
alright.
Whenever you need me, baby, call me, beat me.
If you want to reach me, beat me.
If you want to reach me, If you wanna page me, it's okay.
Doesn't matter where, doesn't matter when.
I'll be there for you till the very end.
Danger or trouble, I'm there on the double.
You know that you always can call Kimpossible.
Yeah, whoa!
Me, me, if you wanna reach me, when you wanna page me, it's
okay.
Just can't wait until I hear my cell phone ring.
Doesn't matter if it's day or night, everything's gonna be
alright.
Woo!
Call me, beat me, if you wanna reach me, when you wanna page
me, it's okay.
Just can't wait until I hear my cell phone ring.
Doesn't matter if it's day or night, everything's gonna be
alright.
When are you gonna need me, baby?
Call me, beat me, if you wanna reach me.
Katie, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you!
Disney don't make shows like that no more.
I missed those shows.
What is this?
Oh, the naked mole rat rap.
I don't remember how it goes though.
That's a classic though.
Come on and listen to the mole rat.
Na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na, na.
Four, three, two, one.
Yo, listen up.
How I holler from Ron.
Naked mole rap.
It's the name of the song.
His story not his glory.
It can't bark.
It's really the naked mole rap.
What is that?
Freaky day.
I don't remember how it fully goes, so I can't fully sing
it.
Unfortunately, I can't fully sing it because I don't
remember how it fully goes.
Oh, there was another one I really want.
Oh, what was it?
Five.
i was looking up songs and i forgot what i wanted to look
for what was it called oh yeah you're an alpha he's an alpha
does anyone remember you're an alpha it's such a funny i
never watched this song but that song is so silly and shitty
to be an alpha be an alpha be an oh you guys are lucky they
don't have that song you're so lucky guys so lucky they
don't have it i'm an alpha
merry christmas everyone oh someone requested this and i
want to sing it now oh they don't have it unfortunate they
have the teen titans go version they have this
they don't even have hi hi puppy i'm a new song hi hi puppy
i'm a new song They don't even have that one.
That's funny.
They don't even have like the Teen Titan, like the original
Teen Titan song.
Where do they have?
I mean, I don't mind seeing this one again.
Wait.
Oh, really?
Oh, they don't have Icky Vicky.
Icky Vicky.
Ah, everyone sings the Pokemon.
one song now.
Everyone sings it.
Polar Express.
You had the Polar Express?
Oh!
I remember how it goes, so I don't think it's good for me to
sing it, actually.
I actually don't remember how it goes.
The Polar Express.
That's the only part I know.
My shiny.
They only have my shiny teeth in me.
That's the only one they have.
I've sang that before.
They have...
Yeah.
Ben 10 guys they don't have Ben 10 unfortunately that's
crazy they don't have Ben 10 Ben 10 is the fucking classic
wait let me see all
right let me see I'm
searching on what other I mean I mean I could sing you're a
mean one mr.
Grinch
I'll rinse my pants.
I would like to, but then, like, I'm really bad at that
song.
Because, like, I don't fully remember the tune of it.
So, like, fucks with me.
All right, let's see.
All I want Christmas is you.
What other songs can we sing?
I sing like so many that I've lost track.
I mean, I can always sing this one.
No, but then.
gonna be like singing by myself that's sad oh wait no you
guys are with me sorry that's sorry to me and you meet you
guys are my backup touch that uh singers uh i don't know i
don't know what else to
see deck the ha's i mean i could oh we go back to christmas
we should go back to christmas songs That's a good idea.
We should go back to Christmas songs, guys.
That makes sense.
Deck the halls with bars of holly.
Fala, la, la, la, la.
Tis the season to be jolly.
Fala, la, la, la, la, la.
Done.
We now are gay apparel.
Fala, la, la, la, la, la, la, la.
Troll of the ancient Utah era.
Fala, la, la, la, la, la, la.
See the blazing field before us Fala, la, la, la, la, la
Strike the harp and join the chorus Fala, la, la, la, la
Follow me in joyous measure Fala, la, la, la, la, la While I
tell of you tied treasures Fala, la, la, la, la, la, la Oh
my gosh, I also ate the old year passers that the new year
lights and lashes sing we joyous all together heedless of
the wind and weather I remember there is one song that that
we forgot about which is a classic for us Oh, Seth
MacFarlane sang a...
Wait, do they have...
I saw it like I was searching it.
I was like, Seth MacFarlane sang a song.
What did he sing?
There's a Seth MacFarlane song in here.
I don't...
I'm Mrs. White Christmas.
I'm Mrs. Snow.
I'm Mrs. Ice-Sicle.
I'm Mrs. Danville.
Friends call me Snowmeiser, whatever I touch Turns the snow
in my clutch!
I ain't too much!
It was a classic blur.
Cheese, Mrs. White Christmas, Cheese, Mrs. Snow.
That's right!
Cheese, Mrs. Icicle.
Cheese, Mrs. Ten below.
Friends call me Snowmeiser, whatever I touch Turns the snow
in my clutch.
Oh, she's too much.
I never want to know a day that's over 40 degrees.
I'd rather have it 30, 20, and a 5 when it rains over.
She's Mrs. White Christmas.
I'm Mrs. Snow, that's right.
I'm Mrs. Ice-sickle.
Oh, Mrs. Tember-loat.
me snow miser whatever i touch turns the snow in my clutch
oh too much oh too much that's one of my favorite songs i
love that song so much there was like i was introduced to
song by a cover artist that sang like the female gender bent
version of it and it's been like stuck in my head ever since
oh my god c is for cookie cookie starts with a c that's a
sign i played deck that's like what the fuck oh i had a song
in my head but i already forgot what it was god damn i hate
when that happens um i had a song in my head but i'm already
forgot what i wanted to sing it must have been something i
mentioned uh what did i talk about i was like looking trying
to remember
I was like talking about something and then like it popped
in my head I really wanted to sing it but I forgot what it
was god damn it he knew what happens when I had like a song
that I wanted to sing and I just forgot
I don't want what was it what was it I guess I'll never
remember I had a song that I was one I wanted to search it
up if they have it but I already forgot what it was that I
wanted to search up oh man
let's see hmm
no it wasn't no it wasn't the Grinch song something else
that is woohoo
Do you have this?
Oh, they don't.
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles.
Say, I'm just, like, looking through the list.
I'm looking through the list and, like, see shit like that.
Pink pony gum.
Um, what do I want to sing?
Mama Mia, here we go.
You know, fuck it.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Because I always sing the song.
I always like randomly hum it.
I might as well.
Let's bring it back.
Here we go.
I had to pay the bills I have to pay.
Ain't it sad?
And still there never seems to be a single penny left for
me.
That's too bad.
In my dreams I have a plan.
If I got me a wealthy man, wouldn't have to work at all fool
around and have a ball money money money must be funny in
the rich man's world money money money always sunny in the
rich man's world.
All the things I could do, if I had a little money, it's a
I always hum that song whenever we fucking play games, we
have to collect money in a rich man's world.
Men like that is hard to find, but I can't get him off my
mind.
And if he happens to be free, I bet he wouldn't fancy me.
That's too bad.
So I must leave.
I have to go to Las Vegas or Monaco.
When a fortune in a game, my life will never be the same.
Money, money, money, must be funny.
in the rich man's world.
Money, money, money.
Always sunny in the rich man's world.
Oh,
all the things I could do if I had a little money.
It's a rich man's world.
Money, money, money, money.
Must be funny in the rich man's world Money money money
Always sunny in the rich man's world All the
things I could do if I had a little money It's a rich man's
world Timmy, Timmy, are you okay?
Rich man's world Timmy's, oh no, Timmy's alive, guys.
It's okay.
Timmy is alive.
He's moving, guys.
He's moving.
He's there.
Okay, we might need to swap matches.
Okay, all right, we gotta swap, guys.
I'm sorry.
I know you love carrying your little matches and everything,
but we gotta swap.
We gotta swap, Yimmy.
You gotta go back to Keraling.
all right back to caroline give me to me needs to sell
matches now we were so close who snitched someone snitched
all right because we have 10 minutes left what's we we shall
end with a christmas song what song would you guys like to
end with chat
song I'm super thanks for asking I'm super but I don't know
I'm just thinking about the looking what if I sing a has
been hotel song right there with all you guys are so lucky
they don't have it we Last Christmas, I gave you my heart
But the very last day, we'll give it awareness here To save
me from tears, we'll give her someone special Save You guys
got saved You know Fall Out Boys in Hasman Hotel?
That's fucking crazy
Thanks for the memories, but I don't know I'm singing this.
I'm fucking going in.
Yeah.
The lead singer, Fall Out Boy, is in a husband hotel.
I'm going to make you bend and break.
Say a prayer, but let the good times roll.
In case God doesn't know.
And I want these words to make things right, but it's the
wrongs that make them.
words come to life who does he think he is if that's the
worst you got the better put your fingers back one night one
more time thanks for the memories even though they weren't
so great thanks tastes like you only sweetie what i believe
the alcohol is hitting me thanks for the memories thanks for
the memories see
I shouldn't sing this when I'm like not not sober I'm
looking forward to the future But my eyesight is going bad
And this crystal ball Yeah it's always clouding Wait wait a
minute wait a minute Oh my god okay jumping Jumping I sang
this at the maid cafe and I think you guys would like it by
saying this song.
People were so excited.
We pivot, we pivot, because they reminded me of this song.
We're pivoting.
Hey, hey, you, you.
I don't like your girlfriend.
Think you need a new one.
I could be your girlfriend.
Hey, hey, you, you.
I know that you like me.
No way, no way.
No, it's not a secret.
Hey, hey, you, you want to be your girlfriend?
You're so fine, I want your mind.
You're so delicious.
I think about you all the time.
You're so addictive.
Don't you know what I could do to make you feel all right?
Don't pretend I think you know I'm damn precious.
Hell yeah, I'm the motherfucking princess.
I can tell you like me too, and you know I'm right.
She's like, so whatever, you could do so much better.
I think we should get together now.
And that's what everyone's talking about.
Hey, hey, you, you, I don't like your girlfriend.
No way, no way, think you need a new one.
Hey, hey, you, you, I could be your girlfriend.
Hey, hey, you, you, I don't like you, like me.
No way, no way.
No, it's not a secret.
Hey, hey, you, you wanna be your girlfriend?
I can see the way they see the way you look at me.
And even when you look away, I know you think of me.
I know you talk about me all the time again and again.
So come on over here and tell me what I wanna hear.
Better yet, make your girlfriend disappear.
I don't wanna hear you say her name ever again.
So whatever, we could do so much better.
I think we should get together now.
And that's what everyone's talking about.
Hey hey UU, I know that you like your girlfriend.
No way, no way.
Think you need a new one?
Hey hey you, you!
I could be your girlfriend!
Hey hey you, I know that you like me!
No way no way, no it's not a secret.
Hey hey you want to be your girlfriend?
to be a girlfriend.
In a second you'll be wrapped around my finger.
Cause I can, cause I can do it better.
There's no other, so when it's gonna sink right in.
Oh, in a second you'll be wrapped around my finger.
Cause I can, cause I can do it better.
There's no other, so when it's gonna sink in.
She's so stupid, what the hell are you thinking?
Hey, hey, you, you.
No way, no way, think you need a new one.
Hey, hey, you, you, I could be a girlfriend.
Hey, hey, you, you, I know that you like me.
You know it's not a secret.
I wanna be a girlfriend.
Hey, hey, you, you, I don't like your girlfriend.
No way, no way, think you need a new one.
Hey, hey, you, you, I could be a girlfriend.
Hey, hey, you, you I know that you like me No way, no way
No, it's not a secret I wanna be a girlfriend Woo!
I'm in my punk era now
Hey, hey, you, you No, no, no, no, no, no I fucking love
that song I remember seeing that in school All the time Bro,
and this one too I'm in my punk era now It's also this one.
He was a boy, she was a girl.
Can I make it any more obvious?
He was a punk, she did ballet.
What more can I say?
He wanted her, she'd never tell.
Secretly, she wanted him as well.
And all of her friends suck up their nose, and they They had
a problem with his baggy clothes.
He was a skater boy.
She said, see you later, boy.
He wasn't good enough for her.
She had a pretty face, but her head was up in space.
She needed to come back down to Earth.
Five years from now, she sits at a home, feeding the baby.
She's all alone.
She turns on TV, and guess who she sees?
of MTV.
She calls up her friends, they already know, and they all
got tickets to see his show.
She tags all on, and stands in the crowd, looks up at the
man that she turned down.
He was a skater boy, she said, see you later boy.
He wasn't good enough for her.
Now he's a superstar, slamming on his guitar.
Does your pretty face see what he's worth?
He was a She said, see ya later, boy.
He wasn't good enough for her.
Now he's a superstar, slamming on his guitar.
Does your pretty face see what he's wearing?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
girl, but you missed out.
Well, tough luck, that boy.
And this is how the story ends.
Too bad that you couldn't see.
See the man that boy could be There is more than meets the
eye I can see a soul that is inside He's just a boy and I'm
just a girl Can I make it any more obvious When we are in
love Haven't you heard How we rock each other's world I'm
with the skater boy I said see you later boy I'll be
backstage after the show I'll be at the studio sing the song
we wrote about a girl you used to know I'm the skater boy I
said see you later boy I'll be backstage after the show I'll
be at the studio sing the song we wrote about a girl you
used to know oh my god that that is a classic I fucking love
that song I love I didn't girlfriend is better i think
girlfriend is better and then she did hello kitty and then i
don't know fucking know what happened to her i hello kitty
hello hello that was a mistake from her it's a good classic
so i really wanted to sing that i had like a little oh my
gosh you'd sing this song moment there um all right okay
i'll do two more because i'll end with a christmas song
because now i want to sing this song i'll end with a
christmas song though bro didn't she marry like didn't she
marry someone from nickelback right all right one more song
two more songs two more songs we end with a christmas song
this one isn't a christmas song but i really wanted to sing
it i threw a wish in the well Don't ask me, I'll never tell
I looked at you as it fell And now you're in my way I trade
my soul for a wish Pennies and dives for a kiss I wasn't
looking for this But now you're in my way Your stare was
holding Rip jeans, skin was showing Hot night wind was
blowing Where you think you're going, baby?
Hey, I just met you And this is crazy But here's my number
So call me, Mamey It's hard to look right at your baby.
But here's my number.
So call me Mamie.
Hey, I just met you.
And this is crazy.
But here's my number.
So call me Mamie.
And all the other boys try to chase me.
But here's my number.
So call me Mamie.
You took their time with the call.
I took no time with the phone.
fall.
You gave me nothing at all, but still you're in my way.
I beg and borrow and steal after sight and it's real.
I didn't know I would feel it, but it's in my way.
Your stare was holding, ripped jeans, skin was showing, hot
night wind was blowing, where you think you're going, baby!
Hey, I just met you.
It's crazy, but here's my number.
So call me, Mamie.
It's hard to right at your baby but here's my number so call
me maybe hey i just met you and this is crazy but here's my
number so call me maybe and all the other boys try to chase
me but here's my number so call me maybe before you came
into my life i missed you so bad i missed you so bad i
missed fast before you came into my life.
I miss you so bad.
I wish you should know that.
I miss you so, so bad.
And in the music video, we find out he's gay.
Part of... Oh, wait.
I don't remember how this part.
Here's my number.
So Tommy made me.
Hey, I just met you.
And this is crazy.
But here's my number.
So call me Mamie and all the other boys try to chase me But
here's my number So call me Mamie For you came into my life
I miss you so bad I miss you so bad I miss you so so bad For
you came into my life I miss you so bad And you should know
that So call me Mamie Okay guys, I know I said one more song
but like this pop into my head too
This is now it's for real last two songs I always get that
way I just figured out some songs I really wanted to sing I
was like oh shit I should sing this one
And I just got to throw back moan
Whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa you love me?
I know you care.
You shout whenever and I'll be there.
You are my love.
You are my heart.
And we would never, ever, ever be a part.
Are we an item?
Girl, quit playing.
We're just friends.
What are you saying?
So there's another look right in my eyes.
My first love broke my heart for the Baby, baby, baby, ooh,
I like baby, baby, baby, no!
Baby, baby, baby, no!
Thought you'd always be mine, mine.
Baby, baby, baby, ooh, like baby, baby, baby, no!
Like, baby, oh my god, I choked on my saliva.
I thought you'd always be mine, mine.
We're you.
We're done whatever.
I just can't believe we ain't together.
I wanna play cool, but I'm losing you.
I buy you anything.
I buy you any ring.
And I'm in pieces.
Baby, fix me.
And you shake me till you wake me from this bad dream.
And I'm going down, down, down, down.
And I just can't believe my first love will be around.
Like baby, baby, baby, oh Like baby, baby, baby, no Like
baby, baby, baby, no Thought you'd always be mine, mine
Baby, baby, baby, oh Like baby, baby, baby, no Like baby,
baby, baby, no Thought you'd always be mine, mine When I was
13, I had my first love.
There's nobody that compared to my baby and nobody came
between us, no care.
She had me going crazy.
Oh, I was starstruck.
She woke me up daily.
Don't need no Starbucks.
She hit my heart found.
I seem to be where I can't sing this at school and
playground.
But I really want to see her on the weekend.
She knows she got me dazing because she was so amazing.
And now my heart is breaking.
baby baby oh like baby baby baby no like baby baby baby baby
I don't remember the rap part it's like when every song used
to have like random rap parts in the middle and doesn't make
any sense like that's why I always forget about the rap part
in the middle of the fucking Justin Bieber song
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, gone, gone, gone, he just says,
yeah, yeah, yeah, let's go back to Christmas, let's go back,
sorry, I had a little memory lane, um, segue, uh, pivot
there, I got distracted, i got really distracted there i had
to pivot all right there you go i'll be the i'll be the guy
and be the creep
but baby it's cold outside i've got to go away but baby it's
cold outside been hoping that you drop in i'll hold your
hand they're just like ice Beautiful, what's your hurry?
Listen to the five plays for...
Beautiful, please don't hurry.
Put some records on while I pour.
Baby, it's bad out there.
No caps we had out there.
Your eyes are like starlight now.
I'll take your hat, your hair looks swell.
Say no, no, no Mind if I'm moving closer What's the sense of
hurting my pride?
Oh, baby, don't hold up.
Baby, it's cold outside.
Oh, whoa, buddy, back up.
No one's really thinks about the lyrics.
But baby, it's cold outside.
The answer is no.
Oh, baby, it's cold outside.
How lucky that you dropped in.
Look out the window at the storm.
Gosh, your lips look delicious.
Waves upon a tropical shore.
My maintenance mind is vicious.
Gosh, your lips are delicious.
Never such a blizzard before.
Baby, you freeze out there.
Say lend me a comb.
It's up to your knees up there.
when you're touched by hands.
How can you do this thing to me?
Think of my lifelong sorrow.
If you caught pneumonia and died, get over that old doubt.
Baby, it's cold out.
Baby, it's cold outside.
I told you I was gonna be the creep.
I told you guys You guys like, huh?
Okay, we'll do a We won't end with the fucking With how I
sang that We won't end with that This is the last song for
real We won't end with that Because I realize I might have
sang that little too creepy This is a Christmas song An
actual Christmas song Made famous by Michael Bubla
Better watch out, you better not cry, you better not pout,
I'm telling you why.
Santa Claus is coming to town.
He's making a list and checking it twice, he's gonna find
out who's not here nice.
Santa Claus is coming to town.
He sees you when you're sleeping And he knows when you're
awake He knows if you've been bad or good So be good for
goodness sake You better watch out You better not cry You
better not pout I'm telling you why Cause Santa Claus is
coming To town.
Oh, let's go.
He's watching.
It's always watching.
This one's not creepy, at least.
Oh, just like God.
He's like God.
It's always watching you.
Whatever you're doing.
He likes to watch.
Santa loves to watch.
Night sees you when you're sleeping.
And he knows when you're awake.
He knows if you've been bad or good.
So be good for goodness sake.
Better watch out.
You better not cry.
You better not pout.
I'm telling you why.
Santa Claus is coming to town.
You better watch him.
You better not cry.
You better not come home.
I'm telling you why.
Santa Claus is coming.
I mean the big fat man with the long white beard.
He's coming to town.
Better watch out, you better watch out, you better watch
out, you better watch out Anyway, that was a good sign to
end it in
He's coming over Waiting for his old ass, or if we think
it's Super Chat, thank you, thank you Anonymous, thank you
for the five gifted souls, thank you, thank you Jets, thank
you for the hundred videos, thank you, thank you next stage
they give us super chat thank you thank you skater boy doki
imagine uh that was the karaoke portion that was fun i had a
lot of fun i don't know if you kids are if timmy and jimmy
are okay but let's you know let's take them to the bar real
quick but don't worry guys give me a sec don't worry don't
worry i gotta go to the car to grab some stuff real quick
yes guys don't worry guys you'll be okay I believe in you
give me a sec oh so I still need to pee as well okay uh uh
Doki has to take a bathroom break so Timmy and Yimmy you
stand out here for a little while while I go take a bathroom
break don't worry I'll be back just just stay there if you
just stay there I'll be back it'll be fast okay wait also
also here for Timmy and Yimmy I'll be right back
All right, I'm back.
You guys don't see me yet, but I'm back right now.
I hope you guys are okay.
You guys didn't fight, did you?
Uh, Nia, thank you.
Thank you.
Zell, uh, blood, greenie, Ryu, teacup, aka.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Uh, I really appreciate it, guys.
Thank you for the tips after, uh, me and my families carry,
Carol, Christmas, Caroling.
I really do appreciate it.
We did maybe diverge a little bit from this.
Christmas theme music, but like, you know, we had some fun.
We, we had some fun, guys.
All right, let me, all right, we'll take you guys to a
local, before we go to the next one, we'll take you guys to
a, all right, where is it?
This is this.
Oh, there we go.
All right, we're going to take you guys to to a bar i'm a
very good parent you guys got your ids right yeah you you
all got your ids all right we're gonna go grab a drink
before we pivot to the next thing all right hello welcome
welcome guys to um to the dokey bar this is where all the
dokey birds take their kids to drink i own this
establishment your dokey bird left you here with me today uh
they um they left their dokey here today with me so sorry
they left their no no i'm i'm the owner look there's a lot
of dokeys in the dokey verse i make my you know how like
like there's like in Then Rick and Morty, I know you have to
have a very high IQ to understand Rick and Morty, but like
it's like in Rick and Morty where there's like the One of
the ricks open like a little Jerry daycare.
So I took that I I borrowed that idea from Mr. Dan Harmon
And boys like wow, that's a great idea.
I should open a bar for the doki's to take their kids to
They're very legal kids by the way.
This is It's a babysitting bar.
It's called Club Doki.
Welcome to Club Doki.
So they leave their chats here with me.
So you might see other Dokiverse chats and elsewhere hanging
around.
So don't worry.
Your Doki is hanging around.
out with the other jokies right now and so you're you're
stuck with me right now kids uh legal kids by the way over
the age of if you are canadian over the age of 18 if you are
not canadian or like i mean if you are if you are not
american over the age of 18 slash 19 if you are american
over the age of 21 gotta be specific here uh please do not
me to my establishment to the police.
I am babysitting technically I am babysitting young adults.
Just so you know.
As I was saying.
That sounds so sus.
So.
I hope you two have had a great Christmas so far With your
With your doki in your particular doki verse Music, thank
you for the akasupa Thank you, thank you It's been a long
time lurking from beyond this life I'm finally in a position
financially Show your appreciation for all the entertainment
you provided me Thank you again for the akasupa Thank you,
thank you I really appreciate it, music Yeah, I'm really
glad you're in a good financial place right now guys uh so
you don't have to obviously like um you don't have to donate
to me but i really do appreciate it when you do and you guys
come here to watch me and like hang out with all of us like
all the dragoons and everyone it really does mean a lot so
um i hope all you guys have been having a wonderful holiday
so far um with your family friends or with us the dragoons
and everything uh code thank you for the magenta soup but
thank you thank you happy holidays bartender make me a too
fun thank you thank you i really appreciate it thank you um
all right so like i said i hope i hope you too have been
having a wonderful time with your dokey um and that she has
been um entertaining both of you um but now she is off to
get drunk with the other dokeys so now you're under my care
it's christmas she needs a break uh now she has continued to
drink with the other jokies uh left you at the left you at
club jokie for babysitting what there's something about what
what is it um my chit chit oh sorry my chit chat my twitch i
would like to play you a christmas carol um if there's all
right to watch if not it's great time oh okay wait i have to
do something real quick before we can so you could come back
later 20 minutes 15 to 20 minutes um but thank you i would
love to watch it i think i've seen a clip of it from last
year but i would love to i don't know if he's gone now
because it took me a while to reply back sorry yeah so but
like yeah i'm multi-streaming right now so i'm so like it
was my first time multi-streaming so um so it's like it's
like a lot all right all right so i hope you Let me see some
IDs, Dragoons.
Who did you bring your IDs before I make you to a drink?
Don't worry, I also have my own drink too.
Like everyone says, always test your own products, you know?
Don't worry, I also drink on the job.
All right, let's see.
We'll go with Yemi, right?
All right, you mean you you tell you show me your ID first
before I give you a drink Look, I don't want to get
arrested.
Okay, we don't want to shut down club dokey This is a very I
worked very hard to make a living here Where the fuck is
your ID?
Where did I?
Is it here?
What is this?
Oh wait, that's not that's you Wait, that's you oh there it
is I found your eye.
Okay, here you go all right show me show me your id all
right all right let's see it says drag all right give me it
so you are age bureau clock and that's a lovely that's a
lovely photo id photo like
It's not role play.
It's real.
This is a real establishment.
It's not real.
I make my living doing this.
All right.
That looks about right.
You know what I mean?
That looks right.
I'll go put that back in.
All right.
Let's see.
Where is... Where the fuck is?
Timmy, where's your ID?
Timmy, where's your ID, Timmy?
Come on.
Where the fuck's your ID?
Oh my god.
Don't worry.
You got any time?
You got any time to grab your ID?
That's okay.
I get it.
Oh, you got it?
Alright.
Alright, Timmy.
Let me see your ID.
Sorry.
I make myself laugh.
God.
Ducky, you're so funny.
All right, let's see.
Timmy, Timmy, oh, you're a chonky-goon.
Whoa, I don't know how you get so chonky when your mother
barely feeds you, but...
But it looks like your age is 8,008.
Wow, you're very old.
So...
Alright, so, alright, so it seems like you were both, you
were both very legal adults here.
So, the bar club will, the bar will not shut down.
And what would you two like to have?
What would you two like to have for your drink?
I mean, I think you didn't even hydrate outside Christmas
caroling.
I mean, you guys are Christmas caroling right next to my
bar.
it back to twitch 8008135135 you want a beer you want okay
guys one at a time guys all right don't worry watch this
wait where is my thing give me a sec where did i put it
where did i put my beer making my my drink making thing give
me a oh there it is guys watch this i shall now make you a
drink.
I've seen this on TV, guys.
I've seen this on TV, so I know how to do it.
I don't need a license to distribute alcohol.
Alright, so you too.
is this where your drink is here is there you go to me
here's your drink and yimmy here's your drink enjoy and then
here's my drink
Dow be it $20 each from Timmy from Timmy and Yimmy
Gamba Gamba Alright guys Clink your glasses here You guys
are bonded now Through this Christmas stream It was a very
difficult martini beer That I made I poured beer in the In
the shaker thingy And then I shook it a lot And it was very
hard to do And then I think that's what makes it a martini
Right?
So it's a beer martini It's a beer tini It's my own
creation.
A birtini.
Smokey, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hey, guys.
Super chat.
Thank you.
Guys, both of you guys.
Come on.
Clink your glasses.
Clink your glasses, guys.
You're united now.
Through friendship.
Through friendship, you are both united now.
Clink your glasses.
Clink, clink.
Here's the...
Here's the $20.
Even though he gave me the wrong drink.
A drink is a drink.
Mr. Broken Bond.
Thank you, Mr. Richad.
Thank you.
There we go.
Look at that.
That's cute.
Look at you two working together.
and you're warmed up oh shit oh shit okay sorry i didn't
clean my mouse back i accidentally like like slammed my my
my can down and then now my oh no it's okay it's okay it's
okay everything is okay everything is okay i cleaned it i
gotta get a trash bag there's a lot of tissues up in my left
side okay give me a sec i might need to grab water Oh, you
know, I never balanced this with water.
I need a...
Okay, guys, guys, okay, I need you two to work.
I need you two to be nice, okay?
Like, I know, like, your dokey dropped me off here.
Like, dropped... Sorry, not me.
Sorry.
I think I drank too much on the job.
But they always say, you always try your own product and
make sure it's okay, good.
You know?
That's what they always say.
to get some water because i think i know like your doki's
left you guys here to like for me to babysit you guys but
don't worry um don't worry i have someone better to babysit
you guys give me a sec uh don't worry don't worry we have
some so great i got someone better to babysit you guys there
you go don't there you go he'll babysit you all right i'll
be back we also have dads okay here
Guys, I'm back.
I'm...
Alright, Dad, you can go now.
I am back kids.
I mean, like, you know, adult kids.
And I brought...
Not only did I bring more water, but also brought more
alcohol.
It's a real Christmas party.
I've only had one cat.
This is my second cat, by the way.
And, like, for those who are worried about it, it's...
That's 5% alcohol.
But, like, I'm Asian, though, so it hits hard.
Okay, so I'm still on my first can.
I brought a second can just in case, you know, for
precaution.
Doc, welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
All right, kids, adult kids who are above the legal drinking
age.
I can't get my club closed down, guys.
My bar closed down.
savings um i sold my i sold my chats to fund this why else
do you think i'm taking care of you guys were you guys be
like where's your chat guys you're gone they're getting i
sold i sold my my chat children to be able to afford the
club doki but it's okay now now i can like babysit you guys
you guys are like my chat so guys okay we can't get the
police to shut this place down is all i have
all right are you adult children ready for some minecraft i
know i said fortnite first but i won't play minecraft that
or do you want to play actually do i no i just play blocks i
just actually know we got fortnite jk we're doing fortnite
first wait actually i don't know all right let's have a
No.
On YouTube.
Wait, can my mods...
Wait, mods can make polls on Twitch.
A poll on Twitch.
Because my mods can make a poll on Twitch.
And I don't really want to make it right now.
Mods make a poll.
Fortnite or Minecraft.
On Twitch though.
To me shall decide.
Yimmy's fate.
Do you even do a pull on both?
Yeah, but then, like, it's easier if I just do it on one,
you know?
It's just easier in general.
Alright, mods.
Make that pull!
There we go.
Is it up?
I think my mod fucked up.
A smoky.
Thank you for the 100 bitties.
Thank you.
Oh.
Did he mess up?
Oh, I guess.
I guess I have to make my own.
I guess I have to make my own pull, I guess.
Alright.
Slash a pull.
Did you do slash pull?
Minecraft.
Oh my god, I can't type.
Thank god we're not playing Spelling B right now.
Or.
For tonight, though.
Monk.
I'm not.
okay all right it might be hard to there you go I'm going to
make it one minute good luck it's a one minute pull
all right let's see I'm not sober right now
all right It's a 50-50.
It's at the very top.
If you look up, you will see that poll.
All right.
Oh.
It looks like foot.
Oh, it's a very close fight.
Fight.
All right.
Music.
Thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you.
Yo.
Bartender Doki.
This is probably my last donation for the next year.
But seriously, I want to know your favorite drink.
Thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you.
A screwdriver.
That's basically orange juice and vodka.
favorite drink because it's either that or soju um the
flavored ones i think peach soju is either screwdriver or
peach soju screwdriver because it's the first alcoholic
drink um i've ever had um because like uh my friends made it
for me uh well actually that's a lot it's why why was my
very first alcoholic drink because my professor our
chaperone professor gave it to me and then like i had one
sip and i was already red and then like my friend was like
yeah enough that like we were at doing a conference uh i was
like by the way i was also i was also like 18 but we were in
america because we were doing a conference in america um
okay i'll talk about it we were doing uh model we were doing
model united nations um in new york city because we went to
the actual united nations building and then yeah we had we
did it because it was like hosted at the real un building so
um i was 18 and then our professor our chaperone professor
uh gave me wine in our hotel room like we were having a
meeting um in her hotel room and she gave all of us wine and
i was 18 but legal drinking age in canada is 18 um so like
but then like um i my face started getting red and then my
my friend who was sitting next to me like one of my friends
like we're all friends uh doing this send your explanation
like that is enough of that and i was like no yes a
professor a university professor gave me gave me alcohol
when um when i was under technically under asian america but
yeah my friend was trying to take you away was like that's
enough for you and i was like no
and then um even then later on like after we did our
committees meetings and stuff um my the same friend made me
a screwdriver like the next the next uh i was like the same
day uh because we because there was always part by the way
so the crazy thing about model un is that people fucking
party hard like like these future lawyers and okay lawyers
politicians And everything.
They were like, like, party.
Like, they party fucking hard.
And then my friend made me a fucking screwdriver.
Like, like, like after our meetings were done.
Like the conference, like the day one of it.
No, they were fucking, yeah.
It was a hard, like, it was a crazy party.
Like, it was like the official, like, organizers organizing
the party, too.
They got a fucking DJ.
They got it.
They got a D, like, they organized a fucking party, like,
uh, um, at, like, for it, too, and they had a fucking DJ,
too, at the hotel and shit.
Yeah, work hard, party harder.
Yeah, and then my friend made me a fucking, like, we
pre-gamed.
This is, like, the first time I've ever learned about
pre-gaming.
Yeah.
It was the first time I've ever learned what pre-game was.
We pre-gained before we went to the body.
And she made me a screwdriver.
Wait, what won?
Oh my god, I looked away.
I was telling my story.
And I looked away.
Who won?
Drop a B in the name of peace.
Oh, Minecraft did.
Wait, Fortnite?
Okay, you guys are telling lies now.
Okay, Minecraft.
Wait, who?
What?
One tells the truth.
The other tells the lie.
Which one is it?
Is it Timmy or Yimmy?
I...
Who tells the truth?
Is the Stimmy tell the truth or is it Yimmy?
Papa and Smokey, they give the 100 biddies.
Thank you.
Minecraft.
All right.
Does anyone have any suggestions for free SMP servers?
Or should I just look it up?
Okay.
Minecraft.
SMP is...
servers free who has suggestions now
we're going to raid I wouldn't know all right I'll look it
up right now okay minecraft all right here we go guys here's
the link minecraft dot buzz let's find one we're we can like
fuck around with
let's see which one is okay wait there's one i want to do
let's do bed wars what how what is that is there no more a
server was last updated on do they have bed wars here over
six million players vanilla mini games
What version?
Oh, that's a good question.
All right, let me launch Minecraft real quick.
Go into Hypixel.
All right, let's...
I guess we raid Hypixel.
Hi, Hypixel.
Okay, Hypixel server.
All right, free-to-play Minecraft servers.
All right, let's do...
Let's create our own bed wars.
Bed Wars.
All right.
Where is the...
Give me a sec.
I'm booting it up real quick.
I'm just going to use this version that I have already
installed.
Surely if we all queue at the same time, we'll all get
there.
All right.
Anyway, well, I'm not the one that's hanging out with you
guys, but I helped set it up with the other dokey for you
guys.
All right.
Give me a sec.
Let me go grab her real quick.
quick.
Let me grab the other jokie so you guys can go play
Minecraft.
Oh, shit.
It's full screen.
I gotta fix my fucking thing.
I'm gonna do Windows.
I don't think I'm sober enough with full screen, right?
Oh, my God.
Well, I am playing...
I am going to be playing rival.
I don't know.
Oh, this is gonna be bad if I'm playing rival.
It's like that.
okay all right all right i shall bring her out give me a sec
all right
oh my god okay give me a sec i'm i'm trying to i'm dragging
her out right now all right all right hey i'm back yeah
Because that's when you have any water.
Oh.
Alright.
Let us now pivot to FedWord slash Minecraft.
Where is it?
Where the fuck is Stereo?
Yeah!
Alright.
Where is my my where is my gaming oh wait who missed okay
that's just all right gaming minecraft hello hello kids did
you miss me it's not full screen because i can't be bothered
right now um but we are gonna be which version of minecraft
this is 1.21.8 it might not be the right one but we will see
We'll see if it...
I'm gonna see if it works.
Wait.
Okay.
My has been detected on your account.
Oh, wait.
What version do I need for Hypixel?
Wait.
Guys.
What version do I need?
Oh, it won't matter.
Then why the fuck am I...
Why the fuck am I blocked on Hypixel?
What did I do?
Guys, why does it say I'm blocked on high pixel?
Okay, security block.
Oh, is it because I have mods on?
Okay, wait.
High pixel security block.
How can I un...
Wait.
wait do i turn off okay we gotta make our minecraft ugly
give me a sec i have to make my minecraft ugly guys give me
a sec oh my god okay uh what is the latest okay ugly
minecraft there you go i'm getting ugly minecraft in
all right
all right here we go
wait it still says my account is blocked All right, guys, it
looks like it's not high pixel tab It still says my I don't
know what I did Maybe past Doki did something But I don't
know what I did I swear I didn't do anything All right, what
are the other good bed wars servers
I don't know
Okay, here we go What did I do?
How would I know how to cheat on Hypixel?
I don't fucking know how I...
I barely know how to function.
Okay, wait, I got this.
I have another server.
Wait, I don't want to use this ugly ass no shader shit.
I'm banned.
I'm banned from Hypixel.
I don't even know what I did.
you think they know you think they know what i did on my own
server
okay let me try this server
connecting the server
oh this is a server from four years ago do you think it
still exists
guys what's a good server guys
guys what's it oh wait guys i found another site to use all
right we can go look for stuff we can go check out servers
here oh my god wait my chat is frozen now my all right wait
wait i gotta figure it oh no guys give me a sec everything
is going wrong i can't even wait i can't type to you guys oh
there you go i i i did it all right there we go there's
another air here.
Which one is this?
They play my new.
Oh wait, that's Europe.
Yeah, we can't do that here.
There's this one.
Purple Prison.
Voted best of prison 20.
Oh, that sounds nice.
They have the best prisons.
Let's go.
Guys, I'm in!
I'm in purple prison!
Guys, get over here!
It was voted best prison!
They were voted best prison, guys!
Where do we go?
Oh my god.
Okay.
Caution.
PvP is enabled.
Guys, where the fuck is?
Okay.
There's so many things on my screen, guys.
It's a prison server?
Yeah, what's a prison server?
Wait, what's a prison server?
There must be like, why is there so many people lying?
I don't know how to activate the prison.
Left click to buy arrows.
have money how did you guys type oh protect off protect off
there we go i'm ready i'm ready to go forward what the does
prison do stuck safe zone for disabled wait how do we fight
how do we how do we start the game oh shit I should put on
armor you're right you're right I should put it up info I
would like to start the prison mode how do I how does one
start the prison mode oh oh get back in get back into
oh my god they're all fighting i'm so warp mine a warp mine
a
wait you do not wait it doesn't let me work warp mine a i
don't have permission to work there wait i have to start
mining Oh, there you go.
Hello.
We're in prison now.
Oh my god.
This, guys, we're leaving.
This is one of those, like, Roblox games where you fucking,
like, mine.
It's, like, AFK shit.
Is that what it's called?
Like, it's literally cookie clicker, but we're mining.
I thought this was Ben Wars.
How is it?
Ow, I'm in a prison!
Ow, is this a prison?
This is...
This is a...
I am here with my cry.
I thought...
Guys, guys, we're pivoting, guys.
Guys, guys, we're pivoting.
We're doing a jail break.
I thought this was like jail...
I thought it was like...
Fucking prison.
break from gmod like little do i know i'm literally doing
labor so yeah i mean it's actual hard labor
um guys i'm leaving i'm finding a new server you guys mine
around me how is this this says minecraft bedware servers
and purple prison is like Oh my god, they bought, oh my god,
this was a sponsored, oh that's why it's number one.
It's literally a sponsored fucking nugget.
Alright, it's okay guys, I can find, don't worry guys, I
shall find the bed war.
I literally clicked the first one and it was their sponsored
server.
Alright, alright, I found, okay, wait, wait, we're pivoting
guys, we're pivoting.
Okay.
Let's check this prison.
Let's check here.
Type.
Register your username.
Okay, we're leaving.
When I come here, I want to just be done.
I just want to be there.
I don't want to register.
I'm finding the server with the least amount players on
right now.
What about this?
MPU.
Oh, they have...
700 people on right now okay did you already have we
recommend to keep your no I do not wish to do
that oh guys guys I found the server come um but um oh my
god there's in again.
Bump, bump.
Guys!
Guys, come over here!
There's bed wars!
Oh my god, Saikudo!
Thank you for the rain!
Thank you!
I got a great stream, Saikudo, and a great Christmas too.
Hello, everyone.
I am not sober right now.
I'm sorry.
We are gonna play bed wars!
It's so fucking bright here.
Oh my god.
Where did it take me?
But hello everyone.
Hello everyone from Saikuno's stream.
We guys had a great time.
My name is Joki Bird and we're doing a little marathon of 14
players.
Oh wait, that's so the doubles.
Quadruples.
Guys, quadruples.
More people on team equals better.
We select Aquarium.
i selected aquarium guys everyone aquarium
aquarium guys did i select aquarium wait only 16 players oh
my god that bed wars had more people okay fuck it okay are
we all here guys is it really bad to tell you guys that this
might be my second time i've ever played bed wars it's like
that's like me guys okay so how do you play bed Yeah, I
think the only time I played Bed Boards was when I was in
that Minecraft tournament And even then, so how do you put,
I know like, all I did was defense Alright, we got this I
believe in my team I don't believe in myself, but I believe
in my team Alright, how many people here have played
Minecraft?
Oh my god, how many people here have played Minecraft
before?
How many?
Sorry, bed wars.
Assume we all played Minecraft before.
How many guys have...
I forgot the most part.
How many times have you...
How many of you guys here have played bed wars before?
Ooh, it's a bed war.
Extraordinary.
You?
You're on my team.
You.
Are anyone else has played bed wars?
Dead Wars.
Anyone.
You.
You're a liar.
You're a fucking liar.
Did you just say you haven't played before?
No, I'm willing it.
You can't pick your team by willing it into existence.
No, it's okay.
I will will it into it.
It will happen.
Because I proclaim it to the world.
I shall receive my teammates.
Do not worry.
How to play Bed Wars?
It's quite easy.
I think.
I don't know.
This is my second time playing Bed Wars.
I just wanted to play Bed Wars.
Yes, we're doing an endurance streamed it.
But this is the server we're in.
Alright.
Don't worry.
I have the streamer buff So I told you I told you Edward
yelling I told you I fucking told you I can wheel it into
existence I told you all You didn't believe me But it
happened We got the pro Wait how did you get blocks Oh okay
we got Okay, he was definitely...
I told...
It's a streamer buff.
Okay.
I got this.
And I gotta buy...
Blocks.
Okay, 24 ingots.
And then I'll buy...
Uh...
I'll buy good armor.
Good ass armor.
Okay, I have good armor right now.
Alright, I also have...
Oh!
Oh my god, Christmas present!
Why did I open?
Sarah.
Oh my god, I got another one.
Oh my god, they're just bombs.
They're just bombs.
Okay, that's good to know that they're just bombs.
I thought I fucked up.
Okay, it was just a bomb, guys.
It was just a bomb.
We're fine.
Oh, I need seven golden ingots.
I almost have seven.
It's okay.
Wait.
Okay, wait.
I have, I have, I can buy a good ass sword.
Look at that.
I got a good ass.
Okay.
Um, okay.
We need to, okay.
Where's our, our bed?
Where's the bed in our bed war?
Is it this?
Is this the bed in our bed war?
Don't worry.
They can't get our bed.
If I cover it up like this, our bed will be fine.
Alright.
All right Nobody's coming over to us We're so safe I'm gonna
go I'm going in
I'm going in Oh shit diamond That's
right Doesn't know
Yeah Yeah Yeah
Oh No What Oh damn
Damn It was so clear!
I was like, oh, I'm gonna get him.
I'm gonna fucking get him.
I'm gonna do it.
It's okay.
I have this.
Watch this.
That's fucking right.
Watch this, yes.
Wait, where's my...
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Yeah, that's right.
Yeah, I got the...
Oh, you're scared, aren't you?
Yeah, that's like you, right.
Am I?
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, yes, I got a fucking bomb.
I ain't scared.
I got a fucking bomb.
Oh, yeah!
Yeah, run!
Boom!
Oh, it didn't do nothing.
Oh, shit, that's her face.
Okay, do you think the bomb worked?
Hey, guys.
Okay.
Oh, I give it to the shopkeeper?
Oh my god, I wasted my bomb.
That was supposed to go to him.
I didn't realize that.
Where the fuck does it say we'll take...
It doesn't say anything about him taking my bombs.
Okay.
The bomb didn't do much and what the fuck is the point of
having a bomb?
Guys, I don't think I'm very good at bed wars.
I've come to realize that I might not be very good at bed
wars
okay oh my god I lost two diamonds too I lost these diamonds
for this guys what should I do has been permanently bad oh
wait it's okay no one's coming for us we are absolutely very
safe it's okay I have the pro gamers on my team
like I said I'm here for moral support I am I am here for
moral support everyone it will all eventually work out guys
okay so how do I oh I gave him I gave him my present Did he
take it?
Oh, I'm so poor.
Did he take my press?
Oh, he did.
Can't believe I used it as a bomb and when I can just give
it to him.
Wait, nobody.
Whoa!
What?
Oh, my God!
He just sneaked down
here!
He just got
ambushed!
Oh, my God.
Oh my god, we have no bed.
What happens now?
Guys!
What happens when you have no bed?
Oh my god, I'm gonna grab armor.
I'm gonna... What happens?
We have no bed!
Oh, I can't respawn?
Oh, shit!
Okay, guys, guys, guys, guys.
Oh, guys.
Okay, okay
No, no, no, no I'm trying to run away I'm trying to run away
I hope that if I run away, I would be fine I'm fine I should
have hid I should have hid I didn't know This fucking
bullshit This fucking bullshit.
They fucking sneaked underneath it.
How is I supposed to know you can just do that?
I can't believe they just, they just like went under.
How the fuck does that even work?
I thought I had a professional gamer.
Wait, are they winning?
Who's winning?
Oh, this guy doesn't have a bed no more.
Okay, this is a scam.
Everyone targeted us.
This is a fucking scam.
Oh, am I lagging?
I didn't realize I've been lagging for really hard.
Okay, give me a sec.
I know how to fix this.
Okay.
Give me a sec.
Okay, wait, I know how to actually fix this.
I might have to...
I might have to I might have to do oh wait that's why all
right here and then I might have to actually full screen oh
I hate full screaming wait how is it worse wait oh wait
there we go I had the full screen guys there we go
entire tap whoa shit goodbye world we're not responding back
am i just oh that's oh that's bad
that's bad
is it so is it the server all right we go back to lobby it
could be the server the server might be fuck why
is the server the server might have too much shit okay let's
check oh yeah that seems about it yeah i don't know what
guys i don't know why it's like that that no i think we
wait let's see no that was a lot of chunks yeah no that was
that was bad that was bad okay
decrease oh
my god i don't even know what else to do i don't even know
there's no way is my shader pack my shader packs oh that
makes sense
wait is it fancy clouds
where's fancy clouds oh there we go
it's a lot better now I can't tell oh my god it just keeps
playing but what else can I turn down
no no no
100 200
I'll do this And then Oh my god it's so hot Oh wait wait I
do this I don't like that
Oh Shaders is maxed
I'm too fucking Fucked for this right now
Okay, uh...
Okay, um...
Wait, what was I on?
Oh, no.
What is this?
Cancel.
Okay, cancel.
Oh, shit.
What did I click?
What did... Oh, fuck.
I'm clicking everything I shouldn't be clicking.
Okay, here we go.
Okay, it's custom profile.
Okay, you're advanced.
Uh...
Okay, no shaders.
Maybe that's it.
Oh my god, you're all...
Everything is so ugly.
It's not the shaders, see?
It's not the shaders.
It's still the same.
Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum,
bum.
oh
oh there you go fast
guys we might have to move servers
Oh, no, no, no, no.
Wait, am I better?
Wait, it's a little better now.
Oh, it's sort of better, right?
It's sort of better now.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh, no, no.
Yes, I do.
I need all 200.
It's not.
It's a little bit better.
okay okay i swear i told i bet you guys we're gonna put at
120 and like nothing would change
see i told you i told you nothing has changed i knew it i
fucking knew it you guys believe me
this all right we go again oh drinking alcohol might have
been a bad idea oh i keep looking this this guy's drinking
oh where am i where am i
it's the server i think the server is too jacked up guys i'm
pretty sure i'm pretty sure the server is so jacked up right
now i'm lost and i'm so lost you know where we couldn't go
okay we'll do one more bed wars and then and then we're
gonna go somewhere
do i know anyone here oh i hope these are real people
I hope I hope these are I hope these are people people from
my stream I really do
all right don't worry I'm I buy we'll do one more minecraft
server this one the other one is fun I have an idea
oh yeah here we go I buy I have no money I have no money I
buy
12 12 Oh the screen is fucked Oh I didn't notice
Oopsie It's okay I figured this out Bam There you go Like
magic Okay Okay Wait, what happened to...
Okay, there you go.
I have iron now.
And then...
I'm gonna buy a gold...
I'm gonna invest.
I invest in the golden sword.
There's no way.
Because they're regular people, they won't know.
They won't know it's me.
Alright, here we go.
Don't worry, guys.
I shall help.
I am here.
Where do we go now?
Oh my god, there's a red.
There's a red.
The way I'm coming.
Oh.
Okay.
That's okay.
He doesn't know.
I'm just farming emeralds.
He's not gonna come over.
He's too stupid.
Oh, shit.
It's coming over.
Oh, did it fix itself?
Am I okay now?
Is my skin suit okay now?
Am I okay?
Not okay.
Like, the effort was there at least.
The effort was there.
All right.
I shall now.
I shall buy a wall.
And then...
Random stutters Oh my god, he's Oh my Yes Oh my Yes Don't
worry I got Whoa I
got wood Guys I'm a hero
Iron sword Wait, is this iron?
Okay, diamond sword Uh wait i got this
wait i have no ammo what the fuck okay they'll never expect
this oh okay wait wait wait all right oh my god they
expected this what the fuck
what the fuck what
the okay it's fine it's fine our thing is okay oh shit nice
okay everything is fine everything is fine okay don't worry
guys i'm here i'm here
okay arrow i have the range i have the range it will it all
works out at the end guys we should get rid of that we
should really get rid of this
oh my god wait i'm okay okay i'm green okay i was like oh my
god he's coming and i realized he's green and i'm green
it's okay guys there's like oh i got pink it's okay did i
hit him did i get him oh that's sad that should hit him
whatever ever it's close enough guys what if we all work
together and go kill red how about that
oh he's scared oh my god bro oh my god he's he thinks i'm
gonna hit him look at him he's so scared because he thinks i
can actually aim he thinks i'm sober this guy is actually
scared I'm fucking sober right now.
Look at him.
He thinks I can.
He thinks I can hit that shot.
He's so fucking paranoid.
Oh, I did!
I hit it!
Now he's like, oh, shit.
She got him.
Hey, look at that.
Look at that.
Yeah, fuck you.
Yeah.
That's your fault.
I got him, bitch.
I think you're right.
There we go.
I'm going to go grab put arrows.
I got him.
Yeah, that's right.
He's like, cat aim.
Suckers.
He got so paranoid.
He's like, oh, fuck.
Wait, they hit shots.
What?
You want this?
is that what you want is this what you want yeah take it you
whore I don't know what the fuck I'm doing I'm just shooting
my arrows this guy is like I'd be your influence be your
influence and I'm like what do you want for me I'm trying to
shoot my bow like he's trying to fucking I'm back I'm back
oh that's right i'm coming over oh i should like give them
my diamonds oh what
oh no no the blues got him oh no wait how did he break it oh
oh my god oh my god they broken here here take my diamond i
don't trust myself with diamond You can take it.
You can take it.
Just take my time.
I don't trust myself.
Okay.
We have to survive.
Oh, shit.
One of them's dead.
Okay, that's, that's unlucky.
Okay, we just have to survive and hope to get...
Okay, wait.
Can I get rid of there?
Like, I'll deal with that later.
Oh, he got out.
They got out.
oh no oh no it's just you and i oh no why won't the blues
fight the yellows
oh no it's just us
oh he's coming back oh he's coming back there's it's never a
good sign it's never a good sign when they start coming back
oh i'm so I can still I'm gonna go fucking do pot shots at
people maybe I could third party
is he coming for me I'm trying to see if I can third party
this
I'm trying to see I got my trusty bow in hand oh they're
guarding they're they're guarding each other oh my god it's
That video then went off
Okay You guys can die If I can look at me It was like Now
we'll keep her alive Like people who looked at each other
for so long Dude
Like what the fuck do I do Why do I do I can't afford
anything I'm I'll go to that, but
I wait.
oh, that scared me.
Okay, there's two reds left.
Two, wait.
What happened to the other green?
What do you mean?
There's two of us left.
Yellow are still fighting?
Oh my god.
Don't worry.
I'm gonna try and third party Okay yellow team's bed is
broken That's good for us
Okay that's not good for me
Okay I thought it would hit somewhere else But I was very
wrong I was very very wrong It's okay There's three it's
okay We will be fine we will prevail i
am a survivor where the are they even fighting i swear i
don't see anyone you guys notice that like there's i
literally don't see anyone at all
oh my god they're coming they're coming all i could do is
use my bow no don't be i
why did he go
It's okay.
I am a survivor.
You don't know I'm here.
Oh my god.
I am the final green.
Guys, what if we all work together to fight, to kill Blue's
bed?
We can all work together to fight Blue.
that's a blue right there that's a that's a blue right there
i'm not getting close to her
that's a fucking blue the blues are coming the blues are
coming
oh my god there's still three reds oh my god the blues are
coming i'd rather die by the reds hands than by the blues
Hey, goodbye, goodbye, goodbye guys.
Goodbye, I'm, bro, I'm not going to fight you, I swear to
God.
I'm just trying to live.
The blues are coming.
I'm trying to warn y'all.
Bro, I'm trying to warn you guys.
They're coming.
It's on you.
Oh, now you're running.
Now you're fucking running.
That's like, you're right.
They're fucking coming for you.
Oh, my God.
He's running away, too.
We're all running away.
Oh, my God.
Oh, shit.
The blues are here.
Oh, my God.
Fucking dead.
Oh shit, I'm the fuck!
Oh shit!
They're still here!
I can't look behind!
I'm too scared to look behind me.
Not picking them.
The Reds lost a good man today because they didn't fucking
believe me when i said the blues are coming i just didn't
believe me
i will i don't want to be the last one to die i'm fucking
making that my mission not looking back i'm not stalling the
game this look there's still one there's still one yellow
two Two reds, one green, and that's me.
I'm the green.
Wait, the blues lost her bed.
Oh my god, it's possible.
I gotta keep, I can't, I gotta make sure.
Okay, here we go.
Oh my god.
Oh, yellow's out!
Yellow's out!
Not last!
I'll take those.
I fucking take those.
We're not last.
Okay.
It's okay.
We're not last.
Oh my god.
They're coming again.
I swear to God.
I will not die by his hands.
If anything, I refuse to die by this man's hand.
I will jump off before I die by a fucking filthy blue.
I will jump.
Jump off before I die to him.
Okay.
Where are they?
My goddamn blue.
Say one minute.
Oh my god.
It's 2-2-1.
How's that possible?
Bro, the moment they touch me, I'm fucking dead, guys.
Oh my god.
Where are they?
Where even is this fucking great war?
Where is the great red versus blue war?
Apparently.
Oh my god, there he is.
I'm fucking...
I'm booking it.
I don't know where the last red is.
Okay.
It's 1v1v1.
i can't believe i lived this long
how do i know if i'm like not on the border
i will jump to prevent myself from dying to a red to a blue
i will die to a red honorably but i will never but i will
never die to a blue
I will never die by your hands.
I'm blue.
Oh, no.
I think I'm a little fucked now.
He's like fucking spawn camping me right now.
Bro, that fucking sucks, man.
Bro, this fucking loser is trying to spawn camp me.
Down with the smers.
What the fuck is that red?
Red, we have to...
I will...
Red, I will team up with you Just to get rid of the blue I
will fucking team up with you
Okay, let's go Yeah!
We did it!
Down with the...
Down with the blues!
La live the king Wait.
Long live the king
Yay I did it guys Thieve Thieve I did it We did it everyone
We did it
Yay Who is that Um excuse me I wasn't good this distraction
I distracted him we fucking did it guys we fucking did all
right let's go find there is this other server that I want
to try up I really want to try up and I got them super
excited let's see uh what is this server don't worry guys
it's it's a really good server trust trust trust
is this the run is this the one oh is it okay
let's see if this one works
yeah we did it guys i
want to see if this works first
It's time for the true test, everyone.
It's time for the real test, everyone.
How do I start it?
Oh, hey, it's Christmas.
I'm pregnant.
Oh.
Give me a sec.
I gotta do...
I gotta do the...
Get the first ticket, guys.
Yeah.
I got it.
I don't know.
i start it
how do i start parkour civilization do
you jump for the chicken or a beef oh i got a chicken
where's the actual parkour civilization
wait oh my god did you see that i made it i made it oh right
click whoa okay okay we start the I did it.
Wait, let me give you guys the fucking code.
Too easy.
Too fucking easy.
Alright, here's the server.
I want to do the real parkour civilization.
Oh my god.
That's right.
You're looking at a fucking pro.
right now.
That's fucking right.
That's right.
You're looking at a goddamn pro right now.
Oh,
no.
I'm losing.
Oh.
Oh, yeah.
I'm parkouring.
Guys, does anyone have some extra chickens?
or a beef.
I've done a lot of these parkours before.
I am very experienced.
Okay.
Oh, I should have got more food.
I should have got more food.
I'm going to starve soon.
Oh my god.
Okay.
We're up here?
Oh.
We're doing it.
Are you guys already here?
We had a great stream.
I'm doing parkour civilization right now.
Okay.
That's right.
I'm gaming.
I'm sobering up too.
Parkour civilization is very serious business.
Oh god.
stone right now yeah that's looking right yummy yummy that's
looking right look at these guys look at them oh oh you so
scared not a pro not a fucking pro that's god damn right
this is how hard they get all of them Wait, wait, wait,
wait.
I wish I can knock people out.
That would be great.
If I can, okay, give me a ticket.
Wait, what happened?
What happened?
Why am I back here?
Why am I back?
Why am I here?
It says, get the food, and I was like, oh, I want the extra
food.
I want the extra.
I didn't realize it didn't mean
I poured an extra food.
I worked so out.
You get the fucking...
Okay, here it is.
Here it is.
Oh my god.
It said I was like, Oh, I want the chicken and the beef.
And it took me to the chicken.
The green.
The cookie green.
I thought I was so cool.
I should keep me taking the 10 gifted subs like you think.
Oh my god, what happened to me?
Oh my god, how the mighty have fallen.
I didn't fall once on that parkour.
What happened to me?
It's over.
It's so over.
I'm washed out.
I'm fucking washed.
Oh, I'm so hungry.
I'm so hungry.
Okay.
We can do this.
We've done it before.
We can do it again.
Okay.
This is easy.
This part is child's play.
It's when we have to do the fucking cobblestone shit.
We're fine.
We're okay.
Just half a heart.
It's just half a heart.
It's nothing to worry about.
I'm still moving.
Still have my legs.
If I can move my legs, I'm okay.
Okay.
Back where I started.
See?
Everything is fine.
Everything is okay.
I can still...
still move
it's okay it's like i died on purpose so i can restock on
food guys
why would it take me back i don't understand who built that
into the system okay okay okay okay we're gonna take it a
little slower i have to beat this before i move on to
something else i have to get back to where i was i have to
be the master builder oh wrong wrong franchise wrong block
franchise
yeah there you go it's fine look look we're getting there
the hard part was the the what do you call it the little
barrier shit
okay oh god here it is here's the real challenge the fences
what the fuck
are you a mod
right he's a grand master he's he's a fucking he's the grand
master wait how does he how how can he do that
how is he doing that
sir wait mr net mr uh Night times.
Can I please fly?
I was at the top and I accidentally click chicken.
Please, please, please, they're all There's no admins on a
fortune They are all asleep
I'm so sad
Oh my god, it gave me
a winning He gave me the champion food.
Look at that.
Oh, you're all jealous, aren't you?
I ate the golden apple.
Oh, I'll give you a master voucher.
Come.
Oh, oh, wait.
He said come here.
He's going to give me the master voucher.
Oh, my God.
I look.
I'm number one.
Headmaster wants to be my friend.
Yeah.
I can't buy a house.
Oh, I still have my gold.
I still have my gold.
I...
Let's make it go.
Oh my god.
I'm number one.
Stolen value.
It's not stolen if I was handed to it.
There we go.
Technically I am...
I am the master build.
I am the grandmaster Jump in void for free master And she
was number one Satify I think it was super chat Thank you
Merry Christmas you keep on with See the master The
grandmaster wants to be my friend Yeah
look at that that gives that fills me up with motivation
watch this i'm with him right now
it's it still fills me up with motivation okay i have to
make it to the top i will not stop until i make it back to
where i was
it's okay i still have my gold it's okay oh i could do slash
pro food right
okay it's okay is that grab this and then and then i'll do
this okay here we go here this is it this is it right here
this is the run this is is the run this is the run why can
they all just fly
okay i'm i'm making their day i'm making their day right now
they're like oh my god i can't believe so many people on the
server right now because because i just wanted to play
parkour civilization and i i told you guys we raid a random
minecraft server and then they'll be like what the fuck like
then they're like whoa what the fuck
it's okay we give them joy for a little bit we revitalized a
certain dead server for just for just one moment in time and
then toky t tossing around they're happy they gave me a
master voucher i'm technically a too because of it
I'm an honorary grandmaster yay I love handouts they greased
me from the heavens they really yay I gave a master stop
begging y'all I just gave a master voucher to a youtuber
stone peg yay streamer privilege yay got the yippee god's
chosen favorite i love streamer privilege yippee oh my god
gladi hip yay
om yum yum yum yum yum yum yum Don't, don't, don't.
Yay, add-ons.
Let's go.
Let's take a go.
Yeah.
Yeah, guys, I'm big.
Press this button, guys, guys, guys.
Press this button, guys.
And remember to press this button when you're up here.
I can't never again.
Never fucking.
again when i do this i'm a pro i think i'm a pro now oh my
god i fucking made
it but no
i need to get back i need to get back up there no
I don't understand I thought I thought it would spawn me
Back to where I I fucking made it And I have to redo the
entire thing
Mother you were the super chat Thank you What do you mean I
have to redo it all Oh my god how parkour civilization works
they give it and they take it so fast they really do
okay okay it's fine it's fine I'm still it's okay I still
have another I have all the handouts okay there you go All
right, here we go.
All right, here we go.
We gotta, we can make this.
We gotta get back to pro.
We gotta get back.
I know I said that last time, but we gotta get back.
We got, we got, we got.
Wait, is that the admin?
Are you admin?
Is that TP me back?
I'm getting a TP me back right now.
I...
Look, it's...
Oh, it's okay.
I still...
I still have one.
TP me up top right now.
I want to see the end.
Can you TP me to the end?
It'll be so funny, please It'll be so funny, please Bro, I
don't No, I don't want a parkour battle I can't No, he
fucking left Why no Oh my god, please Um He fucking left
left mo i thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
thank you your voice is so cute right now thank oh my god
thank you thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
okay i don't know what the master voucher is i don't know i
don't know what it does okay eat the steak what did it do oh
my god it gave me another voucher There you go.
It's okay.
We will be a pro.
We will become a pro.
Okay.
We're almost there.
We're halfway.
When we reach the cobble fences, I know that means I'm
halfway there.
Okay.
Alright.
We can do this.
Okay.
Okay, we're so close.
We're so close.
We're out of the cobblestones.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, we did it.
Oh my god, we're pro.
We're pro yet again.
We are pro.
We are pro again.
it we made it we're fucking back baby we're fucking back we
fucking did it we're fucking back it's real it's fucking
real it's real okay okay okay all right oh my god oh my god
admin please TP me to the end
I am shameless.
I want to be able to...
I want to know what it's like.
I don't want to...
I don't want to make the jump.
Yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
it's okay all right I don't all right someone make the jump
first you make the jump right now you I want to test it all
right okay now do the second jump okay cool okay okay okay
we got this it seems fine Oh No, it's snow.
It's snow.
Okay
Okay It's fine.
Everything will be fine.
I got this
All right Okay Okay
Oh, I made it Okay now you two you go up and then I go up
and
give me a sec i'm gonna get another drink i'm gonna i'm
gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna pee and then i'm gonna go get
another i'm gonna get another drink
you know what you know you know what i need right now you
know exactly you know what i need exactly right now guys
I think I think it might I don't think I was meant to be a
pro guys I don't think I was I think it's time to say you
know what you You know what we are?
You know what we are, guys.
We're a fucking new...
That's what we are.
You know, we...
You never make the joke.
up with a thief.
I know what I am.
I know what I have.
I can't be.
This is who I am.
I have I have accepted my fate.
But at least at least I have the master voucher.
What can I fucking do with this shit?
Can I buy a house?
Unlocks after 680.
I can have, I can afford a professional house, guys.
Oh my god.
Look, guys.
Stop giving them free stuff.
Oh, I'm a master!
I'm a ba- Oh my- Oh my god!
Look at me.
Wait, I'ma fight it.
Wait, wait, wait.
Now, wait, now look at me.
because he's poured out after giving them all the vouchers
bro
this guy one of them is such oh this i would say one of them
is such a nerd look at him like we should ban them for rain
they're like but this guy's like bro this guy's like we
should ban because they don't deserve they don't deserve the
role they don't deserve the role of master that's looking
crazy bro yeah it's so fucking like you didn't earn it
stolen valor you didn't fucking earn it bro I just wanted
more civilization bro but you're all done it's just yes ban
them all send them them send them to the pits it's like i
worked so hard to get master rick and then they just they
they just show up and got streamer privilege that's right i
will use my streamer privilege
this is that's true this is parkour civilization this is
very serious Stolen Stolen parkour Valor Jesus God Stolen
Valor Banner Banner
Um Music Thank you For the super chat Thank you Okay One
more For that Chris Cat open Thank you for the Super chat
music Thank you Thank you Rise Thank you for the super chat
Thank you.
Don't give one hour, guys.
I threw up
That's oh,
hello.
Oh my god.
It's the ultimate legend.
Hello.
Streamer privilege.
Yay!
Oh my god!
Oh, it's his house.
Oh my god, this is your fucking house?
Bro, I got T-Fab, bro!
The streamer privilege goes...
Streamer privilege, streamer privilege!
Just like that.
Bro, that's right.
I'm in the fucking champion's house now.
Only me.
Bro, nice crib, bro.
I'm in.
Damn, this game's so easy.
Oh my god, bro.
Your crib's sick.
My Ochi is so good at parkour.
That's crazy.
What is this?
Oh my god.
Bro, did he build this himself?
What's all of these masks?
Oh my god.
Guys, I'm hanging out with the cool kids right now.
Look at that.
Yeah, parkour green.
Guys, look at that, guys.
Oh my god.
Outspeed running parkour.
How the heck do you, did you get here?
I'm just that good.
That's freaking go.
He's so good.
It physically pays me to even think of this level of skill.
Look at that.
Oh my god, guys, they want to be my friend.
I don't even know how to explain.
that friend request guys i think guys i don't oh wait let's
go oh my god and i got demonic way
let's go i'm thinking let's go
yeah oh okay wait slash slash friend I'm so popular
I'm going to guys look I'm friends with the grandmaster I
can't I don't know why it won't let me be friends with it
wait friend and oh shit without the ad oh without the ad
okay slash friend and evil Wait, EVB, EVB Zero Grandmaster I
can't type very well right now I'm at my fucking Eight hour
mark I'm at the eight hour mark guys I can't fucking type no
more I'm not as you keep getting away with this That's like
you're right
I'm in the cool kids club right now.
Look at me.
I got wings.
Bro, if that guy wanted me bad, must be so fucking bad right
now.
He's like, bro, that's okay.
You know what I also want?
I want you to TP me to the end.
I'm like, I'm so greedy.
I was like, you know what?
It'd be even cooler if I get to, if you TP me to the end.
of the game i want more i want more friend at it's apollyon
i'm already on your friends list please no we already
friends greed sickens me and me two friends on bedrock oh my
god wait wait a minute wait a minute he's gonna do it wait a
way he's taking me to the fucking ender dragon wait what the
fuck is that where the end oh wait he's actually literally
taking me to the end he's actually he's actually taking me
to the end I've met like the end game of like the park or
civilization but i'll take this too i'll also take this at
literally actual end end that's a good girl let's go to the
end guys oh it doesn't work oh the end doesn't work the
monkey fall i said you to
The actual end, end.
We're gonna parkour on the dragon, guys.
We're gonna fucking parkour on the fucking end of your
dragon.
It's the hot tub.
We're on the hot tub now.
Just two bros sitting in the hot tub.
Six feet apart because we ain't gay.
Oh, shit.
I did
the fucking game guys I'm fucking insane she's going it I'm
gifted with the sticks guys all right legend fine wait slash
legend fine
Oh, I must be gladiator or higher to use this.
It's okay.
I am, though, guys.
No, no.
It's just glitched, guys.
I'm not stolen Valor.
Guys, it's just glitched, okay?
It just has a little...
It's just a little glitch, guys.
A small bug, chat.
Just a small bug.
I worked so hard for this moment.
I'm so happy.
We are the champions.
No time for losers.
Because we are the champions.
Look at us go.
We're so fucking insane.
I'm doing a victory lap right now.
This is my victory lap.
This is my fucking victory lap right now.
Wait, what?
What is he?
What did he mention?
What did he want from me?
Oh my god.
guys.
This is so good.
Parker Civilization, when?
Want a free rank up?
Yes.
Guys, he said it's not streamer privilege.
Oh!
Oh my god, I did it!
I'm so good at parkour.
I just happened so fast, guys.
It happened so fucking fast.
I know you guys missed it, but I was like, I was like, bam,
bam, bam, bam.
And then I made it down here.
I know it's fucking wild.
He said it wasn't streamer privileged, chat.
Like, I think I am, I had to believe him that he said, like,
if he said it's not streamer privileged, then I don't think
it is.
Yeah, it's just raw talent.
it really is i'm just a very quick learner now how do i get
out of here okay after you fight your journey as a gladiator
starts here now where do i go where do i go like go back
okay i just locked in not everyone has those skills oh dude
slash gladiator oh nice now look at that guys what the fuck
i can i need your help there is someone evil that i need you
to stop he will destroy parkour civilization his name is
blank you're the only person that can I have the time
traveler Go to the find the past version Media and he will
tell you what you Must do I Oh he died of old age Oh no Okay
The future I am The chosen one Who happens to Where the fuck
am I Where Where am I but i think bp should have actually
watched parkour civilization
maybe i should have watched i've been fucking hell right now
i'll go to slash master okay oh my god slash master and then
okay and then now that i'm here to do this?
Oh my god, where am I?
Where am I?
I might need to go back to Gladiator.
I might have messed up just a little bit.
Only a little bit.
Okay.
Here you go.
Okay No one It's okay.
I can do this, though Look at this I shall show you How How
I am It's okay if I keep going in the future I'll live I'll
just keep going to the future Its okay It's okay Oh, I'm
already in the future Wait, I'll go to the present I'll go
to the present There you go, there you go.
I'm alive.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Um So we do have a couple of issues right now.
It's okay.
Um, um, let me eat this so I am on master again.
Don't worry.
I'm back to master, guys.
I did it.
okay so um we have a problem we have a problem look i i will
say that it was ping um would would someone fake her way to
being a fucking gladiator parkour artists no because that's
fucked up i would never do such a fucking thing okay i
earned it all right like you guys might not have seen it
because i did it so fucking fast that you guys just didn't
see it happen um i there's how could i fake it till i'm
there's no such you guys faking it till i make it when when
this was all pure skill baby
Exactly, exactly.
True skill.
I made the advancement to master.
Let's go.
See, they even acknowledged it in chat, too.
It was acknowledged right here.
I made the advancement to master.
Oh, me, baby.
I'm so good
All right Okay guys Wait what time is it Guys what was my
schedule Wait I don't even remember my schedule Let me look
at my schedule Real quick Oh my god Where's the image I
fucking saved this Oh there we go Alright We Our behind
schedule but that's okay i'm having fun um all right poll
time we'll do a poll let's say goodbye to our fellow mat
parkour civilization people goodbye it was fun it was fun i
hope i hope i hope your server becomes alive i shall now i
the parkour prodigy shall leave now
but yes if you guys want to check out the server they were
nice people they were nice people i still think it's so
funny when that one guy was like bender bender she doesn't
deserve the fucking roll and then they gave me higher and
higher rolls after the guy kept telling begging the admins
to ban me like they kept telling they kept fucking telling
them the bad me and then they just like you promote me
higher and higher
i made it guys i did it everyone
yeah check them out that was fun they were pretty cool he
read he he was playing parkour civilization every single day
for hours and then you just rolled up and fuck he was like
can you TP me to the end he was just jealous he truly he was
so jealous of my pure skill i am truly the grandmaster
parkour minecrafter exactly i truly am
We'll do, alright, here we go.
Let's see, where's pull?
Oh my god, I just forgot how to fucking, alright, Twitch
pull.
Twitch pull, I'm sorry, YouTube.
Wait, you know what, I'll do YouTube pull.
Oh, fuck, I have to boot up YouTube.
Okay, wait.
Okay, wait, I can do it.
Alright, here we go.
Let me, five, okay, start a pull.
Okay, Fortnite, or Rivals?
Fortnite.
I could type better now, I'm like, a little bit more sober.
Okay.
I'm a little bit more sober now, chat.
So I can type now.
I can type again.
Alright, it's a YouTube poll this time.
Alright, see, I favor...
There's no favoritism going on.
Oh yeah, let me go back to here.
There we go.
Hello, welcome back, my children.
Welcome back to me and Yumi.
I'd welcome back to me and Yumi
and we do rivals I will make sure that it will be oh my god
what's what was the schedule give me a sec okay I will make
sure it will be only an hour long I will promise you we are
behind schedule little bit.
There is no schedule only raps.
Alright.
It's been fun so far.
I hope everyone has been having lots of fun playing with me
and hanging out with me, chat.
I hope you guys are having a great Christmas stream with me
today.
Or even just if you're hanging out with family, just
dropping by right now.
Or like, was Dropping in and out.
I hope you guys still have a fun lap.
Words are very hard right now.
English is my first language, but I hope you guys have been
having a fun time hanging out with me.
I have not drank alcohol in a very long time, so...
So I'm, like, all over the place right now.
All right.
It seems like...
Wait, who what?
Alright, Rivals 1!
Mod, change the title and the game category and add drops.
Remember to add the exclamation point drops for me.
Mod.
Okay, let's swap over.
Alright, here we go.
I have...
Fuck, I need to remember my settings.
I need to remember my...
Bum-bitty-bitty-bitty-bitty.
bum bum bitty bitty bitty bum bum bitty bitty bum oh my god
that sounds stuck in my head bum i didn't even realize like
the other lyrics in that song it was literally bum but oh my
god i'm gonna be throwing games i feel so i just realized oh
that's not good for people who got me on their team oh it's
okay it's okay i can lock in i will lock in don't worry guys
don't worry i can lock in where's marvel right oh there's an
update what
i realized that there might be consequences to my actions i
mean okay oh yeah remember to add drops too for uh to like
be like drops yes as well even though like i don't know how
many how yeah we could okay we'll do one game of 16 versus
16 we could do that wait is 16 versus 16 still in still in
the game oh no not the consequences of my own action no no
oh my god i forgot to close all the tabs that i used for
making my stream stuff forgot all about it i have like 20
tabs open for this let me start closing them one bop one no
wonder i was lagging so much
okay i'm slowly closing them close close no i have more than
20 tabs but i open 20 tabs just for this i i forgot all
about it
I forgot to close something.
Oh, that was a lot of tabs I just closed, guys.
I've just been closing tabs one by one.
Oh, shit.
What?
Wait, everyone left Face Clan.
What the fuck happened?
Bro, no.
How would I be?
Bro.
How can I, who would I say face up to?
I think, oh my god, did they all let face clan?
Bro, every, like, all the big boys left face clan.
Yeah, did they explode?
Oh my god, they must have exploded or something.
Face down, no!
Oh my god, face down!
I can't believe it happened.
It's no longer phase up.
No, they were making, I bet they were making like millions
of dollars, dollar runies.
Alright.
Yeah, who would start the fucking crypto scams now?
Oh my god.
Oh, I hate that.
Okay, I gotta fix my game real quick.
You might not hear anything yet because I still haven't like
changed.
my monitor usb not usb html monitor uses a usb cable with
the hdmi shit because it's plugged into a monitor my chat
monitor is plugged into my first monitor one so it's
actually a huge fucking pain because it's very inconvenient
all right give me a sec because i have to swap it to my my
main monitor right here you go that should work the fuck is
i solo i don't know who this guy is all right here you go is
there still 16 versus 16.
oh yeah i should buy the new cloak and dagger shit what the
fuck is fluxa i'm buying this shit first
Yeah.
Oh, I bought that too.
I don't care about that.
Who the fuck is Fluxus?
Are you on my friends list?
Oh, it's permanent now?
Wait, you're not even on my friends list.
Oh, I have gifts awaiting?
I have gifts?
Okay.
No, it's not retail therapy.
Just look at how much I have.
It's not even retail.
It's...
I just...
I don't know what else to spend on it.
Oh my god.
I don't play Captain America.
But I'm here to ball.
I'm here to fucking ball though.
Bro, I'm here to...
Bro, I want to fucking go to Times Square.
But if I go to Times Square, I get DMCA...
I mean, the stream is already DMCAed.
But like...
But like, I don't want to fucking get parts of my VOD muted.
It's so annoying.
so I want oh my god okay no I should wait oh my god wait we
have to guys there is a reason why we have to go to Times
Square I forgot but it's fine I'll take it for the team
because there's something very important there it's and I
want a ball we
got a ball
so they these guys will camp they camp Fucking time square
for like hours and hours so they can oh my so they can like
fucking be as big as they can be We're in a fucking ball
right here.
So we eat this And then I become big now Why is it just so
these guys would literally just camp there and then just be
as big as they could just farm to be as big as possible as
long as they can they're the true heroes but like we gotta
refresh this where i can open my gift what did i get yeah
more free currency okay but like not these guys we gotta
leave time square because because we gotta find we gotta
find the right people
There we go.
When the chips are down, you want your heroes a little
roguer.
Remember?
We're in the snow.
It's tired here.
I see who the right people are.
Yay!
I'm here for business.
Merry Christmas, everyone!
Merry Christmas!
Yeah!
Right here, right here, right here, right here.
You gotta be-
Oh my god, I wish I did- I wish it- you made me smaller,
though.
it was i told you we had to find the right people guys see
like this every hour so they would like literally sit here
every hour just to like fucking farm these sandwiches so
they could get even bigger because you can build it up but
it is more venom when you get added to the naughty list but
you just don't care i'm just wait it was Let me see.
I'm, guys, guys, don't worry.
I'll be part, look.
I'm just like, I'm, I'm like the little bro.
I'm the little bro here.
I'm, the little bro.
Little bro, part of the big, with his big bros.
Let's go.
I tilt this up.
What the fuck?
What?
Oh my god.
He's a tree now.
Who let little bro in?
You get added to the nondiless, but it's your own reward.
I'm shaking it with the big bros.
Brothers.
Let us all shake our booties.
Shake what God gave us to us, brothers.
Okay, I should play a game now.
I'm sorry.
show you guys this like i said i like how like i was like we
gotta find our people and then literally we found them right
away we instantly found our people right away right i don't
want to start i want to start a custom lobby okay custom
game create me
there we go i confirm and then i and then i do
wait i don't know about give me a sec and then i do room
settings what the do i oh competitive okay wait where's oh
quick match arcade wait where's 18 versus 18 guys where the
fuck is 18 versus 18
i was live oh there it is i found it i found it guys i found
it guys you can more people can join in now guys i found it
everyone all right move you here guys remember to move over
is that console
okay it is
all right here we go
we are on 18 versus 18 and we the title of this the title of
the lobby is the Grand Master Jokey Bird.
It's the Grandmaster Jokey Bird.
That's the title.
Oh my god.
Is Orca finally being able to play with me?
I'd like see her tweet every day be like, please play with
me.
It's time.
It's her moment.
It's her fucking moment.
moment
all right we still have one two three four five six slots
left
we have six more slots one two three four five six guys
i see every jesus christ where do you live 900 and where the
do you live Like Mars?
Are you playing for the fucking moon?
Where are you?
Are we fucking playing on the fucking moon right now?
That's crazy.
Bro, are you coming?
Bro is at Mars.
It's grand.
You can search up Doki Bird and you'll find me.
We have one, two more slots.
Two more slots.
One more.
one more slot guys he's at the door full but was that
McDonald's alright here we go alright start I've never
played 18 versus 18 but this is the first time I'm gonna
turn off VC because I'm sorry I can't trust you guys I just
remembered about that forgot about that I do not trust
anyone right now
oh my god give me a sec let me like i'm too lazy to like
okay there we go that should be good that should be good all
right here we go don't worry i got this triple support oh
wait there's 18 of us it might be more than triple support
okay wait actually maybe i should wait a hundred Oh, she's
smart.
Thank you for the 10 gift.
Oh my bro.
Okay.
I'm fucking I'm fucking lagging, bro Bro, okay, this is not
good for me like What the fuck I'm lagging so hard That is
so many people that is so many people.
Yes What the fuck is going on?
Jesus Christ I can't see anything.
I actually I can't I'm lagging so hard It's so it's too many
people.
It's so many
Oh my god, wait, oh wait is this supposed to have okay
Okay, give me a sec this is not bro, okay guys I think 18
versus 18 it's oh my god 19 frames i am not doing so well
nine oh my a hundred frames is an actual ass this is ass
right now for me
how many posts is there
Where is he?
There you go, he's dead.
Oh my god, Gambit never falls, guys.
Oh my god, where am I?
Where the fuck?
Oh, Gambit never falls!
Oh my god, what's going on?
Wait, I could kill you.
I could kill myself in game.
Oh, point again, point again!
Let's go.
Okay, this is getting a little bit better Where is he?
Bro, I can't, I could barely fucking fight with this With
this frames right now Like Oh my god, happy holidays Oh
It's like my skin's lagging too No, this is This is an
interesting experience right now This is very interesting
Okay Like, I...
Oh my god, where am I?
Oh, hey, I can...
Oh.
Oh my god, guys, guys.
Don't mess with the amazing Spider-Man.
It's okay.
We have so many healers.
There's no way we can die with the amount of heals we have.
Look at these goddamn...
Don't mess with the amazing Spider-Man.
is actually is that what 18 versus 18 is like is it always
like this guys okay to the fucking 18 versus 18 enjoyers to
farm lord because apparently you can farm lord on this but
like is this what it's like do you just get nothing like you
get zero frames yes okay okay that's good okay i was gonna
say like oh my god i was gonna be very worried It's always
that's good to know that it's always that bad Oh my god, oh
my okay, it's fine It's okay It's okay Gambit never falls
They're all just flying There we go I will fuck you solo up
Oh, God.
I want to know what the dragon was doing with the 999
frames.
Guys, if we all play Adam, just imagine, imagine like, how-
Oh, my God!
Bro, Becky, what the fuck?
Bro, that shark literally killed everyone.
That shark killed everyone.
The Marble Slideshow.
Like, what's the point?
I don't even know.
I feel very nerfed right now.
Like, it's not even, it's not even, like, possible for me to
play.
Okay, surprisingly, I am surprised I got that amount of
kills.
How fucked, like, everything was.
I'm surprised I even got this amount of kills.
Oh, my God.
Like, the frame was crazy.
All right.
All right, guys.
I'll make another lob.
I want to do...
I don't know if I want to try that again, actually.
Don't know that.
Okay, I'm going to see if it's 18% 18 or it's just me.
Or if it's just me.
I'm going to try this real quick.
I got a no.
Because that was fucking crazy.
GG's, though.
I need a no.
Like, that shit was fucking weird as hell.
A perfect way to check up.
This is I thought.
I'm like...
I had like 70 frames.
I was like, whoa.
I'm like, yeah, I don't have.
How the fuck do I do that?
But like, I usually don't have that issue.
So I was like, what the fuck?
How do I have 70 frames?
Ooh, when I'm turning, it's like, maybe it's because I'm
dual streaming too.
I think it's also because I'm dual streaming.
Oh, yeah, no, I think it's also I'm also because I'm dual
streaming because me turning is also Yeah When I turn it
goes from a hundred to I think it's because I'm also multi
streaming Because usually I don't have that issue.
Yeah, it's the dual streaming.
I'm pretty sure The dual streaming has made it go to the 40
Oh, ah, oh, I'm sorry, it's so bad.
This is actually fucking gross.
For me, I'm not a fan.
I know you guys, like, I can see the difference.
It's a huge difference, yeah.
It's actually a huge fucking difference for me.
I don't know if it's noticeable on stream, but, like, I feel
like I'm...
I feel like I'm watching a slideshow right now on my end.
Yeah.
I think it's dual streaming.
Well, at least I know you can't dual stream Marvel Rivals.
Yeah.
No, it literally feels like I'm playing on a PowerPoint
right now for me.
Hey, I'm not...
Oh my god, this is so hard to aim.
Oh my god, you should have fucking been dead.
There you go.
runs
Okay, thank God I check quickly guys.
Thank fucking guys Thanks, yeah, I think you definitely need
a dual PC setup to do this.
Thank God.
Thank God Thank God.
I check.
Yeah, if I was playing ranked game with With this yeah,
that'd be like bad Yeah, I had to make sure because I was
like bro There's no way it's that that bad.
Like, I heard 18 versus 18 was such a popular game mode,
too.
So I was like, what the fuck?
I thought I was, like, so surprised.
I was like, it'll be cool if my team pushes forward.
Oh, no.
It wasn't.
Oh, my team didn't push forward.
Yeah.
It's unlucky.
Wow.
Hey, how come we didn't stack up here?
What the fuck?
It's quick play, bro.
What the fuck do you mean?
What the fuck?
Yeah, no, I think...
The worst part is like... I mean, I could play Scarlet
Witch.
it might be easier to play scarlet witch for me right now
here we go bro why does he say what the fuck we're quick but
jesus christ
i mean that's cool
all right here we go i like the sound effects for the side
lock though oh nice nice angela i'm so happy for for you i'm
trying i hope i need them to end this fast i did oh goodbye
goodbye luna oh he lives i blocked this they are the most oh
fuck okay i was like they are the most passionate no it
doesn't matter it's literally um it's literally uh it's just
streaming.
Oh, we got the point?
Let's fucking go.
Oh, I got out of Invis, because I'm hoping that there you
go.
Hey, guys.
Oh, my God.
They're all stacked up again.
Are you?
I took out.
I took out that's fine.
That's fine.
I took those.
Oh, my God.
I fucking knew he was going to do that, too.
That's why I fucking ran.
Oh, I still died.
Okay.
No, it feels like I'm I'm basically watching a PowerPoint
right now.
So it's like really weird.
Because I can tell the difference between frames.
Because I've been playing on high frames for so long.
Like the thing is, like when you go forward, you can't go
back.
You can't fucking go back.
It's actually, it sucks too.
Like, because like you're so used to playing high frames.
That every, it just feels like hell.
Like you don't know how good it is until it's gone type
deal.
it's literally like that you don't know how good it is until
you lose it
because it's like um because you can't you literally can't
go back
everything just looks like super slow afterwards I love
every person I can do this and do that
I think it's crazy that people are still like judging rivals
for being for the gooner skin when everyone's like it like
you know because it's like bro like we all know like what
what this game is like every everyone knows what Rattles is
it's been like a year now you're still judging the gooners
skins it's crazy people are like i'm so tired of these skins
being good i'm like it's been like that's just the beginning
of the game's launch what do you
change and we get gooner men and female skins bro
all right
oh i gotta kill him yeah weakling wait who's fucking still
oh he's all right there you go yeah that's that's crazy that
they're still like fucking saying shit about have like oh
man how dare how dare they release more gooner skins and i'm
like bro
it's been like that in the beginning bro gooner skin cell
they've always sold why do you think also wait actually why
actually no kiriko is like kiriko is like always sold no
matter what but it doesn't have to be gooner skin.
All right, guys.
Unfortunately, because...
Unfortunately, because I think it's because I'm dual
streaming.
No, it doesn't matter.
Because, like, I think it's just because I'm dual streaming
that...
That, like, my frames are going...
You know what I'm going to do?
I'm going to check.
No, my CPU and memory are fine.
I think it's literally just because of dual streaming.
though no i cannot i cannot play cop lobby like this like
it's actually it's so bad let me try this in practice i went
full screen
oh yeah no bro it dropped the 30 what the fuck i'm in the
practice range what is this loading what it fucking got the
30 at one point.
Am I fucking loading the Empire State Building?
How did it drop the 830?
Alright.
I think we gotta get off.
It's been fun.
18 versus 18.
Maybe we'll try 18 versus 18 again next time when I'm not
dual streaming.
I'm loading to the fucking moon right now i'm loading like
other people's textures
that's crazy
no it would tell you if i have shaders loading but i
definitely don't all right you know it's been fun we had we
had two games it's been we tried our best guys we try your
best
I think it definitely made more sense why why it was like
that you want to say okay look I will you I will I will
entertain this I will boot up at Fortnite just because I
wanted to buy some skins anyway I was gonna but I have to
buy some skins anyway on Fortnite today I shall humor
Fortnite just because of that
you have been freed from rivals Oh, yeah, mods, can you
change?
Can you change?
Oh, yeah, update on if Zandu got his Snow Miku skin, he
forgot his Fortnite password, so unfortunately he wasn't
able to get it.
He was literally like, I forgot my... He was so sad.
He was like, I forgot my Fortnite login.
Oh, yeah, mods, can you change my category real quick to
Fortnite and be like buying skins yeah buying yeah you got
you got me you got me you know you know what I wanted
maybe also my PC is like bro and I expect you to stream this
not which is understandable oh shit wait seal the brain
route what the fuck did I fucking click what the fuck did I
click what the fuck is this That's why I steal the brain
rot.
Okay, the guy's like, oh my god, I can finally show you
guys.
Look, I have SpongeBob.
Yes, look at my...
Okay, guys, guys, I need to show you guys.
Look at my shoes, though.
Look at my shoes.
And then, wait.
I know what.
Look at this.
I have...
Okay.
I got this.
Rara, Rara, Rara, Rara, Rana, Rana, Rana, Rana.
no no no no oh me yeah no i i'm not surprised that i'm not
doing so well right now it's one or the other all right so
this is what i bought i bought snow miku and then i also
bought so i got this and then i also got doobab
also got i got the i got the the fucking golden spatula and
then i also got oh wait what the fuck oh yeah we all okay
and then i had to buy this i i paid for this i also bought
the sponge bath things but but this is very important It's
very important and I think that that's everything.
That was everything that was important to me.
Oh, wait, I guess like emotes to it.
Wait Okay, I can't show too much, but there's the jellyfish
dance All right
Okay, shock time.
Oh, yeah, I show speeds in here now, but, like, I'm very
disappointed.
I thought it'd be cool.
Also, by the way, I have a creator code.
Please use my code.
So, I'm really disappointed in his skin, only because, like,
the emote's pretty bad.
I don't really...
Because he's so expressive as a person.
He's so expressive as a person, but the emote...
Oh yeah, K-pop Demon Hunter is back.
But I'm not K-pop.
I don't know.
I mean, I wish they had better emotes, though.
I mean, I think the songs were cool.
But like, I'm not like that obsessive over K-pop Demon
Hunter's.
I have seen the movie, but I'm not like one of those people
who are like, oh my god, I fucking love K-pop Demon Hunter.
I do like the movie, but I'm not, like, you know, I'm not,
like, super obsessed with it.
Oh, Stranger Things is back.
I heard, oh, Jinx is back.
Oh, the hammer.
Wait, isn't that the...
Oh, I wish this was, like, more arcane-y.
I like the arcane art style.
But this feels too fortnighty It feels a little too for Oh
that's cute What else Oh my god Santa Oh my god Sabrina
carpenter What other stuff do they have Yeah I think Oh look
Z Miku's here I have the whole set I bought the whole set
What's this What's this we don't oh i have gritty i have
gritty okay oh man okay okay i hope i hope i hope they don't
strike me i want me baby don't you want me i love you you
know i like the sign but the dance is like not that cool oh
yeah the the song oh hey yeah so back to the future is here
too so you can actually get the the lord the dorian and
everything yeah you can literally get uh doctor doc brown
doctor brown oh this is why why did i forget give me a sec
sorry this was actually I forgot this was why I needed to
buy it like it like gave me like a jump scare there when I
saw it I was like oh my god it was that it was this I needed
to get
that I I forgot I almost forgot about it
it's cuz I did Buddha fortnight yeah I was like I'm a Buddha
of anyway today
Okay, I got it.
I did.
I had my code up.
Don't worry.
I got it.
My code is on.
Okay, now you're making me paranoid.
Yes, my code is on.
All right.
Oh, my God.
Wait, I need to be...
I want to be the Joker.
And then...
All right, there we go.
This was what I had to buy.
This was what I needed to buy.
Nice.
With his crocs too.
With his fucking kicks.
Let's go.
With SpongeBob.
Oh my god.
I hate.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
Okay, that works, that works.
One for life for Christmas.
There is
I can make him catapult.
and the macarina oh my god the zoom in and macarina I love
Fortnite I literally go on just to fucking buy shit can't
stop you Christmas is over guys I have a feeling I'm still
gonna if I'm lagging right now I have a feeling I'm gonna
lag even more when I'm in game but i bought my skins i
bought i fucking bought my skins that's all we needed and he
has his crocs on too he has his kicks on guys he got his
kicks on and oh my god i want to see him on chenron real
quick oh fuck oh yeah in his skibbity toilet you know if i
if there was a better backpack i would put it on but what i
have right now oh unless i put Or, or Pickle Rick.
Actually, no, I think...
I think Pickle Rick is a better backpack with the Joker.
Oh, Christmas is wonderful, isn't it?
It really is.
I love...
Merry Christmas, everyone.
I missed out on Among Us, okay?
It was when I wasn't...
I took a break.
I took a break from Fortnite.
missed out on Among Us and the repo, guys.
I'm so sad.
I missed out on Peek.
I was just so busy.
The one time I let my guard down.
The one time.
But I'm pretty sure people do dual streaming.
I mean, like non-VTubers.
I feel like VTubers who do dual streaming um a lot of them
don't play like intent like like really intense games like
like you know my rivals is like i will say it's not like
very optimized um it's not like incredibly optimized but and
it's very like cpu intensive too so like they don't it's
like i think like people who usually do dual streaming for
shit like that they'll have streaming pcs uh yeah i mean
sorry multi-streaming yeah they'll have definitely have like
a two do a pc setup and stuff which makes sense which makes
sense you know yeah right because it would help a lot yeah
because i have 50 90 and i have a lot i bought a lot of ram
before the ram thing happened before it happened i had i
bought a lot of ram i don't remember how much i have but it
was a lot um and i also have that 50 90 too so um it's just
not my pc it's literally like it's just too much i just need
a second pc for that yeah before the ram drought thank god
all right it's time for good night dragons all right let me
go change real quick guys i'll change real quick um what is
this all right whoops give me whoops don't worry about it
there we go yay alright it's good night try we're almost
nearing the end nearing the end of our Christmas stream I
have so much work to do
alright let's where is it alright guys All right, Timmy and
Yimmy.
We're going to have to move real quick to the next room.
Guys, to our good night dragon's room.
Here we go.
Oh, wait, that's the wrong one.
Sorry, here we go.
Same tree, though.
Same tree.
Sorry, I bought two trees.
It said night room, so I went with, oh, that has to be the
night room.
Alright.
No, don't worry.
Timmy and Yimmy, you're still here, guys.
It's been fun.
It's been really fun.
But I hope you guys have been having a great time.
The stream isn't ending, by the way.
The stream isn't ending yet.
We still have, we still have, we're still hanging out.
It's just, we're at the part where we're just, we're just
relaxing.
We're cooling down now.
We're cooling down from everything.
now it's dorky dear time um also i'm texting about you guys
give me a sec i'm i'm sub-tweeting you i'm sub-tweeting you
right now give me a sec time to relax time to slowly become
sober guys i'm not sipping more i'm gonna try and sober
myself up right now here uh thank you to the mod to the mods
for helping out with sound changing the titles and the
games.
I really appreciate it, guys.
Oh, yeah, vague tweet.
I'm vague posting.
It's called vague posting now, not sub-tweeting anymore.
It's been a very fun Christmas stream.
I feel like the...
The nine...
The ten hours passed by...
That's crazy that we didn't lag on Roblox.
Roblox was like our...
Our least laggy game.
Oh, yeah.
I'm park or civilization.
um but it's been fun the powers really did pass by so much
and i hope for those who are spending their holidays their
christmas with with us here with the dragons um had a great
time hanging out uh today with us um i think this is the
longest christmas stream i've done so far so um yeah It
really was.
It was really really fun.
I am cooling down right now.
Oh, yes.
There's something I actually really want to do.
I want to do some New Year's resolutions with you guys
because this project that we will have a New Year's
countdown stream and everything.
But with a special project for New Year's, we won't have
time to do New Year's resolutions.
So I'll do it now.
um there's one thing i really want and that is easily one
million subscribers by the end of 2026 it's a huge goal um
but 2026 i'm planning on you know getting back into kick of
things uh getting back into gear because i i have been slack
i i personally think i was slacking this year I focused more
so on doing conventions and doing convention sponsors and
joining other people's events and not doing stuff, you know,
not doing stuff on my own channel.
And, you know, I don't put that next year.
I want to be much more productive when it comes to like
building up my own channel and building up my own, I guess
my...
Uh, my channeling in and building up my, what's the word, my
scope, I guess.
Um, I don't try to get, I'm trying to like figure out the
wording for it.
I guess building up my, my reach, I guess.
My global reach and stuff.
And also I want to collab with more, I want to collab with
new people next year.
I want to make new friends and I want to collab with more
people next year.
Oh, yeah, building up my brand more.
Yeah, yeah, I like that.
And also, I want to next year focus on collabing with new
people at least every other week, I think.
I want to try doing that and making more new friends.
Because I know this year, I was very closed off.
I was very very closed off in general because like you know
after everything that's happened I was very you know I
didn't really want to I was too scared to really interact
with people outside outside the people that like you know I
was already really close with but I want to interact with
more people next year but I still be careful I'll still be
careful because like I said you know I still have trust
issues and at best I just won't tell people things I think
that's the easiest no that one collab a week thing fucking
burns me out so hard because like I was so fucking tired um
because it was just way too many collabs um I'm not gonna do
that I'm gonna be like every other week because I do like
solo streams I really like solo streams because I just like
hanging out with my dragons um I just bantering with you
guys and everything
and aim for every other week I think every other week is
much more ideal than I think for like the first half of the
year because like you know trying to collab with new people
like the entire year is like unfeasible it's unrealistic
because there's like you know there's not enough people I
mean there is a lot of people around like in content
creation but you know what I mean is I want to be I still
want to be careful with who I interact with like who I want
to do stuff with and things.
And I still want to, you know, it also depends on like
chemistry wise as well.
Like, you know, I don't want to like force a collab with
someone that might not have good chemistry with.
So like maybe for the first half of the year, I'm going to
try and do a collab every other week.
And then also, you know, a million subscribers, a million
subscribers.
I mean, I should write this down.
I'm going to write this down real quick.
I want to make pasta too.
I'm like, I should head to bed right away, but I really want
to pasta.
one oh wait that's true i actually wrote one million
subscribers
these are my new years one million subscribers what else um
oh my god guys okay i know i have a stream tomorrow but like
I canceled a stream.
Yes last week too I might push the stream Yeah, dr. Evil
cook
Okay, I'm gonna I might push the stream later.
I think I might push the stream a little like an hour later
I feel bad because I already canceled a stream I know it's
okay guys.
I'm gonna push the stream an hour later Yeah.
It's okay.
I feel bad because I already canceled a stream last week
too, but I think it'd be better if I push it an hour later
just because like I'm thinking about timing and stuff.
Yeah.
Um, also, okay, yeah.
Collab.
Do a collab with someone new every every other week.
Yeah, but I also streamed on Christmas.
26 is when people are more like, available too so um there's
people who weren't able to watch the stream you know today
because it is christmas uh 26 is normally the day where
people are more free
uh wrestle tuber
guys okay i'm sorry i didn't have wrestle tuber this year i
was so overwhelmed with everything going on i'm really sorry
i kept saying like don't worry guys i am working on it and
then like it was just so oh shit hey i'm red now you know
red's cute oh but i don't like this guy on me never mind
wait let me fix this real quick well i know that i'm
changing i'm rgb right now i'm sorry i i'm trying to get rid
of the ribbons right now i don't remember how let me figure
out how to get rid of the ribbons
The fuck where the fuck is the where the fuck is that rip
that always have ribbons guys?
Oh my god, I don't even remember if I've always had ribbons.
I'm gonna fucking it
I don't even remember That was there always ribbons on me
No, how the fuck okay.
Oh, yeah, by the way, I trimmed my I trimmed the bird away I
look so weird about it I trimmed my ears
I can't get rid of it.
It's not getting off.
I unburdened myself.
Oh my god.
Wait.
Give me a sec.
Now I'm fucking...
Now it's fucking with me.
I gotta disappear for a sec.
This is very important.
Alright.
let's see oh it's b b for bows oh i should have expected
that b for bows i that that yeah that that seems right i'm
gonna turn it off though
turn all off oh wait i can't turn it off what the okay it's
fine i changed the number i can't change the number is
locked that's okay b for bow oh yeah this is why wrestle
tuber didn't come into fruition this year because i was so
overwhelmed with everything that i literally just couldn't i
could die i was so tired there's way there was just so much
going on.
I was always playing catch-up.
That's the thing.
I was always playing catch-up, so I never really had the
time to actually focus on anything, because I'm always,
like, I'm always, like, trying to catch up.
Uh, what else?
What else do I want to accomplish?
Oh!
Get a video to a million views get a video upload to
a million views publish my original songs there's like a lot
like they've all been like oh my god be for bows again all
right here you go no a video upload that's not a short
that's not
a short okay me being that cody video does not fucking count
guys like it doesn't count oh wait sorry i can't i can't i
can't read i should i should be here
yes because he used because i told him he can use my face as
clickbait I'm on the thumbnail.
I said I gave him permission to use me as clickbait, guys.
Are my songs not on YouTube music for covers?
I put in the YouTube music category.
I don't know if there's anything else I want to aim for.
Not really.
There's not really merch goals, I feel.
Oh, wait, actually there is one.
Get...
And gaming jokie bird mouse pad.
This one.
That's the one thing I would like.
I would actually use it.
I usually use the xian.
I use the hian gaming mouse pad.
But it would be really cool.
So yeah, gaming jokie bird mouse pad.
And it would be cool.
I don't know how many people would actually use it.
But it doesn't help a lot when it comes.
For those who are actually...
uh for those who are actually are serious about like fps
games or gaming gaming in general um gaming mouse pads do
help a lot it really does uh improve your aim i hope more
people would buy it than dog shirts yeah
cloth or glass though i mean it depends on which company
hits me up i fucking will say yes to company that I just
haven't had an offer yet I haven't had a company I've been
trying to like I try to like ask uh I've been like my
manager and I have been like trying to get wall hack but
they've been like saying no because they don't know how much
it'll sell so then at that point I'll take anyone that
wouldn't make a gaming mouse bad I
just haven't been successful because we've been we like to
have a wall hack custom gaming mouse pad but um like i said
like it's very you know people are scared like it's like a
risk you know that's why i was like uh which whichever
gaming mouse pad company wants to make me a custom gaming
mouse pad i'll just say yes to it
i want to hold in uh I do, yeah, because like, you know...
It made more sense for like pro gamers to have a gaming
mouse pads, you know, but like for me, since I am a VTuber,
I mean, I do play FPS games, but even then it's like a niche
within a niche type deal, you know?
It's like a niche within a niche.
Also like, the hardest part is like I would like to go with
an American company.
Only because of terrorists.
That's like my only concern.
It's terrible, sir.
Because I know that I do have a lot of American dragons.
And like, yeah, no, it's really, yeah.
The thing, yeah.
Yeah, the terrorists are...
fucked I mean if it was a Canadian company the rest of the
world will be happy
that's the biggest issue it's so it sucks because it's like
it's like if it's Canada then the rest of the world will be
happy but it was in America then it's like uh it's like
American goons will be happy oh 3d debut I gotta work on the
3d debut I have not finished play I put I had to I had to
put it on what's the word 3d debut that's why we haven't had
sorry the RGB every time I press a key that's why we haven't
I had I want to use my 3d model but I'm waiting until I have
my actual official 3d debut to actually use it but it's been
like put I like have to bench it for a little bit um because
of everything that's going on I've zero like it's been on
hold because I had to do other stuff as well that's what i'm
saying i was so overworked and so overwhelmed this year um
that that had to bench a lot of stuff on hold um because of
it because i was just i just didn't have like the i didn't
have like the mental space or like the motivation to do a
lot of stuff because i was always like playing catch up like
i'm slowly getting better like 2026 is where like i start
locking in more like this year i'm still i feel like i'm
still like relaxing a little bit too um i did go outside the
last couple of days uh because i wanted to enjoy life a
little bit more i i want to try i think like in 2027 i do
want to travel more i want to get to a million subscribers
next year and then 2027 will be where i relax a bit more and
i want to start traveling i want to start traveling and like
meeting people in real life because i know like mint she
travels so much and she's always meeting people and she's
always doing stuff with people real life and everything and
i envy that a lot because like i also am like super paranoid
when it comes to traveling but i know like for her she's
like more outgoing about stuff like that and I want to I
want to start traveling more in 2027
I do have the street fighter tour I do in Japan I forgot
when is that because they haven't they haven't like told us
about I already forgot when that is I know I do I just
forgot when that is she asked me to go to she asked me well
she didn't ask me to go to holiday Missouri but like she
like I guess it's like implied like, oh, are you going like,
you know, like I said like an open invitation and I was
like, oh, no, no, no, I'm not going.
It was like a like a like a open like directly asked me, but
for holiday in Missouri, she like implied it like, do you
want to come?
Like, but I was like, no.
It was also like, cause like, you know, I was already super
busy too around that time and I wanted to like stay at home.
What else?
What else do I want to work for?
I think these are all like very feasible goals too.
Wait, when is the...
When is the...
The Japan trip, anyway, guys.
When is the Japan trip?
I never thought about voicing a video game.
I mean, if the opportunity ever presents itself.
I mean, I wouldn't say no to it.
I haven't got any...
I mean, I got offers for like...
Like, super indie stuff.
Um...
I haven't accepted any of them.
Um, only because it's like...
Uh...
Like, like, super, super indie.
Like, you know, like...
Like...
Like, 10...
Like, you know, like...
Very, very...
Very...
Like...
I don't know what's going on.
Oh yeah, no, the Pokemon MV, there was, it's out of my
hands.
It's literally because the 3D animator, like, personal life
got in the way for the 3D animator.
And I've always said, like, when it comes to, like, stuff
like that.
Yeah, it was like, it was like, the offers were sus, too.
Like, the, the voice acting brings to it.
So that's why I was like, oh, I don't, yeah, I mean, I'm
going to say, I'm not going to agree to this because it
feels pretty suspicious.
But yeah, like the reason why the Pokemon MV never got
published is because the 3D animator had, I don't know
what's going on.
I didn't pry about it because it's like their personal life.
So they just said that like personal life is in the way
right now, like getting in the way.
And because of that, I haven't got any updates on the
Pokemon.
MV but I'm not gonna rush it like you know you can't really
avoid personal life um so I think they like they basically
got another animator to work on it now but even then like
obviously like the final stuff is like up to them so it's
like whenever they're whatever whatever they're dealing with
personally personal life wise um um it'll be finished by for
it but that's why it's been like on hold for so fucking long
i feel really bad because like um you saw and got like uh
really annoyed at first about it because you're like what
the fuck is going on and i'm like i'm so sorry like it's
literally out of my hands so then they understand because
like i didn't tell i didn't update them about like what was
like because like i was like oh next time i got an update
i'll update you and obviously i didn't get an update so
they're like what the fuck like Like, is the music video
canceled?
Like, I felt really bad because I was like, I'm sorry.
The reason why I didn't update you is because, like, there
is no update.
But I understood after, like, I told them why.
A few more cherry goes to...
Oh, yeah.
The only thing is that there are some goals that...
Obviously, there might be some goals that I might not be
able to do anymore.
but I'll think of alternatives to it but I'll try and think
of alternatives to some of them new outfits?
Nope, there's always gonna be new outfits there's always
gonna be new outfits
um the thing is like um I will have I think everyone sort of
knows this because like you know my uh my rigor she's like
obviously super popular you know she's like she's like the
the most sought after youtuber uh rigor now so uh because of
that all of us i say this before it but all of us only has
like one new outfit per year now because she's not accepting
new clients still um she's not accepting new clients anymore
so it's just like building off of building off of what she
has now and because of that she only can take one new outfit
per year so that it's fair for everyone um and um but but
she told me that uh she gave me a uh she she's gonna give me
a list of people who are who she will allow to work on her
files because obviously you know um i wanted to be
comfortable because like she was like oh you can get someone
to rig your your skin suit with uh with new outfits if you
want to get more than one and i was like no no no it's fine
like i want to work i like obviously like it'll feel so
fucking weird too because like each um each person has their
own unique style especially you know cilia is mostly known
for her the mouth movements and everything so i don't want
to like you know i don't want to like it's so expressive and
everything so i didn't want to go through that route I'd
rather just, like, keep, at least keep the expressiveness.
And then she's going to, she's giving me a list of people
that she is comfortable with working on her files.
So they're just, like, they keep the face.
Mostly keep the face because it's her work.
And then they will work on, like, the hair and, like, the
outfits and stuff.
So I can get more than one outfit.
Because I've always, I want, you know, I like having lots of
new outfits.
um and i wanna i wanna be able to you know debut more than
one
i want to be able to debut more than one obviously um also
oh my gosh wait i said also oh i want to host an outfit
contest next year but let yeah i want to hope but like it's
basically all any outfits i want to make to an actual
official outfit.
Like, not like there's no first, second, and third.
I want to make it so that, like, any outfit that I want to
make an official outfit will get, like, prize.
Yeah, I want to host an outfit contest next year.
I want to, I've been wanting to do that.
I don't know about, I'll do a, so I definitely want to do
that for sure next year.
I want, I like seeing what you guys come up with.
Because we have a lot of really creative, talented dragons
here.
now now now I don't know what the prize would be though
obviously there'll be prize money but like I mean like what
how much how much I will be investing in it
um I only have any other goals I think those are some of the
stuff I want to aim for I don't want to have too many New
Year's resolution stuff because like then it'll be too much
to aim for.
Love, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hello, Doki.
This is my first donut.
The stream and streams this year were fun.
Thank you for everything.
It was my birthday on Christmas Eve.
Good luck with the goals.
Also, I got an electric guitar.
Ooh, that's fucking sick.
But thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I hope you had a great birthday.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear love.
Yeah.
Oh my gosh.
I am definitely...
I'm definitely crashing now.
I am sobering up really fast.
I'm energy going down.
Down.
I'm so impostered though.
I still want my pasta
Oh my god Fucking Oh guys you guys know why Okay okay
apparently The reason why Wait is this real Oh my god So the
reason why everyone led face clan is because Aiden Ross
fucking bot faceclad.
That's so funny.
That's why everyone fucking left.
Yeah.
Aiden Ross fucking bot faceclad today.
So there's like a lot of memories left.
That's fucking funny.
I was like wondering.
I was like, wow.
Aren't they all like super successful?
Or something?
Like they're like literally millionaires right now.
How old?
They're like fucking so young too.
And they're like I think like I honestly think like getting
rich really young fucks with you so much Like you don't
you're not like mature enough for that shit.
I feel like because you don't grow as a person
Yeah, they're like 22 That's fucking crazy.
They're like 20 to 22 years old and they're literally
millionaires.
Yeah I think like You should start a podcast.
I'm so bad at podcasting.
I'd rather just be the guest.
FaceBank submits on Twitter to Viewbot.
Bro, you know why people Viewbot?
Like, this is, okay, other than being at the top of the
page, but like, by sponsors pay, I don't know if I talked
about this before, but sponsors pay per 100 CCV usually so
it's like it's usually like x amount of money per 100 ccv so
that's why people viewbot because they're like they only
look at ccb you know like okay i'm gonna i'm gonna it's not
really a leak but i helped some devs to not get scammed for
rivals i helped the rivals devs to not get scammed because
they were accidentally sponsoring viewbotters in the marvel
rivals category and i was I told them I was like bro that
person's a viewbotter like and they're like but they have so
many views and I'm like yeah but look at the chat
interactions it barely moves and like you can literally
check them out on Twitch tracker and see like they just
gained like a million followers within like a month and then
nothing like barely anything after that so like um and the
thing is they they this is like a regular thing sponsors
don't look past numbers uh they don't fucking look past
numbers they barely like they don't really like research uh
because it's like they sponsors go through bro usually go
through brokers so like brokers they don't want to do the
research on like who they're sponsoring so they're broke
they just go through brokers and just be like i want to get
these people and the brokers would just be like oh these
people have these views you want to get them and they're
like yeah okay we pay x amount of money per 100 ccv so
people a lot of streamers now they view bot so they can get
more they get bigger payouts and everything and i remember i
told you guys how like um a big stream they actually leaked
a big streamer rates to me so i fucking know how much people
get paid if they have like 40k plus like viewers if they
have 40 000 plus viewers i know exactly how much they get
It's crazy.
It's a fucking crazy amount.
Compared to what I get paid for, like, the CCV I have.
And that's why people view by it.
Because, like, they can, they can, like, scam the sponsors.
Like, so they can, like, paid.
It's, like, good investment for them.
Because they literally can get paid insane amounts of money
for, like, lying about their CCVs.
Yeah, it's like a little it's a little infinite money
glitch.
So that's why like because like face clan I won't be
surprised they get sponsored a lot and because they get
sponsored a lot They get paid a lot of fucking money for
like the amount for just because they have to match the CCV
They have to be like X amount like you date their their
policy is that X month X amount of money for X for a hundred
CCV um it's it's legal because like how you they don't
really know you're getting viewbotter now but yeah i helped
the marvel rivals devs figure out who was a viewbotter or
not because i was like you're wasting your money like like
you're wasting your money like that this like this person or
that person is clearly viewbotting like you're not getting
what your their monies were yeah it's really like a fraction
of the cost that's why that's why twitch was like so strict
about cutting numbers like how everyone was saying like i
can't believe Twitch, like, fucked up my numbers or some
shit like that, which is understandable because it's
literally your livelihood and everything.
But Twitch had to double it down because sponsors and
advertisement, like, advertisers were getting really fucking
mad about it because they felt like they were getting
scammed.
Because they're like, wait, I'm not getting my monies worth
advertising to these, to these, like, sponsoring these
streamers because it feels like their numbers are way often
what they actually are because a lot of them are viewbotting
and it's crazy the gap like even getting like if they are
like a big number of streamers um like they're like you know
even like they are like 20k ccv and if you bought 10k the
amount of money you get between 10k to to 20k is a huge gap
as someone that has seen how much like people get paid for
their sponsors A fucking huge gap between it.
Like you get, it's like actual like crazy amount of money.
Uh, fake view bots are like fake viewers, viewers.
So it's like, uh, yeah, you're using a software to like
inflate your numbers.
That's why Twitch has to go really hard on it.
Because like sponsors were getting really fucking mad about
it.
Because it's on Twitch too.
Because like, because sponsors were getting mad.
But all they could do is blame Twitch.
They can't really blame the streamers.
because they're like you let this happen on this platform
yeah and now the numbers are super deflated because they
went super fucking hard on it too that's why like uh that's
why people on kick kick also view like apparently like kick
has lesser moderation for viewbotting so like but that's why
you see like for kick streamers they like viewbot so hard
because it's just good payday
no viewbotting is everywhere It's not like, nobody is safe
from you, budding.
Bro, I recently found out that I didn't even realize this,
but the creator of Kik, Kik, because I was like, how the
fuck is he able to afford all these sponsors, you know?
Like, able to afford all these contracts with big-ass
streamers, but the creator of Kik literally created Stake,
the fucking gambling website.
You know, like, when you see the memes and stuff, it's like,
sponsored by Stake.
It's literally, they're It's literally sponsored by like the
online gambling website.
Yeah, I recently found that out.
Because I was like, how the fuck is he able to afford
contracts with all these like John ass streamers?
It's just used.
Yeah, it's literally just used to promote steak.
Yeah.
Why is Kick treated like Chicago streaming?
Because people can drive while streaming on Kick.
murder i mean they do get banned but like but like
surprisingly very fucked up but um a lot of a lot of like
dangerous things happen on like because like it's less
regulations like i said it's less regulations this is my
biggest peppy people who stream themselves driving and it's
very common on kick it's also it's also happens on twitch
and this is what i also really don't like about it um i
don't know i don't think i don't know if youtube also
regulates this because i don't see this happening on youtube
quite often or i don't haven't seen it happen at all on
youtube but um i don't like how people how moderation for
people driving while streaming is very loose and I've seen
it happen on Twitch and but I've seen it happen a lot on
kick like it's like the thing like the thing people just
stream themselves driving because there's no regulations for
it it's like literally texting while driving but worse I
think texting while driving is safer than streaming while
driving because you're literally reading chat you're fucking
reading chat while you're fucking driving you're not paying
attention to the road and that is so scary
yeah like yeah you're not texting while driving but you're
literally reading while driving like reading and trying to
entertain an audience while driving it's so much more
dangerous and yet it's not right like there it is not
regulated and that's what peeves me the most and there's so
many fucking car crashes because of streaming
Yeah.
Why do people watch someone drive anyway?
It's IRL.
It's because, like, it's not the it's not the driving,
watching someone while driving.
It's the interactions.
Like, where they're going, the interactions and everything.
It's a 4, it's IRL, basically.
Because IRL is just living vicariously off of the streamer.
More often.
Because, you know, they're doing all these cool things and
you're, like, you have to have a glimpse of, like, what that
life is like it's also why it's it's like it's like vlogging
it's like basically that's why vlogging channels were so
popular back then but rl streaming is literally like the
live version of vlogging um but it's like how oh my god i
hate family channels like you know like those like like
family channels where they exploit their kids and like that
is like it's similar to that like people live vicariously
through the family and being like oh like i wish my family
was like this and i so and and they do like these things but
I feel that uh I feel like it's I hate the exploitation of
children yeah those are so bad I recently was watching it it
popped up on my short but there was this like lady there was
this lady who was like whole thing is that she adopted she
has 12 kids and half of them are adopted um and like but
then like it felt weird it felt so weird because she took
them like barely and it was like snowing really hard and um
and like it's it looked really cold and then she was just
like they were just like all standing out there in the snow
waiting for their photos yeah and i was like that is so
fucking weird like i was like that fucking i was like bro
fucking why are you why are you making them all standing up
in the open and stuff and everything like It's so weird and
and I read about it apparently like she's it's like super
exploitative too because like She's just using them for
content and stuff
Just like Timmy and Yumi on Doki.
No, that's different guys
That's that's different guys They are not children Timmy and
Yumi are adults So it's not exploited.
Caught.
Don't.
That's it to me.
They're not here right now.
To me.
It's different.
Okay.
You're going to call the cops for yourself.
They won't believe you.
Juge, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Good morning, Doki.
I'm stuck in isolation with flu right now.
So thank you to all.
to you and all the dragons are keeping me company.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
And be the Toki where children's situation is crazy.
But yeah, no.
I don't know.
I'm just not a fan of shit like that.
It's like oh my god.
And also people who like There's so many things that drives
my gears.
But, but yeah, like, I just think, like, I just think
driving while streaming should be outright, uh, forever,
Ben.
I wish, I feel like, I think it's because, like, politicians
don't know yet, you know, because they're not hip with the
kids, how fucking bad it is now.
Um, that's why there's no rules against it.
Because, like, you know, the moment texting and driving is,
is illegal.
Using your phone and everything is super illegal because
everyone knows about it.
I think we just gotta wait a couple more years until it's
actually bad, bad.
Also, like, I hate how everyone just rage baits now.
Okay, I'll tell you guys this.
There's a reason why I don't...
I know there's, like, people who, like, be like, what's your
opinion on this?
What's your opinion on this on, like, things that are super
controversial, especially in the content creation sphere?
I usually don't respond to it.
I know you should just ignore it because the thing is this
is what I hate about it too but like it's what it gets you
it's basically what gets you seen nowadays it's engagement
baiting it's engagement baiting and rage baiting and it's
like the meta now in the content creation not I mean not
really in the v-tubing sphere but more so in the general
content creation sphere you guys want to know why all these
like really big content creators are always being like to
everything or like or like reacting to stuff or being like
putting inserting themselves in something that they're not
really involved with but they want to give their opinion on
because that's engagement baiting and because of that um it
puts you them in the forefront because you talk about them
you talk about these streamers you talk about what they're
saying you talk you put them out you you make them relevant
again because and it works
loads that shit it literally yeah it literally makes them
money and they click farm and everything it's just what it's
just what works and like that's why like I don't I don't
normally like you know I see people asking my opinion and
stuff or asking like oh and I don't I don't play to it even
though I know if I did it would it will boost my numbers it
will like it will like get me people talk about me but I
personally don't think for me my mental health and also like
my I guess I guess I don't know I don't have integrity is
the right word I just don't feel comfortable with that shit
because like I just want I don't want to fucking do that
like I have made comments or like responded things but only
when it really has something to do with me if I'm like
personally you know obviously I would make a response or
like if it's something we're like or if it's something like
you know I felt very heavily relate to it then I will make a
response but if it's something where I know it's like clip
farming engagement baiting rage baiting shit like that like
I tend to not I tend to just ignore it uh but that's what a
lot of content creators do now everyone's just rage baiting
engagement baiting clip farming and everything because it
makes you It makes people talk about you and like it spreads
your name everywhere And then you don't forget about these
people because of it And it works, it makes them a lot of
money That's streaming meta now And it's, you know That's
why a lot of these content creators are also They haven't
fallen off, you know Because that's the scary thing about
content creation That's something I'm always afraid of
falling off That's why I'd like this next year Next year I'm
focusing more on rebuilding my brand building but you know
keeping expanding my brand um and uh expanding my brand and
like you know building myself up more and uh putting myself
out there more uh and uh and stuff like that but it does
work for those people but it's like everywhere it's like
it's like the new meta now and it's but like i said that's
what makes like these big content creators like the really
really big ones that's if it feels like you know they're too
big to fail type deal because they are they are because they
they know the meta which is like just continuing to put
themselves in the forefront and making people talk about
them because it like i said it fucking works
no i also agree like it also like creates a community that's
also like it's not a community that i want to foster
Once you become too toxic, nobody wants...
That is not true.
In the content creation circle, unfortunately.
I know it's like, oh, the real world, like, you don't want
to associate...
That...
In the content creation circle, that's not really that true.
As long as you have the numbers, someone will hang out with
you.
It's like It's literally that
It's sad but true Yeah Oh my I haven't heard anything about
Royce coming so a lot But it's also because like Like Also
because Doesn't he like not have the numbers anymore
Or I think he was super chat Thank you thank you It's over
for you I've already portrayed me you're it's the pet
defensive monkey and you has the angry leopard rage bait is
up like thank you miss super chat thank you thank you yeah
i'm also like the internet is a scary place where one day is
one internet day like actually one day for like real life is
like is like a week on the internet
bro oh someone wait someone talking about beauty pie bro
PewDiePie lived the most optimal content creator dream he
made it and then he fucking made it so hard that like his
kids kids kids will still live um will still live through
his what he made during his career and he he fucking just
retired he's like technically semi-retired And like, he has
a hot wife.
And a hot, talented, creative wife, by the way.
And he has a talented son who is at least four.
He knows four fucking languages at least.
Because his wife is Italian.
He is Swedish.
They're living in Japan.
And they speak English.
like bro his son is gonna be so fucking smart I think a lot
of people forgot PewDiePie was studying to be a fucking
engineer like this guy literally built his own AI system
because he was boy like
he's yeah he's literally baby maxing
language yeah that's crazy yeah
I respect the hustle that's what I'm saying he's literally
like lived the perfect well not perfect obviously he has had
a few controversies but you know what I mean his like
journey to the end like from beginning to end and he yeah
yeah like no one's perfect in content creation like if you
are then you're literally a fucking you're literally a
fucking test tube baby grown by the government and this was
your goal if you are actually a perfect content creator
because we're all human we all make mistakes um yeah um yeah
and like but like at the end at the end he got to like like
do everything like you know he gets to be semi retired and
just live his life right after and he's only like what like
early 30s that's the crazy part wait yeah he oh wait he's
like mid 30s he's 36 and he's already like doing whatever
the fuck he wants now how he's 36 now he's 36 oh my god
you're like air enhancers like in his 40s now I'm pretty
sure Yeah, he's like 38 Aaron Hansen is 38 I know Danny is
like in his 40 Like 40 50s
Yeah, he's literally PewDiePie is just doing fucking Side
quests Every day He's like just doing side quests He doesn't
have to grind for anything Honestly He doesn't have to grind
for anything anymore He's just doing whatever the fuck he
wants and what he and like gaining life experience which is
good for him that's something I want to do that's like
something I want to do in 2027 um and it's that like also
like recently I read a quote being like you should
experience the world more and travel more when you're young
versus doing that working all the way till you're like much
older and not being able to experience that type of
experiences that you could experience when you're younger
and like that like really really hard for me because i've
been like grinding a lot like the last couple of years i've
always been like very sheltered so i didn't get to like i
did get to travel with my parents when i was like really
really young but it was like it was like my parents
vacations my parents trips and everything not like what i
wanted to do or what i where i wanted to go or what what i
wanted to like explore and i want to travel more in 2027 i
want to like experience the world more that's in 2026 and
2027 relax a bit more and like do traveling stuff.
Maybe like collab with, do off collabs and stuff too.
Yeah.
Boiton Rex, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
By the way, Hytale is going to release in January.
Thank you for dipping your toes on content when it first
comes out.
Is that the one with the by X respawn people?
Is that the game?
Is that the hero shooter?
Thank you for the thousand biddies thank you thank you i
really appreciate it though thank you um hsp thank you for
the super chat thank you thank you oh it's hightail the oh
that's high guard oh sorry sorry they both start oh it's the
minecraft rpg as a parkour civilization streamer privilege
fun thank you for the super chat thank you thank you oh
that's the minecraft i didn't know anything about the
minecraft sandbox thing but people were like freaking out
about it because like i don't um sorry but uh i heard
everyone was like freaking out like what was freaking out
about i don't mind trying it i know a lot of people were
were like like really happy about it um i reminded me when i
what was it called the one there was a kickstarter where it
was a similar concept where it was like rpg minecraft and
then they like it never they like never did anything with it
ever i even and everything.
That was so sad because they didn't really do anything with
it and, like, ruined the game, too.
Because the early access was so good.
It was, like, it was like a Minecraft RPG thing.
But, like, Indy.
It was so long ago.
Cube World!
Fuck Cube World!
It was the very first project I've ever kick-started, and I
had to beg my mom to use her credit card to kick-start that
fucking game.
Because I didn't have a PayPal yet.
Fuck Cube World.
Because I was like, because my friend.
Also, fuck my friend for fucking making me play Cube World.
Like, yeah, I was one of the OG Kickstarter backers.
So one of my friends was like, you gotta check out Cube
World.
It's so fun.
And so I was playing Cube World with my friend.
like wait does this so much like yeah they have a kickstart
and everything and look at these rewards you could get so i
was like oh i'll back it and i begged my mom if i could like
if i could like use her um because it was it was so fucking
fun in beta so i bet because i wanted the i wanted the
exclusive like the i don't remember what reward it was and
then i begged my mom for it and she's like okay you can i'll
back it for you and then it was just just and then it was
just disappointment after disappointment after
disappointment because they first fucking um Oh, I'm like,
fuck you world.
I...
But it's hard.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm so...
It was so good in beta.
And then they fucking changed everything.
For no fucking reason.
Like...
Bro.
Like the beta was so...
And then they're like, they're like, Wow, everyone seems to
love the beta.
You know what?
Let's change.
everything about the fucking game yeah no
that like yeah I'm no longer epi I'm no longer epi that that
shit made me like remembering that made me so fucking angry
literally the very first game I've ever kickstarted the very
first thing I ever kickstarted
that's crazy it that's fucking crazy I was so fucking
disappointed it gave me a second win it almost did guys but
i'm trying to be realistic here
no it wasn't a cash grab it was literally like it was like
procedural gender it was literally procedural generated so
like everything like everyone's um instance in cube world
was unique
And like, it was very fun.
Like, you could play with your friends and everything.
There was multiplayer, and you could play with your friends.
And like, because Acupra was like a really, really, it was
like an old game and everything.
And like, but still, the multiplayer was actually really
good.
No, I've not played Warframe.
I know a lot of people have been talking about Warframe
lately because it's been happening.
It's getting a resurgence lately.
I did play, I remember playing Destiny.
I did enjoy Destiny for a bit.
I only stopped playing because it got way too Like I I
played for a bit But it just felt way too granny because I
literally Couldn't do PvP because I had the shittiest
Fucking guns so it just like wasn't fun For me Um in the end
And I know Like Warframe is getting like a sudden resurgence
Again why is Warframe getting A resurgence lately
Huge new update
Oh Oh, new content.
Oh, oh, because they went hard on sponsoring people.
I mean, yeah, it's always Rick's, yeah.
New update has pretty women.
Yeah, because, like, because Warframe's been around.
I don't know.
I don't know which one's been around longer, Destiny or
Warframe.
But Warframe's been around for a while now.
So I was, like, so curious why, like, everyone's talking,
like, everybody's talking about it again.
Like, I saw a lot of VTubers are fucking streaming it now.
So I was like, what's going on?
Yeah.
Because it's always been, like, Warframe versus Destiny.
But, like, Destiny is falling off now.
And then Warframe's coming.
Because, like, Destiny would be the one that's being, like,
being talked by everyone.
In terms of, also, like, I know, like, Twitch does a lot of
things with Destiny as well.
When it comes to, like, Twitch rivals and sponsors and
stuff.
stuff and it's up this year warframe just suddenly like it's
like everyone's talking about warframe now i was so confused
because i was like they both it's always been like you know
like the console wars you know like it's like destiny versus
warframe and stuff like that so that's why i was like oh how
did warframe came back
oh man they give a super chat thank you thank you Warframe
is Much better than Destiny I see that someone almost 4k
hours in Destiny 2 I also remember dancing When you did 10
When you did 10 Yeah cause you're fucking Grinding guns
I remember doing very well In the PvP modes Even with the
shitty guns I had Cause I had that aim I
the more framed devs constantly deliver regarding updates
box they use super chat thank you thank you that makes sense
i mean as long as the oh wait as long as the um the devs
treat their community well you know it always go be what go
well also that reminded me of that the game awards i forgot
which dev was it was it bouldersgate oh yeah they won the
award for like most best supportive some shit and then
literally a couple of days later the entire community turned
against boulderscape because they admitted they used ai or
something was it that i thought that was really funny
because they literally just won like you know best
supportive community yeah yeah and then they're like fucking
hate you like the guy feels like i fucking hate you
boulderscape fuck you I was like, what the fuck?
Like right after they won, too.
Yeah,
they used AI as a foundation, but it, it's, you know, AI is
such a controversial topic to talk about sometimes.
understand and it it does suck because it does take away
jobs from like real people but I feel like it's unavoidable
now like I know a lot of people are fighting about it and
everything but capitalism will always win I know it's like
it's companies will always go for the cheapest route wrong
i feel like companies will will always go for whatever
whatever is the cheapest route when it comes to like when it
comes to like what can we do cheaper it fucking sucks it
really does I think, like, I...
I love...
Okay, here's one of something.
I love Professor Layden.
It is...
One of my favorite...
It is literally my...
I would rank it as number one.
Um...
Number one of my favorite game ever.
Because it gave me so much love and passion.
Over the characters, the stories, and everything.
Level 5 now uses AI for almost every game they develop.
And they really...
They released, like...
They released like a little a document About like everything
they do with AI And like they even show like here's Here's
like they literally use it for like concept art and
everything To like conceptualize everything and then get
real artists to draw the concept art out But like yeah it's
crazy it's like I'll show you guys the tweet I was like oh
my god I was like I'm just like of them are really funny
though the concept art like it was pretty funny but still
i'm just like oh my god but they're very open about it too
they're very fucking open about using it
here but yeah i would always be like a super controversial
topic to talk about
i just think i my opinion is that i think it's obviously
like it's that it takes away like you know jobs from real
human beings and stuff it's like how like people always be
like to like uh what is it called to like what does jobs
call like working in retail and everything retail and fast
food they'll be like robots will replace you ai's will
replace you and shit like that you know that's obviously
that fucking sucks you know yeah it just the only thing i
like about ai is when ai was first started and people would
just make funny out of it like like the ash baby ash baby i
talked to her before the only thing i was that i that i used
to i i mean i won't say used i guess used to because now
it's just too much but like like maybe was fucking hilarious
and also the fact that parents are using AI to trick their
kids that Santa is real like I I'm sorry I just don't feel
like that's fucked okay but for me that's fucking hilarious
because I would do that if I had if I have a kid I would use
AI to make Santa like I would be like kids oh my god Santa
was just like in our house like and then I fucking AI
generated Santa a christmas tree and be like oh my god kids
and then they will believe that's so funny
you're evil
okay you know what okay and people okay it's really fun when
people make like ai videos that are like super like seem
really realistic but when people made that fucking ai video
of a cat holding a gun and going pop pop like a machine gun
i'm sorry that actually got me i like i wish people use ai
to make stupid like that like because like that's good
that's actually funny but like people don't do that people
like use ai to do like dumbass like fucking i hate like the
other The one with the artillery gun.
Like, she was like, there's a cow with a gun on the
doorstep.
And then, like, the cat started fucking shooting rounds on a
cat.
And I was like, okay, that's actually pretty funny.
Like, it was just stupid fucking memes.
That's fine.
Like...
I didn't know there'd be more regulations in the future.
It's because AI is still new.
That's why.
AI is still new and everything.
But...
It'll get regulated later because other like everything gets
regulated in the end
Uh, my name thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you Call it now when the ai bubble pops the free
market capitalist will cry to government to force taxpayers
to cover their losses Thank you the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you There's something that I'm gonna say something I
want to talk about but I remember
I'm trying to remember right now I'm using like There's not
much of my brain left But I'm trying my best to use like At
least like 1% of it I'm trying There's something I want to
talk about I'm trying to remember It's not going so well
though Memes songs There are some Some songs I didn't
realize were AI generated.
That shit is scary though.
They were like some fucking funny songs.
What was it?
It was like something, it was like a country related song
that was like really popular in like during the YouTube
shorts slash TikToks.
And then like I recently found out it was actually like AI
generated.
I was like, what?
Oh, it was so funny too.
I'm trying to remember what song it was.
It was like some country related song.
that was like that kept popping up on my youtube shorts for
a while
but it's like very scary because they can like replicate
like that's what i'm saying ai is getting more and more
regulated because like music artists were like bro that's
not cool but yes people were like um same with like sora ai
sora where like a lot of some companies started um uh
started sending like cease and desist letters for sora ai
because they're using their stuff and also uh and also for
like uh for like music artists when it came to like ai music
yeah because they're like they're that's my voice you can't
do that
bro you know what i hate the most they've like corrupted my
youtube shorts they'll ai generate reddit stories like fake
reddit stories and then put put it over like ai generate
like those like ADHD like videos and sub where they're like
you know like oh this like this oh my gosh those are and
like the AI post the Reddit post would be like like read oh
the alien AI reading over an AI generated Reddit fake Reddit
post and then putting that over an AI generated video of
like a like like random fucking videos like it's so fucking
weird like it like i i already fixed my youtube algorithm
for my shorts but it kept popping up for a while but like i
have to like force force feed my youtube algorithm like
non-slop to fix it oh my god speaking of ai also like i i
sort of want to do a parody of it has anyone got like on
youtube like when they're scrolling through youtube shorts
um there would be like these like gaming live streams where
it's like if you super chat me i'll wake up and it's
literally an in ai generated clip of this girl sleeping on
her chair like this like it's like this gaming room and it's
like an ai generated clip loop clip of this girl sleeping on
her chair and every time she wakes up she'll be like oh um
thank you for the super chat but i'm not gonna wake up yet
and she goes by it's like and it like plays over like roblox
clips i swear to god like yes and it's not even a real woman
it's like ai generated women too it's so fucking weird it's
yeah and then I would see like how many people are watching
this and it'd be like 400 to 700 viewers and like what the
it's like they're money and subscribers off of people too
because then I'll be like subscribe and maybe I'll wake up
and she'll be like oh thank you for subscribing and I'm like
and it's just a Roblox clip dude she's like fucking out of
play Roblox or a fucking mine or some shit
literally passive income yeah Yeah, no, people have donated.
I literally see it happen too.
Brother, they do, okay, another one.
There was another one too, not just like the fucking,
they'll be like, oh, um, uh, there was like so many
Minecraft ones, because the thing is, they would sell, they
were trying to get subscribers.
They're trying to like, fucking be like, oh, um, don't, uh,
don't subscribe.
Don't subscribe.
We're like, um, they'll be playing trying to like make a
build or some shit and then subscribing will kill them or
something so they'll be like don't subscribe guys don't
subscribe oh why didn't you subscribe but it loops too like
it's not even like like the dialogue fucking loops and
everything it's like guys why are you subscribing it's so
fucking weird and then they get to like some i guess some
like amount or some shit and then and then they like sell
the account off it's so fucking weird
it's like oh my god it's so fucking weird no but the fucking
girls sleeping shit like i don't know i guess it's like they
can't get a real like they can't get a real woman to like
fucking do it but it's just it's so fucking weird to be like
It's like, subscribe, oh, oh, subscribe and I'll maybe wake
up.
Oh, thanks for subscribing.
I'm still going to go back to sleep.
I want to link you guys that video, but I sort of don't want
to give that video.
Like, there's so many.
The thing is, like, there's so many of them.
It's not even from, like, one person.
users like creators that do it too and like i would always
like i'd like like it won't happen often but like i would
just be scrolling youtube shorts and it'll just pop up yeah
you might find in your algorithm if you scroll enough uh
bungalow they give it to your one-so they can thank you yeah
but lisa and tick-tock mpc were real women like or men too
like the Miles Morales NPC shit.
They were real people.
It's not even real people.
It's all AI.
Oh, yeah.
Did you guys see the...
Oh, so that just reminded me.
Also, a lot of thank you was super chat.
Thank you.
That just reminded me that there was this, like, kid that
was like, stop saying 6-7.
It's not funny.
Stop it.
And it was like this kid.
And he was getting popular because people thought it was
like pretty fun like i didn't watch it i didn't really find
the humor in it but i guess it's like ironic humor um and
then he was like re he was like now i react i'm gonna react
to my most famous video now he literally like uploaded a
video be like i'm gonna react to my most famous video and
then like i think like a couple of days ago he fucking
uploaded another video like i think it was like a day
yesterday or a day before and he was like guys my my stop
saying video is now minted as an NFT.
And then he turned off comments.
Yeah, he's like this child, by the way.
I'm pretty sure he's like eight or something.
And he's like, you even like, he's like eight years old.
And he's like, and he's like doing like some Fortnite that's
like, guys, my, it's now minted now.
You could now get it as an NFT.
And I'm like, what the?
Fuck I'd probably kill this career before it could actually
happen Yeah It always goes back to NFTs somehow And then the
The thing is He fucking He's like six or seven years The
thing is He's He like turned off the comments on that video
too Like he knew what the fuck was gonna happen He had sold
out before Yeah he fucking or sold out
And that was fucking crazy.
Oh my god, it wasn't even an NFT.
He literally made a fucking cryptocurrency.
I forgot.
It wasn't even an NFT.
He made the fucking meme coin.
It wasn't an NFT, guys.
It was a fucking, he fucking, he did the Hawk Tour shit.
Where he fucking made the meme of Bitcoin, like
cryptocurrency.
And then, oh wait, this is my favorite part too.
Also, Melly, thank you for the red.
Thank you, thank you.
We had a great stream.
Thank you so much.
And a great Christmas, too.
Wait, I have to see.
Okay, I need to find it.
Like, the description was so funny.
I thought the description was fucking hilarious.
Because I'm like, this kid does not know what the fuck is
going on.
Um.
Okay.
Let me...
Okay, it's really...
He's like, yo, guys.
My pump fun token is here.
here for the Roblox community.
And I was like, kid, no Roblox kid is going to fucking
invest in your cryptocurrency.
I do not think these children know what it is.
I do not think these Roblox children know what a
cryptocurrency is, child.
I, he's like, he's like shilling into his Roblox community.
And I'm like, oh, you poor child.
know what's happening to you yep it
was even in my out okay it was it was on my twitter i told
you my twitter algorithm is very special no yeah i think
yeah crypto is definitely oh yeah bro did you guys see the
okay speaking of like pump and dump scheme did you see the
newest logan paul pump and dump scheme i don't know
understand how it's like you fell for it again i know it's
not How people keep falling for it again is actually like at
that point is is actually like impressive that it keeps
happening So and then I'll give you guys an update for those
who aren't terminally online Um, like I said, I'm terminally
online, but like it I am the power to my algorithm So like
some things I don't know because it's not on my algorithm So
I'm terminally online and a lot of other stuff so My fate is
controlled by my algorithm but the newest the newest like
pump and dump scheme that he did is that he went to like I
don't know what channel it is but it's like a famous
investing channel like actual like news channel for
investing he was like telling people like yeah Pokemon cards
are the next best investment in anything it's better than
stock market like ever since I started investing in Pokemon
cards like it has like double triple and whatever earn in
stock market like is what you have to do and then because
and he was like i am going to sell the most expect my most
surprised uh pokemon card um like a psa 10 like card and uh
yeah he did like a tv interview about with like the stock
like this like investment channel yeah and he's like it's
like 5.3 million pikachu card and it's like the most one
most expensive cards out there like literally like he got a
world record for buying the most fucking expensive card out
there he's like um and he's like um it's gonna go on auction
and and then he was like but and then the thing is um the
Pikachu card was on his website for the auction and in order
to be eligible to bid on the card you have to exchange your
real money for this fucking random made up money on his
website and apparently uh to the pump and dump is that when
people exchange their real money for this imaginary money on
this auction site they were not getting the their imaginary
money even though the payment went through and then to make
a tween be like yeah we had some issues like i'm talking to
the i'm talking right now to the organizers of the auction i
was not aware that this was going to happen or like it's
going to be this like poorly organized and then he got
community noted and was like logan paul is one of the
co-founders of this website
i like he loves like the community he's like he is one of
the co-founders of this website what the fuck do you mean he
didn't know what was going on like yeah because he literally
and then you click on the community note of where of where
the reference leads you like where they got their like
source from it's literally logan pa because you'd be like
guys i co-founded this website that's the source he
literally tweeted out that he is one of the like source is
literally him like
Vox thank you for the super chat thank you thank you won't
don't you wake up
yeah community note has been a great addition to twitter
despite everything else all the other shit is not great but
bro my twitter has been like fucking up in terms of like i
don't know if anyone's been like searching stuff on twitter
but sometimes they pull up i don't know if like i think
there's something around the servers but they'll pull up
like old stuff even though I'm going by recent even when I'm
scrolling down it'll pull like super old shit and that's
when like I'm searching stuff on Twitter.
I don't know if it's just me but I feel like it's I feel
like I don't know if it's happening to everyone else also I
like how someone's like both Jake and Logan are so dumb.
Bro Jake there's a reason why Jake is very dumb right now
bro this guy is doing boxing
I'm I think he's lost like 70% of his brain cells like and
like a 30% already lost like 30% of that like from the last
match He didn't have a lot starting to be fair, but like
it's definitely gotten worse Yeah, I know so I was like
yeah, but he was dumb before yeah, but like now he's like
actually like Medically he people are surprised that he's
still going Like, I feel like medical professionals right
now are like, how is this guy still going right now?
Like, Megley speaking, there is concerns.
You are the lab, but not actually living.
Oh my god.
We hit...
Wait, we hit 11 hours!
yeah we did it everyone all right i'm gonna we're gonna
segue now we're gonna segue guys because it is two in the
morning now and um thank you everyone thank you everyone for
coming um to my stream thank you everyone coming to
celebrate christmas and the holidays with me um i really did
have had a great time with all of you guys and um for
everyone that you know coming in and out dropping in
dropping out because it is the holidays um i hope you guys
had a great stream with me and the dragons today um thank
you everyone for being there for my first multi-stream
officially um i'm definitely It's not going to be a common
thing.
But maybe for special events like this.
Because I knew today was a very special day.
I wanted to keep a lot of like dragoons.
Maybe you're not even a dragoon.
I want to keep a lot of people company today.
Because I know like, you know, spending holidays alone isn't
fun.
And I wanted to, you know, help those who, you know, might
need some extra cheering up today for the holidays.
And it really, it cheered me up as well too.
It really did help me out a lot as well.
because I'm spending time with you guys always makes me
really happy.
Like I said, whenever I get sad, I was the first thing I
think of is like, I should stream because whenever I stream,
I get happy because I get to interact with you guys.
It's very fun interacting with you guys, too.
Goodbye, Timmy.
Goodbye, Jimmy.
I'm back to the cage, Timmy.
Guys, stop fighting.
I thought you guys are friends.
what happened but um I definitely had a great time and I
hope you guys I hope you guys had a great Christmas a great
Christmas Eve a great holiday um today and thank you all for
the subscribers the subs the follows uh the bitties the
supas like all of that thank you guys thank you I couldn't
do it all this about your support and that's what makes me
keep going because you know you guys are supporting me to
keep going with content creation and um i always want to
give back to you guys too because you know i can't do this
without you guys um those who are new here my name is
dokeybird i for the twitch people i usually stream on
youtube so please check me out on youtube um that's where my
main channel is that's where my main content is um anyone
support me uh if you want to know whenever I go live on
Twitch feel free to follow me on Twitter because that is
where I tweet out about whenever I go live on Twitter for
tomorrow's stream I might push in an hour back because I
need a rest and I really wanted to have pasta really wanting
pasta right now um I wanted to make it but you know what I
mean um and um you want to support me other means I do have
a merch store So please feel free to check out my merch
store.
It is a great way to support me and my stream as well.
And I have a lot of doggy shirts I need to fucking get rid
of.
So you have a dog and you want to dress them up in a silly
Hawaiian shirt made for dogs.
It will help me a lot because I might have overestimated the
demand for Hawaiian dog shirts.
Or a cat.
It works on cats too.
and also um i do have a lot of stuff i do have uh i know
like i have a lot of like exclamation points there so you
can use all the other explanation points um i do want to say
like thank you for spending time with me too um um it does
mean a lot um and i had a great time spending it with you
guys as well i hope you all have a wonderful holiday i look
forward to celebrate to end 2025 with all you guys and also
kickstart 2026 with you guys as well otherwise i'm gonna
head off now it's very late and i'm tired and i want my
pasta so as always everybody stay hydrated posture check get
up and move around to get that blood flowing and if you stay
up for me head to bed cause you deserve it I'll see you guys
next time everybody bye guys bye for those who are wondering
if I'm gonna raid anyone I'm just gonna free you guys I'm
too tired to figure out who to raid so disperse naturally
bye bye everyone bye